Hallo, Stefan.
Wie geht's Deutschland?
Wir sind jetzt in Deutschland an der Kante von Sein zum Vergehen angekommen.
Ich hab jetzt das Intro darüber gegrübelt, wer hier ist und wer vergeht.
Ist das ein Zitat von Auswahl Spengler oder vom Schrauben-Milliardär Reinhold Wirth?
Oh, ich kann es nicht sagen.
Der hat ein Interview der Augsburger Zeitung gegeben und ist tief besorgt. Wirk-Live-Balance, ein großes Problem. Denn er sagt, die Wirk-Live-Balance wurde immer mehr in Richtung Live-Balance verschoben.
Dramatisch.
Er macht sich große Sorgen. Er sagt, es sei Angst und Bange um Deutschland. In anderen Ländern wird bei deutlich niedrigeren Stundenlöhnen länger gearbeitet. Und wir werden immer fauler im Prinzip. Das liegt auch daran, dass die jungen Beschäftigten fast nicht mehr zu bewegen sind, weil die der Generation der Babyboomer entstammen. Und die wurden wahnsinnig verwöhnt. Und jetzt sind die jungen Leute auch verwöhnt. Und deshalb ist unser Land an der Kante vom Sein zum Vergehen angekommen. Der Schraubenmilliardär kann auch Reichenbesteuerung, all das nicht verstehen. Denn er arbeitet jeden Tag seit 75 Jahren. Und wie kann man da sich eigentlich anmaßen? Und das wurde medial ja groß breit getreten. Mit viel Zustimmung dann auch interessanterweise. Wo man ja auch so denken müsste, wenn man als Journalist darüber schreibt, gibt es vielleicht einen Unterschied, ob ich mit meinem Unternehmen Milliardär werde oder ob ich einfach länger arbeite und weniger verdiene. Ist da vielleicht eine Differenz da? Meilschberger, die ja für mich die schlimmste von allen ist, hat ja auch noch Uschi Claas ins Interview gebeten. Und Uschi Claas macht sich auch große Sorgen. Vieles in diesem Land. Auch über die Arbeitsmoral. Also sie können schon verstehen, bei manchen Berufen sei das vielleicht so, dass man die nicht ewig machen kann. Aber sie können das nicht verstehen, dass die Leute aufhören wollen zu arbeiten. Sie sei ja 82 und freut sich, wenn sie immer noch arbeiten kann. Doch da könnte man ja überlegen, ob es vielleicht eine kleine Differenz gibt zu allen anderen, die so ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen.
Ja, Arbeit ist Arbeit. Da lohnt es sich nicht zu differenzieren. Der Herr Wirth ist ja wahrscheinlich auch so 182 Jahre alt. Wenn jemand eine Milliarde auf dem Konto hat und mir Arbeitsethos vorlebt, kann ich gar nicht in dieses Gespräch einsteigen, weil ich es nur auf intellektuelle Augenhöhe führe. Ja. Und dieser Mann ist offensichtlich dumm.
Punkt.
Das ist mein Commentary dazu. Aber sehr gut, dass sie bei allerhöchster Beschäftigungsrate und allerhöchster Stundenleistung, die in Deutschland je erbracht wurde, irgendwo Defizite sehen. Ich würde ja mal qualitativ nachhaken.
Und gleichzeitige Arbeitslosigkeit nicht, weil die Leute faul sind, sondern weil die Agentur für Arbeit vermeldet. Wir haben immer weniger Leute, die Stellen haben für unsere Arbeitslosen.
Ganz starrer Arbeitsmarkt. Also, ich habe eine Statistik gesehen gestern. Und zwar sind millennial Väter, ich zum Beispiel, heute so viel mit ihren Kindern beschäftigt, wie Boomer Mütter.
Ah ja.
Typischerweise sind ja die Mütter immer mehr mit den Kindern beschäftigt. So, wir haben also eine extreme Beschäftigungswerte, aber Beschäftigungsumfänge in Deutschland, bei gleichzeitigen extremen Zuwendungen dem Kind gegenüber. Und das alles aus einem Grund, die Arbeitgeber bezahlen zu wenig und der Staat leistet auch zu wenig. Also, die Schule funktioniert nicht und man kriegt kein Geld für irgendwas. Von daher, ja, die Leute kritisieren da irgendwie wild rum, aber es ist einfach von der dunklen Seite des Mondes so. Ja. Völlig absurd. Okay, willst du noch was dazu sagen oder?
Nein, wir lassen das genauso stehen und ja, schimpfen nochmal mit all jenen, die überhaupt denen immer eine Plattform bieten. Also, dass man als Augsburger Allgemeine sagt, wir müssen unbedingt mal den Reinhold Wirth, den Schrauben-Milliardär, zur Arbeitsmoral befragen. Also, wir sehen ja eh, wie jetzt alles, was über Arbeitskämpfe erstritten wurde, kurz und klein geschlagen wird. Und dass dann so Journalisten nichts anderes zu tun haben, als solche Protagonisten einzuladen und zu interviewen. Und dann Maischberger nochmal sagt, ich machs noch ein bisschen blöder und lade Uschi Klaas ein. Und spiele dann nochmal, nachdem man sie schon zu diesem Irrsinn befragt hat, den Winnetou-Film ein, in dem sie aufgetreten ist. Um dann nochmal so eine kurze Debatte führen zu können, darf man eigentlich noch Indianer sagen. Also, das ist einfach so deutscher Diskurs 2026. Das ist alles unerträglich.
Das ist Arbeit.
Wo Teams vernetzt sind und Ideen wachsen, liefert Internet at Work von Vodafone high speed für ihr Business. Together we can.
Okay, dann greifen wir das doch mal direkt auf. Ich will heute zwei Voranstellungen machen, denn es ist ja, wie man häufig hört, sehr viel Chaos in der Welt. Und diese Leute, die dieses Chaos verursachen, sind die Superreichen und Supermächtigen, weshalb es für uns heute nur ein Thema gibt und es ist Davos hauptsächlich. Ich will aber zwei Sachen voranstellen. Das eine ist eine ganz kleine Beobachtung nur. Einer der Superreichen, Bezos, hat mal kurz darüber erzählt, was Stress eigentlich ist. Also Leute fühlen Stress, weil die Welt im Chaos usw. Und er meinte so, Stress kommt eigentlich nur aus einer Quelle und es sind unerledigste Aufgaben. Nun leidet man aber typischerweise nicht daran, dass man es noch nicht geschafft hat, Astronaut zu werden oder Beethovens Zehnte in Vollendung auch noch fertig zu schreiben, statt nur aufzuführen und so. Und das Problem mit diesem Stress ist, es sind diese kleinen Aufgaben, bei denen man, wenn die Mutter fragt, hast du schon den Geschirrspieler ausgeräumt, man sich denkt, der größte Stress ist eigentlich jetzt eine Erklärung zu finden, warum nicht, weil die Aufgabe so bewältigbar ist. Also wir haben es mit ganz viel bewältigbaren Aufgaben zu tun, die wir aber nicht mehr auf die Kette kriegen und das führt zu Stress. Also nicht die großen, überbordenden, sondern eigentlich die ganz kleinen, die man so selber in der Hand hat. Aber man liegt abends so im Bett und denkt sich, was hätte ich eigentlich heute machen können, aber habe ich nicht. Und jetzt rede ich es mir selber schon aus. Ich kriege noch nie mal eine Frage von außen so. Und es setzt mich schon unter Stress. Und das gibt es auch in einer anderen Domäne, über die Bezos natürlich nicht spricht. Und das ist, man sieht irgendetwas und weiß auch, was es ist, aber irgendwas hindert einen daran, das einfach zu sagen. Also wie zum Beispiel Minnesota kniet ein Typ auf allen Vieren und wird zehnmal den Rücken geschossen. Und dann kann man jetzt Faschismus sagen oder nicht? Und dann krübelt man so ewig rum. Deswegen möchte ich jetzt kurz anmerken. Ja, also dieser Stress, den ihr da erlebt, ist dadurch, dass ihr die einfachsten Wahrheiten aus irgendwelchen Gründen einfach nicht aussprechen. So, und das will ich jetzt mal in einem ganz großen Bogen. Und dann will ich aber eine kleine Schließung machen. Ja, also wir reden natürlich.
Das haben wir in Davos nur erlebt. Dass da Leute sich gegenüber sitzen. Also bis auf ein paar Ausnahmen, die aber dann aus der anderen Richtung kommen. Aber sonst erleben wir natürlich ganz viel uneigentliches Sprechen dort. Die haben einen irrsinnigen Stress, genau dies und das und das nicht anzusprechen.
Genau. Also Carney kommt damit jetzt die große Ehrlichkeit. Wir nehmen das Schild aus dem Schaufenster. Man denkt sich so, ja genau, also das war wirklich die Nicht-Sonntagsrede. Also es lebe, Tod der Sonntagsrede, es lebe die Sonntagsrede. Die Sonntagsrede ist tot, es lebe die Sonntagsrede. Ja. So ungefähr. So, bevor wir das jetzt durchgehen. Ich war in Nürnberg, habe einen kleinen Ausflug gemacht zu den historischen Städten des Nationalsozialismus, die ja da alle noch stehen. Warum? Gleich. Und das war hochinteressant, schon allein, weil wir eine tolle Runde waren. Also ein Rundgangsleiter, ein Architekt, jemand, der die Kulturhauptstadt-Europabewerbung mitverantwortet hat und so weiter das Wort. Wir werden das auch wiederholen, denn die Zeppelin-Tribüne ist gerade eingepackt. Sie wird das alle erst einmal überhaupt so ein bisschen renoviert, kann man nicht sagen. Und jetzt auch das Uneigentliche sprechen. Die Stadt Nürnberg hat sich entschieden, eine Trittfestmachung vorzunehmen. Das heißt, man kümmert sich ein bisschen, dass es nicht ganz zerfällt, aber es ist auf gar keinen Fall eine Renovierung. Weil man will ja nicht Hitlers Werk und so weiter. Trittfestmachung. Ja, also mal auf die Trittfestmachung, damit die Leute nicht stolpern, wenn sie in die Tribüro gehen. Gut ergeben. Und die ist gerade eingehüllt und das Doku-Zentrum ist auch geschlossen seit einer Weile. Das wird aber jetzt im Mai offenbar wieder aufgemacht. Also sobald das wirklich offen ist, kümmern wir uns um neuen Termin. Und dann ist auch Sommer und dann ist es schön und dann können wir uns das angucken. Also wenn sowas wie in Minneapolis passiert und da stehen Leute daneben und sagen, das ist Faschismus, das ist ein ganz großer zivilisatorischer Fortschritt. Ich will mal kurz, wie die Deutschen dazu kamen, das Wort Faschismus in den Mund zu nehmen, in den Mund zu nehmen, was das für eine Leidensgeschichte war. In Nürnberg geht es um 14 Quadratkilometer Nazi-Bauten. Da haben ja hunderttausende Leute aus dem Reichsarbeitsdienst und so ihre komische Show da aufgeführt. Die mussten also in irgendwelchen Bracken schlafen. Man hat da Rodungen vorgenommen und das aufbereitet. Das Reichsparteitag glännte die große Kongresshalle und so weiter. Man kann sich das gar nicht vorstellen. Das sind natürlich alles Steine des Anstoßes, wie man so sagen kann, die natürlich diese Diskursgeschichte, 8. Mai, Kriegsschluss, immer wieder aufgewirbelt haben. Quasi jedes Jahr wieder kann man da so nachgucken, wie hat man denn diesmal drüber gesprochen? Ganz lange war es halt einfach, da ist was zusammengebrochen. Da gab es eine Niederlage, eine Befreiung. Also es hat eine Weile gedauert, bis man dazu kam. Und dieser Übergang, also von so, okay, wir haben überhaupt so eine allererste Phase Nachkriegszeit. Und wir wissen, alle Leute, die wir auf der Straße sehen, waren dabei. Also wir haben sozusagen ausschließlich Zeitzeugen. In dieser Phase, sagt dann Hermann Lübbe, war einfach kommunikative Beschweigung. Niemand redet darüber. Es ist einfach Mucks-Mäuschen-Stil. Diese Gebäude steht aber trotzdem alle da. Man läuft so durch und denkt sich, was ist denn hier eigentlich? Ach so, ja, Motorradrennen. Man hat also da vor der Zeppelin-Tribüne ab 1947 Motorradrennen und später Autorennen und dann Rock am Ring und so veranstaltet. Die Gebäude waren einfach da.
Rock am Ring ist ja ein Nürburgring.
Rock im Park, also das Parallelding ist auf dem Reichsparteitagsgelände. Da haben wir auch schon Rammstein gespielt und natürlich den Lichtdome aufgebaut und so. Das läuft dann alles so mit. Und es ist wirklich amüsant. Man steht vor der Zeppelin-Tribüne und da drüben das Stadion und man fragt dann so, also die Leute gehen zum Stadion hier so durch. Jaja, und da stehen auch sehr viele, die machen dann kurz Pause, machen Hitlergruß, ein Foto für zu Hause, so. Also das wird schon genutzt irgendwie, das ist Gelände. Naja, wie auch immer. Also wir haben diese erste Phase, in der einfach relativ wenig passiert. Außer natürlich die Nürnberger Prozesse, als die Hauptlastträger des Kriegs und der Kriegsgründe werden vorgeführt. Kriegen ihr Tribunal, aber das ist natürlich alles so eine Pionierarbeit, dass man überhaupt mal so was wie ein Völkerrecht formuliert. So, die amerikanische Armee übernimmt das Gelände, hält da auch ein paar Paraden ab, weil kann man ja nutzen, wenn es da ist. Und es schleicht sich so eine Banalität der Nutzung ein, so könnte man es formulieren, denn es ist einfach Alltag. Quelle, der Versandhändler nutzt also die großen Hallen, also diese großen, also man hat ja diese Kongresshalle für 100.000 Leute und so und da gibt es halt viele trockene Stellen, in denen man einfach Sachen lagern kann, also ist da einfach Quelle eingezogen. Zeugen Jehovas halten da irgendwie ihren Kongress ab und so weiter. Und solange Adenauer regiert, ist ganz klar, wir schauen in die Zukunft, wir machen Westbindung und wenn wir über uns reden, dann ist es das Leid der Deutschen, die Bombennächte, die Gefangenschaft, die Vertreibung, wird nicht groß thematisiert. Dann 1960, und wir sind jetzt schon mehrere Jahrzehnte nach dem Krieg, also mindestens ein Jahrzehnt ist schon abgeschlossen. Die erste Generation kommt zu Bewusstsein, die zwar auf deutschem Boden Kindheit erlebt hat, aber nicht unter NS-Zeiten, sondern in dieser Beschweigung. Und dann beginnen aber 61, 63 Eichbahnprozess in Jerusalem, Auschwitzprozess in Frankfurt und so weiter. Und es kommen so mediale Begleitungen, also auch Fragen auf. Und man spricht überhaupt das allererste Mal darüber. 1973 werden die Städten in Nürnberg unter Denkmalschutz gestellt, weil ansonsten die Gefahr unter Banalität der Alltäglichkeit Abriss gedroht hätte. Das ist schon sehr weit weg von dieser NS-Zeit. Bob Dylan spielt 1978 vor der Tribüne, auf der Hitler da sprach und heute bis heute eben Rock im Park und so weiter und so fort. Bundespräsident Walter Scheel 1975 sagt am 8. Mai, wir wurden von einem fundamentalen Joch befreit, von Krieg, Mord, Knechtschaft und Barbarei. Aber wir vergessen nicht, dass diese Befreiung von außen kam, dass wir, die Deutschen, nicht fähig waren, selbst dieses Joch abzuschütteln. Also 45 bis 75, das sind schon 30 Jahre, ja, 30 Jahre, in denen man so langsam, okay, wir wenden uns dem jetzt mindestens mal am 8. Mai zu. Und dann stellt man so fest, ach so, es sind nicht einfach nur die Gebäude hier mitten in der Stadt, die doppelt so groß sind wie das Kolosseum, sondern wir haben noch so ein paar andere. Und es beginnt so eine Art Schockpädagogik. Also man sagt einfach, da ist ein KZ, guck sie doch mal an und dann begegnet dir als allererstes so Leichenberg und du so, sorry, aber das überfordert mich gerade. So und dann erst in den 80ern beginnt so eine dritte Phase. Erste Bürgerinitiativen kümmern sich darum, dass man aus der Kongresshalle jetzt kein Einkaufszentrum macht. Es kommt überhaupt erst 1985 in diesen Städten dort zu den ersten Ausstellungen, wo man so ein Holzbrett an die Wand lehnt und so ein Bild festnagelt, wo man sich mal ein paar Bilder angucken kann, was hier eigentlich wie Hitler sich das vorstellte, was hier stattfand und so weiter. Weizsäcker spricht dann noch mal zehn Jahre nach Walter Scheel, 85, erst vom Tag der Befreiung. Also der 8. Mai war ein Tag der Befreiung. Er hat uns alle befreit von dem menschenverachtenden System der nationalsozialistischen Gewaltherrschaft. Also dass die eigene Geschichte eine Gewaltherrschaft war, dass es Nationalsozialismus war, dass es menschenverachtend, dass es ein System war. 40 Jahre hat das gedauert. So, aus der Schockpädagogik wird so langsam eine Spurensuche, führt natürlich wieder parallel dann zum historischen Streit. Also man sieht es und will es sofort abschütteln und dann wird da in den Föhrt-Haus herumdiskutiert. Und erst in den 90ern, ja 1995, gibt es die Wehrmacht-Ausstellung. 1993, 1998 kommt Schindlers Liste. Das Dokumentationszentrum dort eröffnet 2001. Man ist aber seit 2021 schon wieder geschlossen, weil peinlicherweise braucht man irgendwie fünf Jahre, um das zu renovieren, was auch immer. Deswegen, wir warten darauf, dass es aufmacht. Und Jan Aßmann, den wir hier sehr schätzen, sprach also von dem Floating Gap. Man brauchte erst mal eine große Phase des Schweigens. Und dann eine sehr mühevolle Zeit des Übergangs. Also wir reden von 30 Jahren. Dann nochmal 20 Jahre. Und dann rutscht das so in die, okay, also in Bayern zum Beispiel, der Besuch eines Konzentrationslagers steht jetzt auf dem Lehrplan. Ist für alle Schüler verpflichtend. Das dauert einfach 50 Jahre. Was bedeutet, wenn man so was wie Minnesota sieht und sofort und sei es nur ganz hinten im Köpfchen so einen Grundbegriff dafür findet, was das vielleicht sein könnte, aber die Geschichte ist noch nicht ganz entfaltet, dann kann man das einfach zulassen. Das ist halt Faschismus, was man da sieht. So und jetzt könnte man natürlich noch ewig warten, bis Trump sein Ballroom, der jetzt zwei Fußballfelder groß ist, hocheskaliert hat auf 14 Quadratkilometer irgendwas. Und dann findet er halt in zehn Jahren, ja, JD Vans macht dann die große Party oder so und sagt, wir sind jetzt nach net negative migration, sind wir jetzt ausländerfrei oder sowas? Ja, keine Schwarzen in Amerika. Das kann man auch jetzt schon in Worte fassen. Und ich will, weil wir ja hier ein spontan historisierender Podcast sind, mal zwei Clips spielen, die allerdings so ein bisschen, also die Radiosendung ist Essay und Diskurs. Da geht es typischerweise hochtrammend zu. 30 Minuten lang und danach so, was habe ich gesagt? Keine Ahnung. Also man weiß nichts mehr. Ach komm. Ja, es sind schon geschriebene Texte, die jetzt nicht unbedingt immer fürs Zuhören optimiert sind, sagen wir mal so. Aber wie auch immer, es gab am 4. Januar ein, in dem wir jetzt reinhören, als würden wir gerade in so einen Taxi steigen, wo das zufällig läuft. Also ich mache jetzt keine große Vorrede und so, sondern es geht einfach um, wie kann man mit Geschichte arbeiten, Genealogie, also so Abstammungsforschung, aber nicht nur an Biografien, wie auch immer. Und wir hören einfach so eine Minute hier rein. Mir kommt es auf die allerletzten Worte an. Von daher, dieser Clip ist jetzt wirklich sehr voraussetzungsvoll, ohne dass ich irgendwas mitliefer, außer das, was ich jetzt gesagt habe. Und wir lassen uns mal auf die letzten Worte hier hinzulaufen. Das ist Ralf Konersmann am 4. Januar, falls hier, oder ja, 4. Januar, weil es noch jemand nachhören will.
Dementsprechend können genealogische Arbeiten zu einer heiklen Angelegenheit werden. Sie halten die Gesellschaft dazu an, sich bewusst zu machen, was sie gern wäre, und sich dem zu stellen, was sie im Unterschied dazu tatsächlich ist. Genealogien unterlaufen und irritieren die Eingenommenheit der Gegenwart von sich selbst. Aber sie leisten noch mehr. Dem Umweg über die Vergangenheit folgend zeigen sie das gegenwärtig gültige in der Position der Vorläufigkeit, in der es sich anders als heute noch deutlich artikulieren und gegenüber konkurrierenden Positionen durchsetzen musste. Sie versetzen das Geläufige, damit es hervortreten kann, in den Status seiner Möglichkeit zurück. Das sind Arbeiten, historische Arbeiten, zu denen Zeit gehört und der Schein der Lampe. Offenheit für sämtliche Aspekte des Themas, Mut zu unbequemen Wahrheiten und Verwahrung gegen die Flüsterstimme der Narrative.
Die Flüsterstimme der Narrative. Wenn man die hört, kann man sich entscheiden, ob man sie aufgreift oder nicht. Aber sie flüstert halt nur. Die einen sagen, ne, Obama hat doch auch Leute deportiert, im großen Maßstab und so weiter. Dann kommt so eine andere Flüsterstimme und sagt, ja, so in diesem Alcatraz-Ding fehlen jetzt so tausend Leute. Man weiß gar nicht, wo die sind. Und die Anwälte und die Angehörigen wissen das auch nicht. Und so ist vielleicht doch was anderes. Was ist es denn dann? Ja, und dann kann man das so spontan historisieren. Also diesen Moment der Gegenwart einfach nehmen und sich das mal so im Großen und Ganzen angucken, als hätte man so ein Puzzleteil, wo man das noch so sucht, wo es passt und so. Also das ist das eine. Und das Zweite ist, und das widerspricht jetzt sehr meiner eigenen intellektuellen Überzeugung, denn ich bin ja als Soziologe und sage dann, ne, das Bewusstsein der Einzelnen können wir bitte absichtlich umgehen. Und die Protagonisten der Politik sind sowieso austauschbar. Vielleicht ja nicht, ne. Also klar, das ist jetzt hier ein...
Aha, was kommt dann jetzt?
Ja, das ist vielleicht ein Beitrag zur Genealogie.
Ich denke, die wählen alle motivlos und so weiter.
Ja, genau. Also beim Wähler bleibe ich dabei. Aber es ist vielleicht nicht egal, wen die Wähler motivlos wählen.
Ach so.
Sondern da können Unfälle passieren. 80 Millionen Leute denken sich, der Typ, den ich im Fernsehen gesehen habe, den finde ich irgendwie lässig und der fasst auch Frauen ins Genital. Das würde ich auch gerne machen, so ja. Und dann wählen die einfach. Und in der Aufsummierung hat man dann plötzlich den falschen Präsidenten. Kann ja passieren.
Ich will nur ganz kurz anmerken, ich will hier nicht in einen Luhmann-Streit mit dir gehen. Ich will nur sagen, ich habe hier mal vor vielen Monaten gesessen. Wir haben über Ähnliches diskutiert. Und ich sagte, vielleicht funktioniert Luhmanns Theorie sehr gut in einer Bundesrepublik, wo die Frage sich stellt, wird der nächste Bundeskanzler Helmut oder Helmut heißen? Also, ich will sagen, ob das die SPD oder die CDU ist, ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so entscheidend, wie die Frage, ist es Trump oder jemand von den Demokraten? Da sehen wir, da ist ein bisschen mehr Gewicht drin. Und dadurch ist natürlich auch dieses, so, wir abstrahieren mal vom Inhalt und so und schauen nur mal, dass das so formal alles funktioniert. Für eine alte Bundesrepublik würde ich sagen, ja, so war das. Ich hatte damals versucht, was du entschieden abgewehrt hast, auch Luhmann in einen historischen Kontext zu setzen.
Genau, das lehne ich ja weiterhin ab.
Aber in gewisser Weise machst du es jetzt gerade, deswegen finde ich das sehr...
Naja, also zum einen, die Politik ist in der Gesellschaft ein besonderes Feld, da sie immer wieder für sich reklamieren kann, primat zu sein, was wir aber grundsätzlich ablehnen. Was eben auch zu einer Einsicht führen könnte, wie wenn man Kräfte hat wie Alex Karp, Peter Thiel, Elon Musk, ist vielleicht egal wer Präsident ist. Aber wenn es dann doch jemand wie Trump ist, findet ein Matching statt, das historischer, einzigartiger Beobachtung bedarf. Wo man dann sagt, okay, die allgemeine Theorie kann man jetzt auch mal kurz ein bisschen vom Text abweichen. Aber hier geht es ja nun, also das läuft wirklich unter Genealogie. Und das ist ja nun eigentlich die, sagen wir mal, familienhistorische Abdingslehre. Ganz so eng muss man es nicht sehen, aber Protagonisten sieht man dann schon. Und ich würde sagen, das ist nicht ganz unbedeutend.
Der lange Blick des Genealogen greift jene Proklamationen auf, in denen sich das heute als normal empfundene noch offen erklären und ausweisen musste. Im Zuge dieser Arbeiten erweist sich die Normalität der Gegenwart als Realisierung einstiger Erwartungen und Absichten, als Resultat machtvoller Gesten und durchgreifender Entscheidungen. Die Gegenwart bekommt ein Gesicht.
So, die Gegenwart bekommt ein Gesicht. Das bedeutet, es ist nicht ganz egal, wer Entscheidungen trifft. Die Theorie, die einfach nur sagt, die Entscheidung ist es, reicht nicht ganz. Und das ist ja damals auch schon. Ich habe ja eine Promotion begonnen, eben in der BGHS. Und das H steht eben für historisch im Bielefeld. Also da haben ja die Soziologen und die Historiker schon zusammengearbeitet, um da einfach 1 plus 1 mal 7 zu rechnen. Und in der Hinsicht gibt es hier große Lehren. Also das eine, was ich eben schon sagte und jetzt verbunden mit diesem, das, was wir gerade auf der Straße sehen und wofür wir Worte finden müssen oder also wir müssen sie jetzt nicht finden, aber Leute, die gestresst sind, können vielleicht diesen Stress abbauen, ohne dem sie einfach ohne falsche, oh nee, dann dreh ich jemand auf den Fuß oder so, einfach sagen, okay, das ist halt Faschismus so. Und das zweite hier ist eben dieses Gesicht. Das ist eben von Menschen gewollt. In diesen Davos-Reden bricht es immer so über sie herein, so, ja, das ist ja wirklich irre, ja, und wir hören ja nachher Macron, wie er so seine Rede beginnt. Man denkt sich so, nee, ist nicht über euch hereingebrochen, sondern in euren Reihen ist halt ein Faschist, und es ist gleichzeitig der Mächtigste unter euch. Und jetzt müsst ihr nicht Grönland vor Russland beschützen. So, wir wissen, warum ihr da die Bundeswehrsoldaten hinschickt, ja? Also lauter solche Sachen. Und nur weil es heute, ich habe in der Tagesschau gelesen, oder ich habe es bei Nurder Koch gesehen, wie er einen Clip gemacht hat, den die Tagesschau gemacht hat, ohne ihn zu hören, aber ich habe den Text mitgelesen. Die israelische Armee hat wohl zugestanden, 70.000 Leute in Gaza getötet zu haben. Was bedeutet, also 70.000 ist auf jeden Fall ein Massenmord, so, ja. Und ich finde, das sind auch Dimensionen kurz vor Völkermord. Jetzt haben wir uns irgendwie drei Jahre lang auch darum gewundet, ah nee und so weiter und so fort, ja. Aber unter dieser Maßgabe, dieser Spontan-Historisierung, wie wir es jetzt gesehen haben, die Flüsterstimme der Narrative und mal ein Gesicht zum Vorfall finden, also das wollte da jemand und es fand statt. Und es ist jetzt nicht das allergrößte Vergehen der Welt, wenn man sagt, nee, bei mir sind es erst ab 80.000 Völkermord, dann hat halt jemand einfach eine andere Meinung aufgrund irgendeiner Sache, die man nachvollziehen kann. Der Benchmark liegt bei 80.000. Meiner likt halt bei 69.999. Deswegen sage ich jetzt, das war halt auch Völkermord. So, die Israelis haben jetzt bestätigt, was die ansonsten immer als, das ist ja alles nur Hisbollah und Hamas und so, aber diese Zahlen sind jetzt auch von der israelischen Seite bestätigt und von daher war es halt ein Völkermord.
Nun, will ich nicht gleich in diese Debatte einsteigen um den Faschismusbegriff, das wird uns ja eh immer wieder begleiten. Ich wollte nur den Satz einmal beginnen mit den Worten Adam Tuus und ich. Halten ja das für noch nicht eigentlich den richtigen Begriff für das, was die Trump-Administration tut, dass man damit den Begriff Faschismus kommt. Vielleicht kommt man da nochmal auf einen anderen Begriff, aber wir wollen das jetzt nicht wieder alles hier haarklein ausdiskutieren, weil ich auch da dir zustimmen würde, man sollte es auf jeden Fall mit einem drastischen Wort belegen und wenn das passiert, dass dort einfach auf der Straße jemand wehrlos abgeknallt wird, dann muss man nicht sagen, wir warten jetzt mal ab, dass da die Untersuchungen uns Näheres liefern dazu, wenn es schon so offensichtlich ist. Also auch da noch ein institutionelles Vertrauen zu haben, dass vor allem auch die Trump-Administration an Aufklärung interessiert sei. Also dann hat man wirklich sich schon die Augen zu gebunden und will an Formalitäten festhalten, die schon längst eingerissen wurden. Das halte ich für falsch. Was ich aber denken musste, als das jetzt geschah, dass da jemand erschossen wird von Eis, war, dass wir ja alle gerade so nostalgisch sind das Jahr 2016. Viele posten ja doch gerade das Jahr 2016. Das war doch das letzte Jahr, was frei war. Hast du das generiert oder hattest du tatsächlich? Hattest du eigentlich damals eine Kappe mit Make America Great Again an?
Tilo war ja damals zum Geburtstag in Amerika. Und hat in Youngstown oder so eine Rallye mitgemacht von Trump. Und da ist er natürlich shoppen gegangen. Also habe ich auch ein Trump 2016-T-Shirt und eine Maga-Head. Und habe mich 2016 damit fotografiert. Und das Bild habe ich noch mal rausgekramt.
Ja, sehr schön.
War natürlich ein Aufreger bei Instagram.
Wirklich, ja. Ja, natürlich. Jedenfalls, 2016 wird jetzt gerade so verklärt, das war die letzte gute Zeit, obwohl da ja schon Trump da war, in dem Sinne. Ja, es war ja schon das Phänomen da. Jedenfalls erinnerst du dich an das Ding, das man immer über Horrorclowns sprach, die an Universitätsniveau sind, die so rumgerannt, die überhaupt in Städten überall sind. Die hat man so Horrorclowns erlebt, die dann Leute erschreckt haben.
So Stephen King-artig.
Genau, und ich meine, die Horrorclowns, die haben wir heute in Davos sitzen. Da können wir ganz deutlich sehen, wie die Zeit eben nicht mehr so ein popkulturelles Phänomen ist, sondern jetzt ernste Politik. Und es gab damals Pokemon Go. Du weißt, das war dieses Spiel, mit dem man mit dem Smartphone durch die Gegend lief und dann konnte man Pokemon zu einfangen.
Mit dem Smartphone und dem Akku.
Ja, pass auf. Shijek hatte damals in der Zeit einen Artikel geschrieben, der für einen kleinen Skandal gesorgt hat. Denn er hat dann erst dieses Spiel erklärt und sagt, die Technologie von Pokemon Go läuft auf nichts anderes hinaus, als auf eine Externalisierung des Grundmechanismus von Ideologie. In ihrem Kern ist Ideologie, also falsches Bewusstsein, die ursprüngliche Version der Augumented Reality, der erweiterten Realität. Was er also sagen will, ist, wir blicken, wenn wir diese App nutzen, dieses Spiel spielen, ja auf eine Realität, die mit der Digitalität, mit der digitalen Welt verbunden ist. Deswegen Augumented Reality. Und das ist aber eigentlich etwas, was wir in der Ideologie vorfinden. Wir sehen ja nicht einfach, wie die Dinge sind, sondern da kommt ja irgendwas dazu, nämlich Ideologie. Vielmehr findet sich hier etwas öffentlich inszeniert, was immer schon der Fall war. Die Tatsachen nämlich, dass der große andere, das dichte symbolische Gewebe des Wissens, der Erwartungen, der Vorurteile und so weiter, in der alltäglichen Wirklichkeitserfahrung ständig die Lücken unserer Wahrnehmung ausfüllt. Denn projiziert ein westlicher Rassist nicht genau in diesem Sinne ein Komplex von Vorurteilen und Erwartungen, wenn er auf der Straße unversehens auf einen Araber trifft. Also der Araber wird dann auch im Stadtbild wahrgenommen, wie das Pokémon, das gejagt wird. Und dann ging er am Schluss sehr weit in sein Matiko und sagte, und hat Hitler den Deutschen nicht das Phantasiebild seiner nationalsozialistischen Ideologie beschert, durch dessen Raster sie überall ein besonderes Pokémon, den Juden, auftauchen sahen, dass sie mit einer Antwort auf die Frage versorgte, wogegen man zu kämpfen habe. Und gilt nicht dasselbe für alle anderen ideologischen Pseudoentitäten, um die man die Realität ergänzen muss, damit sie vollständig und sinnvoll wird. Was er uns hier sagen wollte, das Muster, das da verfolgt wird, diese Argumented Reality, das ist eigentlich, wie Ideologie funktioniert. Nur, und das ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen dem Jahr 2016 und 2026, jetzt wird wirklich gejagt auf der Straße. Und zwar nicht irgendwelche Figürchen, sondern Lateinamerikaner werden gejagt und verhaftet und verprügelt und so weiter. Also das fand ich nochmal interessant. Man kann jetzt sagen, das geht ja sehr weit, was der Shishak da tut. Aber einfach dieser Kontrast 2016, 2026 wird dann nochmal besonders deutlich.
Ja, Shishak geht ja immer sehr weit und wird immer wieder eingeholt von der Realität. Denn ich finde auch, also Pokémon war ja vor allem auch eine technologiegestützte Unterhaltung.
Ja.
Das hat ja auch nochmal sehr zugenommen die letzten zehn Jahre.
Und Eis ist ja auch technologiegestützt.
Ja, genau. Das darf man nämlich echt nicht unterschätzen. Also, wir kennen doch alle jetzt von Peter Thiel, diesen Sprucher auf der Bühne. Mit Dämagologie überzeugen wir sie nie. Also mit der großen Wahlkampfrede und so. Sondern wir müssen sie über Technologie machen. Und die Frage ist, wie die das jetzt gerade nutzen, während sie ja wissen, also Trump ist so ein biologischer Körper, der nicht mehr ganz auf der Höhe ist. Aber den technologischen Körper kriegen wir da irgendwie reingebaut. So, es ist zuerst dieses, Elon Musk räumt Institutionen ab und baut da einfach Serverlandschaften aus. Jetzt kommt Eis und fotografiert dich einfach im Gesicht und sagt dann, uns ist egal, was in deinem Pass steht. Die App sagt, kommst du jetzt hier mit? Und dann werden einfach Leute eingesammelt. Und das wird immer noch unterschätzt, wie, ich bleibe jetzt mal dabei, der Faschismus über die Technologie einfach Einzug erhält. Und wenn Zizek sagt, völlig zurecht, mit Pokemon Go findet er schon einen Einflugschneise. Also dann erst recht mit dem, was wir jetzt alles sehen überall. Also das neue TikTok in Amerika, das ist ja grotesk, was man überlegt.
Mich wundert, dass Zizek seinen Pokemon, vielleicht konnte er sich da selbst nicht mehr dran erinnern, aber er hätte eigentlich das gut aufgreifen können.
Könnte er eigentlich nochmal plagiieren heute, ne?
Ja, er hätte eigentlich diesen Text nochmal vorlegen können und nur am Ende sagen, und so ist das jetzt mit Eis.
Was zu beweisen war. Ich will noch eine Sache, die mir nämlich jetzt auch die Woche wieder auffiel. Carolin Amlinger war hier im Musonturm oder so. Ich weiß, ich wohne hier seit 100 Jahren. Musonturm. Musonturm. Okay, da gibt es so eine Reihe an Gesprächen, wo man so ohne Eintrittsgeld hingehen kann und so. Und sie hat auch nochmal über die Zerstörungslust gesprochen und hatte auch nochmal das Fallbeispiel dieser Frau Kowalczyk oder wie sie hieß, die also während Männer so ein instrumentelles, ja ja, schön, da kann ich mich auf der Straße mal ausleben, sind halt Frauen in der Spitze, diejenigen, die wirklich krasse Zerstörungslust haben und so. And it was interesting for me, nicht nur zu sagen, okay, das was wir im Großen und Ganzen sehen, ist einfach destruktive Politik, wo dann irgendwie Macron, Merz, Carney von Larry Fink, wie so die Facility Manager reingeholt werden, damit sie mal aufräumen. Welche Idee habt ihr jetzt, um den Schmutzfleck da wegzumachen, so ungefähr? Und diese Großwetterlage wird also runtergebrochen auf den archimetischen Punkt eines elementaren Gefühls, verletzter Stolz aufgrund blockierter Leben oder wie auch immer, ja. So, und während ihr sie das vortrug, fiel mir noch mal auf, wie, also erstens grandios das ist, das als Idee zu formulieren, aber auch wie wichtig diesen archimetischen Punkt gegen Widerstände wirklich durchzuhalten. Also nicht in so eine Psychologie reinzufallen und zu fragen, ja, wo kommt denn der verletzte Stolz jetzt her und so? War da vielleicht was in der Kindheit? Hat Merkel was falsch gemacht oder so? Sondern einfach zu sagen, nee, nee, es beginnt jetzt bei diesem, die haben so ein Gefühl. Wir gehen jetzt nicht pädagogisch, psychologisch weiter nach, sondern wir schauen jetzt nur in die Richtung, was daraus erwächst, weil wir einfach sehen, dass da so krass viel raus erwächst. Kann sein, dass irgendwann mal irgendeine KI superschlaus oder so und das alles aufdröseln kann, aber wir sollten jetzt bei diesen elementaren Gefühlen mal ansetzen. Deswegen auch die Flüsterstimme des Narratives. Das ist nicht einfach nur ein Pokémon Go Spiel, wo ein 13-Jähriger so, ach hier, kommt da und da und da, ja, sondern zehn Jahre später stehen die auf der Straße und der O-Ton ist original.
It's pretty cool.
Feels like, und dann irgendein Computerspiel genannt. Nachdem die so eine Straße in Minneapolis langgelatscht sind und sich dann wieder sammeln. So, das ist einfach eins plus eins ist hier genau. 2,00000 ist eindeutiger, geht's nicht.
Wir gehen zu Davos über, Weltwirtschaftsforum. Aber wir machen erst einen kleinen Stopp in Frankreich. Ende des Jahres ist ja, wer verstorben? Die große Brigitte Bardot. Und du weißt, Brigitte Bardot war nicht nur eine große Schauspielerin, sondern auch eine sehr umstrittene Person. Ja deshalb, weil sie ja neben ihrem radikalen Tierschutz sich immer sehr fremdenfeindlich in den letzten Jahren, Jahrzehnten geäußert hat.
War sie denn wirklich fremdenfeindlich oder nur vernebelt?
Na ja, also sie hat sich schon in den 90er Jahren mit dem Alten De Pen getroffen. Also sie hat in Interviews dann betont, ihr ging es immer nur darum, wer für den Tierschutz ist, den wählt sie. Sie würde sogar einen Kommunisten wählen, wenn er für den Tierschutz ist. Aber das ist immer so eine Sache. Jedenfalls war Marine Le Pen auf ihrer Beerdigung. Allerdings, als sie dann betont als Privatperson, während die Macron's ausgeladen waren, ganz klar, weil Macron sich nicht entsprechend für den Tierschutz eingesetzt hat. Der Tierschutz, okay. Brigitte Bando war ja auch die erste Marianne. Du weißt, das ist die Figur der Republik, die man auf dem Gemälde von Delacroix auch sehen kann, also von der französischen Revolution, die die Facke der Freiheit trägt, die Fahne der Freiheit trägt. Und danach, nach dieser Marianne, wurde ja dann immer eine Französin auserkoren, so als Galeonsfigur.
Als offizieller Akt, oder war das einfach so?
Ja, ja, als offizieller Akt durch Frankreich. Und die erste war Brigitte Bardot. Ich kenne jetzt nicht alle Aufzähler, aber das war Ines de la Fressange, Catherine de Neuf, Sophie Massot und auch Mireille Mathieu. Nun, Mireille Mathieu macht ja seit Jahren ihre Abschiedstournee durch die ganze Welt. Sie hat auch gesungen auf der Beerdigung von Brigitte Bardot und war zugeschaltet jetzt vor einer Woche im französischen Radio Europe, oder so heißt das, richtet jetzt davon, dass sie mit Brigitte Bardot ja noch im vergangenen Sommer telefoniert hat. Und wir hören jetzt mal uns an, um zu dem geopolitischen Thema zu kommen, was Mireille Mathieu hier zu sagen. Wir hören es auf französisch, aber wir übersetzen es dann.
Das ist ein Monument.
And we talked about Marianne. I told her, Ich gehe im Weltall und ich bin in Marianne's office.
But you are the first.
And I said, Ihr seid wirklich das Movement in Frankreich. In der ganzen Welt. You are...
So she laughed like crazy.
She told me, Sie war humbl.
Sie war wirklich... So we talked about it too.
I told her that I was a goalkeeper.
And she yelled at me, Ich bin auch ein Goalkeeper.
Okay, alle lachen. Das habe ich gehört. Was...
Sie erzählt erst, dass Sie sich darüber unterhalten haben, dass Brigitte Bardot ja die erste Marianne war und dass Mireille Mathieu durch die ganze Welt reist und da auch immer als Marianne empfangen wird. Aber sie, Brigitte Bardot, ja die wahre Marianne ist. Und dann hat Brigitte Bardot wieder gesagt, nein, aber sie sind auch genauso wie alle anderen und so weiter. Und sie sei ganz bescheiden. Jedenfalls haben Sie dann noch darüber gesprochen. Also Mireille Mathieu hat dann zu Brigitte Bardot gesagt, ich bin ja Golisthin. Woraufhin Brigitte Bardot rief, ja, ich bin auch Golisthin. Und das ist natürlich einmal lesbar in Bezug auf, wie viel Fremde will man im Land haben und so. Da beziehen sich ja eben sehr viele Rechte jetzt in Frankreich immer wieder auf diese Art des Golisthimos. Es gibt ja auch dieses Bild von von Charles de Gaulle. Man kann eben nicht Wasser und Öl zusammenkippen. Das vermischt sich nicht, sondern das ist immer eine Trennung da. Das sind ja so Bilder, die von von von Rechten aufgerufen werden. In diesem Monsieur so und so und seine Töchter. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht dieser berühmte Film. Da ist der Vater, ist ja so ein Golisth, der auch dieses Bild dann zum Beispiel bedient. Aber der Golisthimos meint natürlich auch, wir brauchen ein unabhängiges Frankreich. Wir wollen aus diesem transatlantischen Bündnis, der wird nicht ganz raus, aber so uns doch von dem unabhängig waren. Wir wollen uns nicht vom Dollar die ganze Zeit pisacken lassen. Also diese hohe Eigenständigkeit, die da vertreten ist. Das ist etwas, was wir auch hin und wieder dann in Anklängen gefunden haben bei früheren Auftritten von Macron. Hier war das jetzt alles ein bisschen diffuser. Lag vielleicht auch daran, dass er diese Brille aufhatte, von der man nicht weiß, warum. Adam Toos hat in einem Podcast mit John Stewart gesagt, ja es gibt viele Gerüchte, manche sagen, er wäre Highas Kite gewesen.
Ja, man will ja heute gar nichts mehr ausschließen. Ich würde auch sagen, irgendetwas stimmt da nicht. Wir haben ihn auf jeden Fall schon mal französischer Reden sehen in Davos. Es war jetzt nicht...
Aber wir gehen noch gar nicht über gleich zu Macron und wollen auch gar nicht so... Also ich habe gar nicht viel von Macron dabei. Jedenfalls können wir also sehen, diese Idee der Eigenständigkeit, das ist schon etwas, was den Franzosen immer wichtig war, also seit Charles de Gaulle. Wir können aber noch einmal das Spiel spielen, das Jahr 2016. Was war denn da eigentlich in Davos? Dort hat nicht nur John Kerry so eine Rede gehalten, an der er sagte, wenn wir jetzt so gut weitermachen, dann wird es eine geschichtslose Zeit sein. Also es wird nicht mehr viel Geschichte sich ereignen. Er hat eigentlich noch mal so ein bisschen diesen Fukuyama-Schritt fortsetzen wollen und dann wird es allen besser gehen und mehr Emanzipation und mehr Vielfalt, all das. Es gab aber noch ein zweites großes Thema in Davos 2016. Wir hören hier mal Klaus Schwab selbst. Der hat nämlich dieses Thema damals gesetzt.
The first industrial revolution will have multi-fold impacts, of course. Every industry will be digitalized, will be disintermediated, and has to define a new business model. But it's not only business which is affected. It's government which has to move over to agile government. It is society as a whole, with the danger of job losses, but also with the need to re-skill and up-skill people fast.
Die Industrie 4.0. Die wurde 2016 tatsächlich ausgerufen. Das war ein bedeutendes Thema in Davos. Jetzt habe ich Adam Toos gehört, im chinesischen Fernsehen sprach er aus Davos über das, was da so stattgefunden hat. Und erwähnte plötzlich nochmal kurz die Industrie 4.0. Und wir sehen, Klaus Schwab hatte mehr als recht.
The other urgency for Europe is economic growth. They have seen a very serious slowdown in overall growth, notably at the heart of Europe, in Germany, which is feeling what they think of as a second China shock from the incredible surge in Chinese manufacturing capacity, the successes of Made in China 2025, which ironically I learned is a program that the Chinese borrowed from the Germans, which was Industry 4.0, which was launched at Davos by Schwab. China was the one country that took it very seriously. And it's changing the world as a result. So that is also a really profound concern for. And you heard this in Macron's speech as well. He said, look, the one thing we have to focus on is growth.
Also Schwab hat ja gesagt, Digitalisierung und dann Neugründung. Im Vergleich zu so Reformen von Tankern und so, kennen wir ja, dass das immer so ein bisschen behäbig ist. Wir haben, dazu habe ich dann später auch Clips, eine aktuelle Debatte zur Erbschaftssteuerreform, bei der auch im deutschen Radio nochmal gesagt wird, ich reformuliere es jetzt nur kurz, wenn die Eigentümerstruktur bleibt, wie sie derzeit ist. Das nehme ich immer ein Unternehmer, ein Unternehmen aufbaut, es dann vererbt, derjenige es nicht kann oder kein Bock drauf hat, also einen Vermögensverwalter einsetzt, ein Familyoffice, das wiederum private equity-mäßig einfach mal so guckt, wer so engagiert ist und dann kriegt er so einen 5% Anteil und macht dann irgendwas damit und so. Dann führt das alles ins Verderben. Sondern diese jungen Leute, die zwar dieses mega Vermögen haben, das Unternehmen, aber damit gar nicht umgehen können oder wollen, denen muss es weggenommen werden. Das muss in eine professionelle Managementstruktur überführt werden als AG oder Sonstiges. Die Leute müssen dann ausgezahlt werden. Darauf zahlen sie dann, was weiß ich, 30, 40 Prozent Steuern, haben sie halt immer noch ausreichend Geld. Und dann können die mit dem Geld machen, was sie wollen. Aber wenn sie unternehmerisch tätig werden wollen, müssen die neue Unternehmen gründen, statt einfach die alten vorzuführen. Also das, was die SPD da gerade versucht, ist vielleicht die letzte Rettung, um überhaupt so einen, wie soll man sagen, industriellen Komplex hier über Strukturwandel weiterzuführen. Aber dass einfach alle DAX-Unternehmen 130 Jahre alt sind und alle daran angegliederten, dieser Mittelstandseigentümer und so weiter, das funktioniert einfach gar nicht. Das ist auch der große Unterschied zu Amerika, wo einfach jeder Milliardär das Unternehmen, so scheiße es auch ist, zumindest selber gegründet hat, das einfach hier vorzuführen und an Family Offices auszulagern und die litigieren dann auch wieder. Und dann macht jemand Private Equity und dann kriegt jemand einen 5-Prozent-Anteil und dann kommt nichts darum.
Also das ist so entgegen jeder Dynamik, die man eigentlich benötigt.
Und die Chinesen, also BYD, diese Autofirma, die haben über das ganze Land verteilt hunderte, tausende Unternehmen gefördert und dann Ausleseprozess, Ausleseprozess, Ausleseprozess, Ausleseprozess und bei über dies übrig geblieben. Und die haben natürlich jetzt, also die setzen ja wie die Spinne im Netz da, die ganze Infrastruktur, die ganzen Lieferketten, everything is blank, so to say. While here, der Herr wird dann irgendwie, oh yes, die Frauen in meinem Unternehmen arbeiten zu wenig, so haben wir die Teilzeit-Lifestyles ablegen und so.
Wir hören jetzt erst einmal den Vizeministerpräsidenten von China, He Liefeng.
Ah ja, also, es waren Chinesen da.
Ja.
Weil ich nämlich gehört hatte, auch über Adam Tools und so, dass die Chinesen doch mehr zu Hause saßen. Und ich habe mir dann so vorgestellt, wie sie sich so im Politbüro einfach getroffen haben, wo sie Live-Streams angeguckt haben und dabei so Sekt und Häppchen. Und sich zu freuen, wie da alles zerfällt.
Ich glaube schon, dass das so ist, weil natürlich hier He Liefeng erstmal anfängt und sagt, Qi war ja hier schon und hat über dies und das geredet. Und so ist das auch alles. Also er bestätigt erst einmal genau das, was Qi gesagt hat, um dann ein paar Akzente noch mit reinzubringen, die aber auch nicht neu sind, sondern was hier eigentlich stattgefunden hat, ist, dass wir hier einen Kopf der kommunistischen Partei China sehen, der sagt, also wir machen das jetzt folgendermaßen, das ist so unsere Idee. Ich glaube, das wäre für alle gut. Denkt nochmal drüber nach. Aber mehr machen die gar nicht. Also es ist ganz interessant, auch gar nicht in einem aggressiven Ton jetzt irgendwo hin.
Wissen sie nicht mehr.
Man muss ja auch nicht jetzt darüber diskutieren, dass natürlich China auch versucht, wirtschaftspolitisch seine Macht durchzusetzen. Und wenn die über irgendwas verhandeln, dann sind das auch harte Hunde. So klingt das natürlich hier nicht an, wie er es formuliert. Aber was wir hier eigentlich erleben ist, also würde der jetzt neben Klaus Schwab auf der Bühne 2016 stehen und Folgendes zum Beispiel sagen.
We should firmly support free trade and jointly promote a universally beneficial and inclusive economic globalization. Economic globalization driven by international specialization, collaboration, complementary strengths and the pursuit of win-win is a prevailing trend of history.
Ja, Freihandel ist Win-win. Bedeutet auch, dass China ja hier einen Kurs geht, den wir auch bei Pranko Milanovic schon ein bisschen nachlesen konnten. Es geht also nicht so sehr, wie man erst dachte, als man sich so abschottete während Corona, dass man jetzt nur auf die Binnenwirtschaft setzt. So sah es ja mal kurzzeitig aus, sondern China scheint ja sehr jetzt das deutsche Modell eigentlich aufzunehmen, nicht nur, dass Industrie 4.0 anbelangt, sondern auch, man will Exportweltmeister werden und scheint dafür ja sogar der eigenen Bevölkerung etwas zuzumuten, nämlich, dass es dann nicht ein Wachstum weiter in der Mittelschicht gibt oder dass jetzt nicht so ein weiteres großes Aufstiegsversprechen da formuliert wird, ob das gut geht, ob das sinnvoll ist. Ich habe da meine Zweifel, finde das an sich nicht gut, glaube, dass man vielmehr auch binnenwirtschaftlich arbeiten muss und dafür sehen muss, dass es allen besser geht. Jedenfalls, das Modell ist natürlich auf Export auch ausgerichtet. Mit jetzt genau der Argumentation, die man immer finden konnte, seit Bill Clinton bis heute eigentlich fast.
Making the pie bigger together is more important than fighting for the pie. And solving problems together is more effective than blaming each other.
Also Amerika hat ja auch echt eine strukturelle Schwäche, muss man echt sagen. Wir haben es ja auch thematisiert, wie sie die Dollarhoheit und dass sie die Seewege freischießen und da aber ihre Industrie zu Hause geopfert haben. Und das sind halt dann doch ersetzbare Assets im Jahrzehnte Maßstab. Also die Chinesen haben auch 700 Schiffe und können sich die Seewege da schon freischießen dann. Das ist also dadurch, dass wir nachher so viel hören, wie jetzt die Rule-based Order vorbei ist und nur noch der der Mächtige und so. Nein, das ist genau wie vorher. Nur halt wer der Mächtige ist, wird halt neu definiert. Aber ansonsten ist es wirklich ununterscheidbar.
Ja, ja, wir müssen das wirklich erst mal sehen, weil ich doch sehr verblüfft war, wie die Karnierede aufgefasst wurde. Und ja, mit Sonntagsrede kommen wir da schon sehr weit. Wir hören noch einmal Lie Feng. Er verspricht jetzt Öffnung. Wie gesagt, das ist immer auch mit Vorsicht zu genießen, da wir wissen, wie sehr reglementiert ausländische Investoren werden, wenn sie da in China tätig sind und all das. Allerdings muss man auch hinzufügen, China hat ja auch großes Interesse, hier mehr zu investieren. Das hat man dann auch immer mehr abbremsen wollen.
China will steadfastly expand opening up and share with the world the opportunities from its high standard opening up. Reform and opening up is China's fundamental state policy. China will open its door still wider to the world. China will actively expand voluntary opening up. Align with high standard international economic and trade rules. Expand market access and open more areas, particularly in the service sector. And step up our efforts to attract and utilize foreign investment.
Der Service Sektor, der soll auch geöffnet werden. Ich hab darüber nachgedacht, was ist damit gemeint? Es geht ja wohl sehr stark um digitale Services.
Also wir wissen ja, dass Amerika durch zwei Sachen super erfolgreich war. Export von Software und Import von Intelligenz durch dieses Unisystem. Jetzt gibt es ja die ersten Rankings wie Harvard abschmiert und so weiter und die ganzen chinesischen Unis nach oben gezogen werden. Das ist ja der große Wunsch Chinas, dass man das eigene Unisystem irgendwie so eingliedert, dass man da so eine intellektuelle Freiheit hat, aber noch nicht den Staat gleich dann, nur weil man mal vor die Tor der Uni geht umwirft und so. Und in diesem Feld machen sie gerade große Fortschritte. Und bei diesem, ja, völlig klar, wir kaufen das Zeug in Amerika, weil Huawei ist ja verseucht, das scheint sich auch gerade zu drehen.
Ja, denn wir sehen ja auch...
Die Softpower, ja, die kommt jetzt...
Bei DeepSeek, wie groß das doch aufgenommen wurde und auch hier genutzt wurde.
Wir bauen das einfach in den N&N-Workflow ein und so. Und das Ding arbeitet halt vor sich hin.
Wir sprechen ja gleich noch auf dieses, wir kommen auf dieses Weaponizing zu sprechen. Also, dass man alles jetzt quasi als Machtgebärde ausspielt. Und wie dann natürlich auch die Frage ist, wann könnte sogar Amerika so weit sein, dass die jetzt versuchen, uns Microsoft oder uns Google wegzunehmen, wenn wir in gewisser Weise uns nicht entsprechend verhalten. Also, das sind ja alles noch Sachen, die jetzt gerade durchgerechnet werden. Also, das ist jetzt einfach noch ein viel zu großer Verlust für so ein Unternehmen. Aber man weiß ja nicht, in welche Richtung diese Regierung noch geht. Da kann es dann interessant sein, wenn die Chinesen sagen, wir bieten dann vielleicht die Services an. Da jetzt nicht damit zu rechnen ist, dass zum Beispiel aus Europa die großen Services kommen. Also, wir glauben nicht dann an einen Microsoft-Ersatz aus europäischer Hand, oder?
Ich schon.
Wo siehst du das? Siehst du das bei SAP oder so?
Nein, nein, nein. Die Bayern haben ja kürzlich wieder so einen Servicevertrag mit Microsoft unterschrieben. Also Landesverwaltung und so weiter. Alle Microsoft. Und dann sind sie auch unter Feuer gesetzt worden, weil Schleswig-Holstein schon sagt, wir machen das ja ohne Microsoft. Die Antwort ist da natürlich Open Source. Und das, was wir nicht sehen in Europa, ja, sind, dass gigantische Unternehmen aufgebaut werden. Nur, das versuche ich ja häufiger zu betonen und es ist auch noch schwierig, das Argument zu machen, weil es so fantastisch klingt da, also wirklich wie so Science Fiction. Aber Software ist ja nicht mehr die große Herausforderung. Wir haben zwar gerade die Top 5 Unternehmen der Welt, die nur wegen Software-Gramm so mächtig sind, aber wenn man sich wirklich ernsthaft hinsetzt und sich fragt, welches Problem in meinem Alltag, in meiner Verwaltung, in meinem Organ, was auch immer, in meinem Verein, muss ich denn hier im besten Falle mit Software geklärt kriegen, ist die Antwort nicht mehr, na hoffentlich hat Weikmussoftware was hergestellt, sondern das kann man zukünftig immer einfacher auch einfach selbst entweder completo herstellen oder sich an so einem bestehenden Stack irgendwie andocken, indem man einfach sagt, ich nutze WordPress, aber ey, die ganzen Plugins kann ich mir selber schreiben lassen von Claude Coat und so. Also da ist schon einiges im Wandel.
Also eine ganz andere Art von Interoperabilität, als wir das jetzt bei diesem geschlossenen System haben.
Krass. Und das sage ich jetzt aus meiner, ich mache alles eigentlich nur als Hobby gefühlt. Und ich sehe ja, wie weit ich damit komme und ich sehe, wie weit wir im Büro damit kommen und überhaupt und so. Und als Staatsverwaltung oder als privater Verein, als Schule denke ich mir, ey, wer jetzt noch einen Microsoft-Service-Vertrag über zehn Jahre und so und so viele Millionen abschließt, da hat wirklich einfach den Schuss nicht gehört. So, gestern, das fand ich wirklich wahnsinnig amüsant, Microsoft Excel. Immer alle behaupten, die Welt funktioniert überhaupt nur wegen Excel. The world runs on Excel. Entropic veröffentlicht einfach dieses komische Plug-in. Du musst in Excel gar nichts mehr steuern. Du sagst einfach, was du willst und das Ding schlüsselt dir komplett Excel auf, einfach nur durch Zurufe. Du machst so zwei Promps und zack, ist so eine ganze Excel-Landschaft einfach vor dir entstanden. Und das sind alles so Sachen. Und da muss man halt ganz deutlich sagen, Entropic ist jetzt der Vorreiter. In zwei Jahren, also schon in fünf Monaten, kann man das auch mit einem Mistralplugin aus Frankreich machen. Und in zwei Jahren gibt es wahrscheinlich 20 Anbieter, keine Ahnung. Also ich sehe gar nicht, wo die monopolistische Schließung sein soll, weil weder braucht man alle Mathematiker, die bei IBM arbeiten, um Software herzustellen, noch braucht man diese riesigen Gelder, um da irgendwas zu kreieren.
Ich habe eher die Befürchtung, dass man zum Beispiel ja in China sieht, da gibt es dann so eine App für alles, da kann man dann alles mitmachen. Und da gibt es ja auch manche, die hier so einen Traum pflegen von, das wäre doch aber so schön und praktisch. Das ist natürlich ein ideales Überwachungstool, dass man in gewisser Weise vom Regen in die Traufe kommen kann. Wenn jetzt man sagt, ja, okay, dann nehmen wir das nicht mehr von den Silicon Valley-Verrückten, sondern nehmen das jetzt daher. Erst mal kommt das viel mehr nach Open Source oder so daher, hat aber dann eben sehr viele andere Funktionen. Und gar nicht meine ich jetzt damit, dann kann KI uns alle ausspähen. Vielleicht interessiert ihn das auch gar nicht so sehr, was wir jetzt gerade machen, sondern dass unsere Regierungen wiederum sich dem chinesischen Modell annähern. Also wir haben ja diesen Trend gerade. You meet me at a very Chinese time in my life.
Der Zug ist leider abgefahren.
So frage ich mich, ob diese chinesische Zeit in meinem Leben irgendwann in Brüssel vorherrscht.
Die ist längst da. Denn das ist ein großes Missverständnis. In China gibt es WeChat. Und da macht man alles mit. Und WeChat läuft auf Handys, bei denen so ein bisschen egal ist, welche Handys das sind. Die Chinesen versuchen, ihre eigenen Software erst dazu zu machen. Aber in Deutschland ist völlig klar, Apple, iOS und Google, Android sind deine Everything-App. Also man muss nur den Blick so ein bisschen verschieben von einer einzelnen App auf das Betriebssystem. So, auf diesem Betriebssystem, alles, was du regelst, läuft auf diesem Betriebssystem das ganze Leben. Und das sind nicht unsere Betriebssysteme. Und da ist auch noch totaler Vendor-Login. Also da sind die Hersteller, die einfach bestimmen.
Da kommst du auch mit deiner KI nicht weiter.
Da kommt man auch mit deiner KI nicht weit. Genau, das ist eben, also die KI ist jetzt auf dem Laptop so, ja. Also da kommt man ziemlich weit auf dem Handy. Kein Meter, also Null, ja.
Was ich aber glaube, wie das ja hier klingt, ist ja, dass Live-Feng eigentlich dahin eine Öffnung auch haben will. Also das quasi, wenn wir jetzt von diesen geschlossenen Systemen ausgehen, dann ist das ja noch so, dass jetzt die Chinesen das da eher schwer haben. Und ich glaube, dass es schon darum gehen wird, weil sie auch wissen, womit man Geld verdienen kann, wie die Amerikaner das gemacht haben, dass die natürlich jetzt versuchen auch hier ihre Services anzubieten und nicht nur eine TikTok-App.
Also wenn jetzt noch mal so ein ganz harter Edward Snowden-Moment kommt, wo einfach klar ist, das war ja damals bei Microsoft, alles was du innerhalb von Microsoft-Software machst, wird direkt an die NSA geliefert. Wenn das jetzt mit Google Android und mit Apple iOS passiert, dann halte ich es für gar nicht ausgeschlossen, dass fünf Jahre später völlig klar ist, dass wir jetzt auch ein Handy aus China kaufen. Und ich halte es auch für ganz ausgeschlossen, dass wir ein europäisches Betriebssystem bekommen. Also da auf der Ebene. Für nicht ausgeschlossen. Doch, für ausgeschlossen. Also so sehr ich sage, Open Source wird diese ganz spezifischen Aufgaben, die man in Verwaltung, Schulen und so weiter hat, aber dass unser Alltagsleben, das so sehr auf Convenience getrimmt ist, wo man einfach nicht einen Lehrgang vorher macht, sondern das Handy muss einfach funktionieren und so, ja. Also das kriegen wir Europäern nicht hin.
Das bedeutet aber auch, die Vernetzung bleibt.
China würde dann einspringen.
China würde einspringen, das hättest du aber schon für möglich.
Ja, also wenn Android und... Also angenommen, es geht in Amerika alles schief.
Und das Webanizing geht weiter.
Trump tritt für eine dritte Amtszeit an. Im Hintergrund ist völlig klar, dass da so ein industrieller Komplex einfach alle farbigen Menschen aussatieren möchte, dass man das natürlich über... Wir gucken einfach auf die Smartphones. Und dann wird noch so eine Familienpolitik wieder rum. Also so ein richtig düsteres Handmaids Tale Szenario. Und dann kommen die Chinesen und machen nach drei Jahren medialer Vorbereitung und vielleicht auch den ersten Film, den man so aus China sieht, wo man so denkt, oh, ist ja doch ganz angenehm da. Also so die ersten Tom Cruise Filme aus China und so.
Na ja, es sind ja schon sehr viele chinesische Filme, die jetzt sehr populär geworden sind.
Genau, und dann stellen sie einfach das nächste Honor-Handy vor mit... Klar, chinesischer Software, aber wen interessiert es? Ja, das würden die Leute dann kaufen.
Es gibt ja den Trend in den USA, viel stärker als jetzt hier, dass dort laufen Leute, posten, ich bin so in meiner chinesischen Zeit gerade, ich fühle mich so chinesisch. Und dann geht es ja sehr über den Lebensstil, dass man sagt, ich trinke jetzt warmes Wasser, ich mache dies und das.
Kein warmes Wasser trinken, das kommt aus der Heizung.
Dann solche popkulturellen Dinge, wir haben ja hier auch das Lavobu ausgepackt, also wir sehen ja schon, wie sich da sehr viel verändert und dass das etwas ist, was natürlich jetzt besonders stark ist, weil man den Amerikanern ja nicht mehr sagen muss, ihr habt da so eine dysfunktionale Gesellschaft. Und die sehen es ja an allen Ecken und Kanten, wie dramatisch eigentlich diese Regierung ist. Wodurch dann plötzlich so eine fast merkwürdige Chlorifizierung der chinesischen Situation entsteht, dass da alles gut funktioniert. Die Schnellzüge, das wird dann immer als allererstes so genannt.
Der Bullet-Trail, ja.
Das ist aber schon so ein kultureller Shift, der da stattfindet, die wir jetzt gerade beobachten. Sodass man das dann eben nicht mehr für so unmöglich hält, dass man sagt, naja, dann nehmen wir halt das. Genauso wie ja auch erstaunlich viele deutsche Autofahrer bereit wären, ein chinesisches Auto zu fahren.
Das wird eine ganz große Einflugsmeister.
Was man nicht für möglich gehalten hat, weil man immer sagt, die Deutschen halten ihr Auto, und zwar dem deutschen Auto, die Treue.
Die Leute steigen in chinesische Autos, die Shortvideos laufen schon. Es leuchtet alles bunt. Man wird zugenebelt mit irgendeinem Duft. Die Leute sind Feuer und Flamme für chinesische Autos.
Ich hab jetzt keine Clips davon dabei, aber vielleicht hast du das gesehen, wie Adam Toos, Lagarde und Larry Fink auf einem Podium hintereinander saßen und der ist Citadel-Chef. Interessant war, der Moderator wollte die ganze Zeit über historische Parallelen sprechen. 20er Jahr, vor allem 1929. Adam Tooth ist da ja voll drauf eingestiegen. Du kannst es dir denken. Und auch Christine Lagarde, während der Citadel-Chef und Larry Fink nur über AI sprechen wollten. Und zwar auch dann so Sachen wie, ja, Larry Fink erzählt, was er jetzt bei Walmart gesehen hat, was die mit der AI machen. Also wollte einfach nur so seine Kundschaft froh machen.
Die sind ganz blank, die Leute.
War wirklich ängstlich davor, jetzt irgendwelche historischen Analogien aufzumachen. Denn dann hätte man ja auch über politisches reden müssen.
Oder man hätte sie kennen müssen, diese historischen.
Das dann auch. Und da war so ein Moment in dem Lagarde sagte, sie hat die große Angst, dass wir uns immer mehr abschotten. Denn wenn wir wirklich einen Fortschritt wollen, auch bei den KRIs, dann brauchen wir Vernetzung. Da muss die Welt zusammen das Wissen reingeben. Sie hatte da so eine ganz kleine Vision aufgemacht. Und das sah ja auch eben anders die Vernetzung heute, als die 1929 war, wo man tatsächlich noch ziemlich hermetisch abgeschlossene Blöcke hatte oder Länder hatte. Woraufhin Larry Fink das Wort ergreift und so tut, als würde ihr zustimmen, um dann aber zu sagen, ja ja, wir müssen jetzt wirklich sehen, dass wir da mit der AI vorankommen, damit wir der Konkurrenz aus China begegnen können. Also er hat nur in Blockkonfrontation gedacht. Und dann war das eher Lagarde, die sagte, naja, wir müssten es mal im Ganzen sehen. Das wurde dann noch übertroffen von Howard Lutnick. Das ist der US-Handelsminister. Adam Tuese hat dieses herrliche Panel moderieren dürfen. Wir hören jetzt aber nur Lutnick, der gefragt wird, ja, wie, was macht ihr eigentlich so die Zeit? Also was passiert eigentlich? Wie sieht eure Strategie aus mit den Zöllen und Solar? Und er redet dann fünf Minuten. Wir hören das nicht komplett, aber wir hören am Tonfall. Mit dem ist nicht zu scherzen.
Find the cheapest labor in the world And the world is a better place for it.
Interessanterweise hätten wir vor zehn Jahren auch solche Worte hören können, aber dann von so ein paar kapitalismuskritischen Stimmen, die eingeladen werden mitunter. Ja, Brechmann war ja auch schon mal da, die dann sagen, ja, ihr habt doch immer von der Globalisierung als ein Modell gesprochen, das uns alle reicher macht. Aber wo stehen wir dann? Jetzt ist es Ladnig, der das anspricht, dann aber für sich wendet.
Von Elon Musk, Pedatil, Alex Karp und so weiter. Seit ungefähr zehn Jahren die ganze Zeit zu sagen, die blue color worker sind, die eigentlich waren. Und leider wurden sie abgehängt. Das sind die Opfer. Das macht ja auch Ludnik auch. Mit so einer besonderen Argumentation, nicht nur die neu zu hofieren, sondern auch die white color worker so abzuklären. Dass ihr auf Universitäten geht, war falsch. Ihr lernt da nur Scheiße. Verlasst die Uni, geht richtig arbeiten. Wohl dem, der heute Handwerker wird und so weiter.
Grundet.
Genau. Da steckt aber, klar, wir müssen mehr Theorokysik trap. Also da gibt's sehr viel zu erklären.
Ja.
Aber nicht so wie er das macht. Denn er ist ja einer dieser Milliardäre, die natürlich davon profitieren. Sieht man ja auch bei Trump, wenn immer wieder diese Witze aufkam, dass er da zu diesen Industriestätten fährt und an irgendeiner Lagerhalle, in irgendeinem Stahlwerk eine Rede hält und dort diese Maga-Caps verschenkt, die natürlich alle in China hergestellt wurden.
Man weiß ja auch, wer in Hotels zum Beispiel putzt.
Genau.
Das ist die globalisierte Arbeitsmarkt.
Dass man jetzt plötzlich die Arbeiter für sich entdeckt und überhaupt und so. Da geht es nur um Wählermobilisierung, das ist nicht die Ansprache für zu Hause, das ist alles verlogen.
Aber interessant, dass sie wirklich die Globalisierung als ein Verlustgeschäft hier verkaufen. Aber für sie, die sie eigentlich vertreten, mit ihrer Politik und vor allem Republikaner immer vertreten haben, sind natürlich die Profiteure. Und das ist nicht nur jetzt so eine liberale Elite gewesen, die da profitiert hat. Es ist nicht nur Hillary Clinton und Obama-Eliten, die dort profitiert haben.
Was man aber festhalten muss, 2000 amerikanische Milliardäre rangeln darum, jetzt politische Macht zu haben. Ludnick ist einer davon, der es geschafft hat, dass die sich jetzt als die Opfer, das ist einfach wirklich grotesk, das muss man ganz deutlich sagen.
Das möchte ich auch hinzufügen. Ludnick ist der einzige, der überhaupt in all den Reden, die ich gehört habe, das Wort Arbeiter an den Mund nimmt. Das heißt, die anderen halten alle Reden, ob du jetzt Merz, Macron, wie auch immer, nimmst die Reden von der Wirtschaft oder die verweisen auf Börsenkurse. Das heißt, es ist schon etwas dran, nicht im Sinne von wie Ludnick das dann für sich ausbuchstabiert. Aber die Tatsache, dass Davos natürlich immer so konstituiert war, dass es gerade nicht darum geht, wie geht es der arbeitenden Bevölkerung. Das ist deutlich, dass die das nur populistisch aufrufen, jetzt um Wählerstimmen zu bekommen, geschenkt. Aber sie sind die Einzigen, die es überhaupt ausrufen. Für die anderen ist es überhaupt nicht interessant. Das spielt keine Rolle. Das ist auch nur so eine Mobilisierungsmasse für die anderen, die man noch nicht mal mehr beim Namen nennen muss. Ludnik kommt auf grüne Energien zu sprechen.
Why would the United States of America, which has oil and natural gas, try to convert to all electricity? China does not have oil and natural gas. Electricity and electric cars make perfect sense to them. That is practical and logical. So the point I want to make, and I want people to think about, is that America first is the job of our government to take care of our workers.
So, I'm going to leave it at that. So, now we're going to take a break. So, now we're going to take a break. So, now we're going to take a break. So, now we're going to take a break. So, now we're going to take a break. So, now we're going to take a break. So, now we're going to take a break. Du hast es doch vor der UN erklärt und so, ja. Now we don't even get this effort anymore. But now we just get the order. This is an infrastructure that provides us with the oil. Then we will, and this is funny, be completely surprised by this. All these oil CEOs were invited. They didn't know what was going on the other day. They were all sitting there, and had a short calculation with GPT. ExxonMobil, exxonMobil, said, sorry, it's not worth it. If we build a solar panel, 4 cents per kilowatt hour, but we have to drive a boat over it, that's kind of stupid. We were already dismissed twice. It's not very sustainable. It just doesn't work. It's just too expensive. And there hasn't even been an environmental argument yet. So the dullness is quite surprising. It's really all so dull. But the attitude is interesting.
The American workers have to be protected, Das ist wirklich so stumpfsinnig alles. Aber die Haltung ist interessant. Die amerikanischen Arbeiter müssen beschützt werden. Die geht es überhaupt. Dann wird aber das Wohl der amerikanischen Arbeiter verbunden mit dem Wohl der amerikanischen Wirtschaften allgemein. Natürlich. Das ist etwas, was eben nicht anzutreffen ist.
Wenn es den Dow Jones gut geht oder dem DAX, dann ist auch Oma Erner zufrieden.
Genau, das ist nicht der Fall. Aber er sagt dann etwas jetzt auf die globale Ebene ausgerichtet. Das ist eine interessante Drohung, die hier ausgesprochen wird. Und jetzt will ich doch eine gewisse Kontinuität herstellen zwischen der Biden-Administration und der Trump-Administration. Denn wir sind jetzt auch so ein bisschen dabei, weil die natürlich entsprechend auftreten und das auch kurios alles ist, dass wir sagen, das ist so der Bruch, die Zäsur, was auch immer. Aber es gibt auch Kontinuitäten. Wir hatten mal hier Clips von Jake Sullivan. Ich habe zwei davon nochmal rausgesucht. Als Jake Sullivan als Sicherheitsberater von Biden einen Vortrag hielt über Weltwirtschaft und dort sagte, dass mit dem Washingtoner Consensus diese Idee des Freihandels immer nur die Zölle zu reduzieren, hat die amerikanische Arbeiterschaft geschwächt und hat uns nicht stärker gemacht. Der drückt sich wesentlich diplomatischer aus, sagt aber sehr ähnliches wie Ladnick. Betont dann, er möchte eine Weltordnung haben, die China einbremst.
Was er sagt ist, And it means returning to the core belief we first championed 80 years ago. That America should be at the heart of a vibrant international financial system that enables partners around the world to reduce poverty and enhance shared prosperity.
Er will also auch ganz klar Amerika ins Zentrum setzen. Sagt jetzt nicht America First. Tut es aber. Jemand wie Adam Tuus hat ja immer gesagt, die beiden Administrationen waren mager für denkende Leute. Und sagt dann, mit Verweis auf ein Kennedy-Zitat, folgendes, dass man ja auch als Drohung wahrnehmen muss, ähnlich wie Lattnig das jetzt formuliert hat. Er hat das Bild der Dunkelheit bemüht. Hier sind wir bei Schiffen, die untergehen.
President Kennedy was fond of saying that a rising tide lifts all boats. Over the years, advocates of trickle-down economics appropriated this phrase for their own uses. But President Kennedy wasn't saying what's good for the wealthy is good for the working class. He was saying, we're all in this together. And look at what he said next. If one section of the country is standing still, then sooner or later a dropping tide drops all boats. That's true for our country. That's true for our world. Economically, over time, we are going to rise or fall together.
Niemand hat da was dagegen. Ich fand auch rückblickend diese Aufklärung, ja, America First war doch immer so. Ja, nur es war halt nicht immer so in dem Modus, dass wir sagten, wir wollen das nicht. Sondern dieses America First vorher, dass einfach völlig klar ist, die erste große Auslandsaufenthalte in deiner Jugend machst du natürlich in einer amerikanischen Highschool. Der erste große Film, den du guckst, ist natürlich ein amerikanischer Film. Da hat ja keiner was dagegen. Dass man sich wenigstens den zweiten Uniabschluss dann in Amerika holt, da hat auch keiner was dagegen. Dass man sich hier die Weihnachtsgeschenke holt von was Mattel sich wieder ausgedacht hat, hat auch keiner was dagegen. Aber bei dem, was Trump da vorstellt mit America First, da hat man halt was dagegen. Also ich würde sagen, America First gegen America First.
Ja, ich will es schon nochmal deutlich machen, wir haben das bei der Biden-Administration ja gesehen und Macron war der Einzige, der sich damals getraut hat, das öffentlich zu sagen. Man hat zum Beispiel die Krisensituation, die Energiekrise in Europa ausgenutzt, um überteuert Energie anzubieten. Man hätte das günstigernd den Europäern, den Franzosen, den Deutschen anbieten können, das hat man nicht getan. Man hat also auch da von der Biden-Administration plötzlich sehr Druck ausgehübt. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, wie da auch mit einigen Masken und so umgegangen wurde, wie es um Impfstoff und alles geht, wie da auch sehr die amerikanische Regumonie sich durchgedrückt hat. Der Unterschied ist jetzt, dass Sullivan immer mehr auf diese Partnerschaft sich konzentrieren würde und würde versuchen, auf diese Weise so eine Ertrostung durch Umarmung herzustellen, was ja auch dann dazu geführt hat, dass ASML so eingeschränkt wurde, dass nicht mehr mit China zusammengearbeitet werden darf, dass viele weitere Anti-China-Polices auf der Brusseler Ebene durchgesetzt wurden, aufgeheißt von Washington. Das ist etwas, was ja eigentlich von der Biden-Administration schon weit gebracht wurde, an die Trump jetzt anknüpfen konnte, dass Trump dann jetzt so freitret mit, ich möchte gerne Krönland oder, wie er auch manchmal auf der Bühne sagt, Iceland haben. Und er möchte dann noch irgendwelche anderen Dinge haben und außerdem schere ich mich überhaupt nicht um eure Ideen und so weiter. Das ist sicherlich nochmal ein Auftreten, das jetzt besonders die Europäer irritiert. I think that this disbalance in the relationship was long ago very far advanced. And Macron was always someone who emphasized this. And I think you should recognize this in the continuity. Which then also results in many people that now we really have to get rid of each other. Ich möchte schon mal vorwegnehmen, dass ich das nicht glaube, dass man jetzt die transatlantische Partnerschaft beendet.
Also witzig ist ja, dass wir auch hier im Podcast immer so viel über Politik reden, weil es da so Protagonisten gibt.
Ja.
Und das ist natürlich, während wir, also völlig, ist völlig klar, die politischen Probleme sind die, die wirtschaftlich hervorgehoben werden, die gelöst werden müssen. Wer macht hier unser Zollstreit? Dieses ganze Geopolitik, Geoökonomie. So, ne? Und bevor du jetzt den ersten Macron-Spiel, äh, Clip spielst, ich will nur mal beispielhaft, äh, Macron wurde ja vorgestellt. Das heißt, jemand ist schon vor Ort und macht dann einfach den, den Thementag, die Moderation. Typischerweise bucht man sich da für jemanden, der einfach jung, weiblich und adrett aussieht, sodass einfach alle alten Männer aus der Wirtschaft einen schönen Tag haben, weil sie immer wieder auf der Bühne so Frischfleisch sehen. Ja, ich sag's jetzt ein bisschen dispektierlich, aber das ist so ungefähr der Modus, in dem das typischerweise abläuft. In Davos dieses Jahr betritt immer wieder Larry Fink, der Chef von Blackrock, die Bühne, um die Protagonisten vorzustellen. So, das ist also ein Amerikaner, der in New York sitzt, nach Indie-Schweizreis, dort Carney einführt, Macron einführt, das Gespräch auf großer Bühne mit Elon Musk führt und so weiter und so fort. Also auf der wirtschaftlichen Ebene, auf der Unternehmer-, der Konzern-Ebene und so, war nie mehr transatlantische Verständigung als, wenn Larry Fink erstmal eine Lobhudelei auf Frankreich hält, bevor dann Macron kommt.
I'm gonna get started.
So Trampeltierartig. Zwar noch anreist, aber dann schon sagt, also bei der Sicherheitskonferenz an der München sind wir nicht mehr. So, wir haben ja letztes Jahr schon unsere Rede gehalten. Das war es dann auch mit JD. Vance und so weiter und so fort. Läuft hier auf dieser Konzernebene genau das Gegenprogramm. Larry Finn kommt einfach her und schmiert jedem noch mal Honig im Mund und ach die Europäer.
Macron beginnt scherzend.
It's great to be here.
Es ist wirklich eine Freude, hier sein zu dürfen.
And it's a time of peace, stability.
Es ist ja, es sind der Zeiten des Friedens, der Stabilität und der Vorhersehbarkeit, die wir derzeit durchleben.
Ja, und das mit seiner komischen Brille und ein bisschen sprunghafter.
Macron hat einen Wunsch für Europa.
Und wenn wir dieses Problem angehen möchten, müssen wir vermehrt zusammenarbeiten. Neue Bandsätze bauen. Es braucht mehr wirtschaftliche Souveränität. Strategische Autonomie insbesondere für Europa. Das ist für mich.
Ja, behalten wir das erstmal im Hinterkopf. Es geht um diese strategische Autonomie, mehr Souveränität für Europa. Was ich mich frage, ist, gibt es wirklich das Projekt eines europäischen Großraums? Das ist eine Frage, die ich nachher wieder aufgreifen will. Denn wir haben ja diese Großraumidee sehr stark geprägt durch das Denken von Carl Schmitt, die doch immer wieder kehrt. Nun gibt es ja da einige Schwierigkeiten bei Europa, weil wir einmal die stärkste Wirtschaftsmacht Deutschland haben und auch eine starke politische Macht dadurch, aber Frankreich ja auch nicht ohne ist. Das heißt, die sind ja in gewisser Weise rivalisierend. Wir können das dann ja auch sehen, wie Deutschland zum Beispiel seine Autoindustrie platziert ist, die französische, da kaum eine Chance hat und all das haben wir bei Patrick Makaczemarchek im Buch lesen können, damals Kampf der Nationen. Jedenfalls ist das ja etwas, was so einem Großraumgedanken widerstrebt, zu dem ja auch Großraum bei Carl Schmitt schon auch ideologisch gefüllt ist. Aber jetzt merkt man doch gerade durch diese Begehrlichkeiten, die von Trump bezüglich Grönland geäußert wurden, dass aus dem Lager, das man sonst so zum Beispiel bei Twitter als transatlantisch wahrgenommen hat, immer in Bezug auf Ukraine und in Bezug auf den Krieg in Gaza, jetzt so eine Welle da ist von einem Ruf nach europäischer Souveränität, dass man plötzlich erstaunt ist und sich fast fragt, treten wir bald auch in einen Krieg ein, nicht nur gegen Russland und China, sondern auch noch gegen die USA. Es ist sehr merkwürdig. Ich halte das auch nicht für eine gute Entwicklung, um das gleich zu sagen. Also das klingt ja erstmal so toll, europäische Unabhängigkeit und so. Ich bin auch da nicht begeistert von. Nicht, weil ich generell dazu neige, wenn was zu Ende geht, dass ich ihm dann anfange, hinterherzutrauen in eine tanzatlantische Partnerschaft oder so, sondern weil ich eher sagen würde, da steckt doch eine ganz erhebliche Gefahr drin, nämlich, dass man dann wirklich in einem Großmachtsdenken permanent sich befindet. Das bedeutet auch, dass man also in laufend kriegerischen Auseinandersetzungen wird sein müssen. Aber das werden wir gleich nochmal aufgreifen.
Es gibt ja eine europäische Antwort auf deine Frage. Das ist Spanien.
Ja.
In Spanien ist ja eine Regierung am Werk, die auch gefragt wurde, ob sie das NATO-50-Prozent-Ziel, also 5-Prozent-Ziel mitmachen. Und die haben einfach gesagt, ne, weil wir brauchen das Geld ja für was anderes. Ja. Also Sozialstaat und so. Und jetzt war die Frage, ja, also wie gebt ihr das Geld denn dann aus? Und Europa hängt ja davon ab, dass aus Spanien das Gemüse geliefert wird. Da arbeiten also eine Million aus Nordafrika emigrierte Menschen. Und die werden jetzt alle pauschal, kriegen den legalen Aufenthaltsstatus in Europa. Das kostet natürlich Geld, weil die haben jetzt plötzlich bürgerrechtliche Ansprüche und so weiter und so fort. So, das heißt, in Europa, Wir könnten jetzt auch zum Beispiel statt über Davos zu reden und das Schaufenster, können wir über die Realpolitik europäischer oder spanischer Politik für Europa reden. Also, dass unsere Grundversorgung im Supermarkt weiter gesichert ist, ist jetzt ein spanischer Beitrag auf Kosten der Verteidigungsfähigkeit. So gesehen. Also, es gibt schon so ein paar Linien, an die man anknüpfen kann, wo man diesem ganzen Klartaradatsch, den wir jetzt hier zu entfalten versuchen, einfach ein Gegenprogramm gegenüberzustellen.
Was viel wichtiger ist, also dieses Gegenprogramm jetzt. Und wir sollten da auch häufiger drauf zu sprechen kommen, weil doch ein Eindruck, flächendeckend zu machen ist dann Davos. Mit diesen Leuten will man eigentlich dann nichts zu tun haben. Also jetzt mal Adam Tews und ein paar andere Professoren ausgenommen, die ja wegen ihrer Expertise da sind. Aber der Rest ist wirklich, dass man sagt, ich will mit denen nichts zu tun haben, und ich will mich auch nicht mit denen identifizieren, und ich will auch nicht für die irgendeinen Handelskrieg oder irgendetwas führen müssen. Das ist wirklich dramatisch, was man sich da ansieht. Und das ist einfach wegen gar kein Bock.
Ja. Prefer not to.
Ja, wirklich gar keinen Bock. Also das ist so grauenhaft. Ich habe 15 Stunden, glaube ich, insgesamt Davos geguckt. Und das ist so demütigend für einen denkenden Menschen.
Na, spielbar. Ich bin ja jetzt über deine… Also, Mark Carney wurde ja jetzt vielfach thematisiert.
Ja, Mark Carney ist der, der Redner überhaupt. Also der, der, der wird meine, meine Prognose auch irgendeinen Friedenspreis des deutschen Buchhandelspreises bekommen, oder? Das wäre so eine, wäre so ein Kandidat dafür. Sagen wir so, er hat rhetorisch auf jeden Fall die beste Rede gehalten.
Ja, es sieht ja auch aus wie in Hollywood rekrutiert.
Natürlich, ja, es funktioniert alles bei ihm. Aber es ist eine Rede, die er offenbar selbst geschrieben hat. So wird zumindest gemunkelt.
Gemunkelt, ja.
Ja, jedenfalls ist es eine Rede, die sehr gut ist. Wir werden nachher Friedrich Merz hören. Dann denke ich mir, da hat Stefan recht. Genau, die KI und so könnte eigentlich da viel mehr. Jedenfalls, Markane, also der Premier von Kanada. Spricht er erst Französisch, wechselt dann nachher ins Englische.
Thank you, Larry. It is both a pleasure and a duty to be with you tonight in this pivotal moment that Canada and the world are going through. Today I will talk about a rupture in the world order, the end of a pleasant fiction And the beginning of a harsh reality.
Die harsche Realität, welche ist das nun?
On the other hand, I would like to tell you that the other countries, especially intermediate powers like Canada, are not powerless.
They have the capacity to build a new order that encompasses our values, such as respect for human rights, sustainable development, solidarity, sovereignty, and territorial integrity of the various states.
The power of the less power starts with honesty.
Er spricht über die Mittelmächte. Damit ist gemeint, nicht USA. Also er spricht die USA so gut wie nicht an in dieser Rede, aber darum geht es die ganze Zeit. Also die Großmacht USA, die jetzt einfach tut, was sie glaubt, tun zu können. Da kommt er und sagt, die Mittelmächte haben aber auch eine Macht. Und dem würden wir erst mal zustimmen, dass die natürlich nicht sich einfach als Unterlegen geben müssen, sondern auch was in die Wachschale zu werfen haben, zumal wenn sie sich miteinander verbünden. Es ist eine Illusion von Sicherheit entstanden.
Es scheint, dass wir jeden Tag in einer Zeit von großem Machtverwaltungsreinigung in einer Zeit von großem Machtverwaltungsreinigung in einer Zeit von großem Machtverwaltungsreinigung in einer Zeit von großem Machtverwaltungsreinigung in einer Zeit von großem Machtverwaltungsreinigung We have international relations reasserting itself.
Er spricht also jetzt von all den Ländern, die dann doch versuchen, den König Trump gnädig zu stimmen, Wir haben Kurschen, damit sind natürlich auch Friedrich Merz, Ursula von der Leyen und all die gemeint, die gar nicht so richtig hervortreten mit einer Kritik, beziehungsweise nicht die eigenen Interessen genügend vertreten, sondern dann eigentlich so einschwenken auf den Kurs von Trump und dass man sich damit eigentlich nicht in eine Sicherheit begibt, sondern dass man sich eigentlich da immer mehr anpasst, dem ganzen und unterwirft.
Also, diese Rede gilt ja als historisch, der weiß man ja Jahrzehnte noch, darauf zurückblicken. Das ist die große Zäsur, die Zeitenwende für die Welt und so weiter. Hinten im Saal saß ja die ganze Zeit Gavin Newsom. Und er scheint ja laut Adam Toos dort aufgetreten zu sein, wie der nächste amerikanische Präsident. Gar nicht so sehr aus eigener Egohaftigkeit. Sondern weil alle ihn so sehen wollten.
Ja.
Wenn sich Kalifornia ausgliedern würde, aus Amerika, wäre das ja auf Augenhöhe eine Mittelmacht. Also Platz 6 der Weltwirtschaft mit Kani.
Und dass die beiden sich gut verstehen, ist klar, weil gleicher Typ so. Also die kommen ja wirklich sehr gut miteinander klar. Und es ist auch völlig klar, dass wenn Kani noch kanadischer Premier ist und es Newseum schafft, 29 nächster amerikanischer Präsident zu sein, dass das alles Makulatur ist.
Ganz genau, ganz genau.
Das ist doch völlig hane Büche.
Dann haben wir doch in Brüssel Ursula von der Leinji gesagt, America is back. Genau. Wie sie das bei beiden auch gesagt hat.
Und das ist das eine Szenario. Das andere Szenario ist, Amerika bleibt, wie es ist. Also man betrügt jetzt bei den Midterms, hat dann also nicht nur den Lame Darks, sondern Stephen Miller macht weiter noch zwei Jahre. Und danach schaffen sie es irgendwie, JD Vans zu installieren. Dann ist dieses ganze Gerede von den Mittelmächten, die sich da verbünden gegen das Amerika auch Makulatur. Vor allem mit dieser geografischen Nähe von Kanada. Also das, was er hier überhaupt vorschlägt. Was klingt, als hätte die afrikanische Union mal alles Selbstbewusstsein zusammengesammelt, um in Davos jetzt auch mal eine Rede zu halten. So im Sinne von, lieber anderen afrikanischen Ländern, verbündet euch. Genau, weil für die ist nämlich egal, wer in Europa regiert. Das ist einfach völlig log in, dieses Verhältnis. Und ja, diese Rede ist gar nicht historisch. Sondern es ist einfach nur ein Sonntagsreden-Momentum ausgetauscht gegen ein anderes Sonntagsreden-Momentum. In der Hoffnung, dass man auf das Alte wieder zurückswitchen kann. Und dann muss man die Rede verbrennen, weil dann darf man die nie wieder zeigen, weil das wäre peinlich.
Ja, ja, denn es sind so ein paar Äußerungen drin, bei denen man sich fragt, wie würde das 2029 beantwortet werden, wenn man dann noch mal drauf zu sprechen kommt. Gehen wir erstmal durch. Erstmal bezieht er sich auf Václav Havel und wir kommen der Wahrheit näher.
So what are our options? In 1978, the Czech dissident Václav Havel, later president, wrote an essay called The Power of the Powerless. And in it, he asked a simple question, how did the communist system sustain itself? And his answer began with a greengrocer. Every morning, the shopkeeper places a sign in his window, workers of the world unite. He doesn't believe it. No one does. But he places the sign anyway to avoid trouble, to signal compliance, to get along. And because every shopkeeper on every street does the same, the system persists. Not through violence alone, but through the participation of ordinary people in rituals they privately know to be false. How will we call this living within a lie?
Ja, also das ganze Bild stimmt einfach überhaupt gar nicht und ist hier auch nicht anwendbar. Denn die Leute sind 1985 nicht angstschlotternd, oh, hoffentlich werde ich nicht entdeckt, dass ich früher rausging, in den Top Gun-Film gegangen, sondern mit wehenden Fahnen. Und dann direkt die PM, Peter Mosner, das interessante Magazin, wo drin stand, wie geil der Turboantrieb von so einem Kampfflugzeug ist, das in Amerika hergestellt wird, bitte sofort kaufen. Und dann hat die Bundesregierung das den Leuten gekauft. So, und das ist gar nicht vergleichbar mit diesem Unterdrückungsregime, bei dem alle noch das Schaufenster bestücken.
Vor allen Dingen, wo ist das Schaufenster jetzt bei Trump? Es gibt ja gerade keine Fassade. Also du hast ja einen Ladnick da sitzen, der sagt, wir zuerst, ihr seid bekloppt, dass ihr Autos mit Batterien fahren wollt. Wo sind eure Batterien? Wir machen Öl. Lasst uns in Ruhe. Adam Tuus fragt, wollen Sie noch was zu Krönland sagen? Nein. Also das ist, wo ist die Fassade, die jetzt gerade abgepittelt wird? Ja, dass da vielleicht noch ein Armin Laschet nochmal so tut, als gäbe es eine transatlantische Partnerschaft wie 1992 geschenkt und irgendwann wird er auch lernen. Oder er lernt es nicht, dann wird es seine Nachfolge lernen.
Aber es ist ja völlig irrsinnig, der einzige, der mir einfällt, ist halt Jens Spahn, der einfach sagt, ja, da ist schon was dran, da ist der Trump da und so weiter.
Ja, aber das Bild nutzt ja gar nichts, weil es ja eine Frage ist, von wem profitiere ich jetzt gerade? Und Kanada müsste ja, wenn es jetzt diese Wahrheit ernst meinen würde, nicht nur verkünden, mit wem man jetzt lauter Handelsabkommen macht, was sicherlich Gute ist. Also ich bin ja auch sehr dafür, jetzt viel mehr auf Freihandel zu setzen, weil das in meinen Augen doch auch dazu führen kann, dass wir nicht jetzt alles militärisch lösen, sondern dass wir eigentlich versuchen, uns da in anderer Weise zu vernetzen. Aber man müsste ja dann eigentlich den Schritt gehen und sagen, und wir kappen jetzt irgendwas mit den Amerikanern. Das ist ja eh nicht mehr, dass jetzt jemand da sagt, wir sind für Trump, weil der unsere Werte und unsere Freiheit hochhält. Also das bekommt ja auch Friedrich Merz kaum noch über die Lippen.
When even one person stops performing, when the greengrocer removes his sign, the illusion begins to crack. Friends, it is time for companies and countries to take their signs down.
Da hätte ich gerne diesen Moment gehabt, dass das Publikum Fragen stellen dürfte mitten in der Rede. Um dann zu fragen, wurden wir von Bill Clinton und Barack Obama und Biden wirklich so belogen? Und es stimmt ja nicht. Also es ist ja einfach nicht wahr. So, diese große Abklärung, dass jetzt nach Jahrzehnten, wo wir uns Amerika emotional unterworfen haben, aber nicht die Kraft aufbringen konnten, zu sagen, nee, bitte heute Abend nicht verprügeln und so, dass man da dann jetzt den Mut fasst, weil es unerträglich wurde, sondern nein, hier hat sich doch wirklich ein Vorzeichen verkehrt. Und die wünschen sich das doch alle zurück.
Jaja. Ja, die wünschen sich das nicht. Das ist doch sehnlicher. Das haben wir doch gerade in Bezug auf Israel gesehen. Dass man da nochmal hoffte, weil Trump ja da genauso gepolt ist wie alle anderen auch im Mainstream, dass man da hoffte nochmal so die westlichen Werte durchsetzen zu können, mit allergrößter Brutalität. Du hast eben die Opferzahlen benannt. Also man ist ja sofort bereit, sich in eine Lüge hinein zu begeben. Man bittet ja eigentlich Trump darum, warum belügst du uns nicht wieder? Sei doch bitte nicht laufend so ehrlich zu uns.
Im Grunde ja. Ich verstehe das Bild nicht.
Das ist eigentlich eine Rede, die hätte erhalten können, wenn er jetzt sagt, ich will jetzt Obama eins auswischen, 2015 oder 16 und sagen, ja, Obama, du redest von Menschen, machst aber Drohnenkriege, wir machen da nicht mehr mit. Dann könnte man jetzt diese Rede so halten. Aber ich weiß nicht, was er damit jetzt meint. Das war aber ja auch Agenda von der Kanada und sonst was. Die haben ja alle immer auch gern mitgebracht. Das ist jetzt auch so zu tun im Nachhinein, als wäre man da eigentlich immer unterjocht worden. Für mich klingt das jetzt wirklich so ein bisschen wie so ein ganz stumpfer Anti-Imperialismus, der immer gesagt hat, wir wären endlich frei, wenn wir die Ami-go-home mäßig wären.
Das ist wie der Ludnick. Ich als Milliardär bin ja das größte Opfer der Globalisierung.
Ein Technokrat wie er im BUMO steht, der wirklich in all den Institutionen, die genau das waren, immer eng gekoppelt an Washington, alles machte.
Du hast ja gerade Trumps Ehrlichkeit. Er sagt ja jetzt, die Antwort der Schwachen ist Honesty. Ehrlichkeit. Man gesteht es sich ein, dass man jetzt Hilfe braucht, wie auch immer. Dann sucht man sich Freunde. Und das ist ja wahnsinnig interessant, weil das ist ja eine direkte Antwort auf, das wir ja immer schon scherzen. Ja, Trump lügt einfach nicht mehr. Der fährt halt nicht nach Venezuela wegen der Demokratie, sondern wegen dem Öl. Und da macht schon Stuart Witze darüber, dass man gar keine Verschöungstheorie mehr entfalten kann, weil ich glaube, die machen das wegen dem Öl. Und Trump, ja, ich mach das wegen dem Öl. So, also jetzt trifft ja auch so eine, also wirklich dumme Ehrlichkeit auf so eine doppelt verlogene Ehrlichkeitssemantik. Ja, also das passt ja schon gar nicht mehr. Und was hier jetzt wieder auffällt, dieser Text passt einfach nicht auf Joe Bidens Amerika, sondern nur auf Trumps Amerika. Und man muss sich immer wieder vor Augen führen und dieses Eingeständnis muss man dann mal sehen. Und das hat die Kaunin-Ammlinger auch am Tag, als sie hier waren, auch mal in so einer Story, weil nämlich diese Meldung kam, die Hälfte der republikanisch registrierten Wähler findet gut, was ICE macht. Und dann war so der Nachrichtentext, ja, trotz der Gewalt von ICE sind die Republikaner immer noch dafür. Und dann sie drunter geschrieben, nee, nicht trotz, sondern wegen. Die Leute möchten sehen, wie die Schwarzen auf der Straße verprügelt werden. Und dann sind sie zufrieden, weil dann ihr blockiertes Leben, ah, ich bin nicht der Einzige, der hier zurückgehalten wird, sondern endlich wird da mal zurückgeschlagen. So und dieses Trotz und wegen, also das wirklich ein Vorzeichen umgedreht ist. Wenn man auf der Bühne steht und eine Rede gegen Donald Trump halten will, dann muss man das und zwar honestly machen. Und nicht einfach so einen großen historischen Bogen, wir wurden ja immer unterjocht von der Barbie, Tom Cruise und der Geilheit amerikanischer Flugzeugträger. Es geht einfach nicht auf.
For decades, countries like Canada prospered under what we called the rules-based international order. We joined its institutions. We praised its principles. We benefited from its predictability. And because of that, we could pursue values-based foreign policies under its protection. We knew the story of the international rules-based order was partially false. That the strongest would exempt themselves when convenient. That trade rules were enforced asymetrically. And we knew that international law applied with varying rigor, depending on the identity of the accused or the victim.
Ich stimme vollkommen zu. Nur in anderer Hinsicht.
In drei Jahren werden wir hier im Podcast sitzen und diese Clips wieder rauskramen und sagen, liebe Politiker, der Kani und ihr habt es gut gefunden, hat damals gesagt, das ist alles Lüge. Fangt jetzt nicht wieder davon an.
Ja, denn dass diese ganzen Institutionen, IWF und all das aufgesetzt sind, um zum Beispiel afrikanische Länder in eine Schuldenzange zu nehmen und sie nicht daraus zu entlassen. Genau. Das ist so, dass wir kein Lieferkettengesetz haben. Das ist so, dass wir natürlich, das versucht wird mit einem starken Dollar, andere Mächte einzuhaken. Das ist so. Aber Kanada gehörte ja mit den anderen aus der westlichen Hemisphäre oder wie man es nennen möchte, zu den Profiteuren jetzt gerade daran. Aber wir sehen hier ist eigentlich so ein ganz merkwürdiger Gullismus. Vielleicht hätte das Brigitte Bardot auch so gesagt.
Also auf die Clips kommen wir auf jeden Fall zurück.
Und was kommt jetzt, sagt man jetzt, und deswegen machen wir jetzt eine ganz migrationsfreundliche Politik oder so. Also könnte man ja alles sich fragen, ja. Folgt aber nichts raus.
Also der Stub, der finnische Regierungschef, der ist ja der Einzige, der auf der Bühne sitzt und sagt, vielleicht haben wir den globalen Süden immer belogen und deswegen verloren. Vielleicht müssen wir jetzt darüber nachdenken. Bei Kani nichts davon.
Nee, Kani kommt ja sich als Opfer vor. Da ist es ja nicht, dass er da genau mitgemacht hat. Diese Infrastruktur auch gegen einstmals Verbündete angewendet wird. Vorher haben wir das nämlich schon die ganze Zeit gemacht. Also man hat Iran immer aus dem Zahlungsverkehr in den letzten 20 Jahren versucht, rauszubekommen, hat das auch geschafft. Wir haben das nicht zusammen gelesen. Es gibt ein Buch, ein paar Jahre alt von Gideon Rachman. Dort schreibt er schon mit dem Swift-Verfahren, das lange bevor der Krieg von Putin beginnt, dass dieses Swift-Verfahren immer mehr weaponized wird, um dadurch missliebige Länder auszuschließen. Wenn man das einmal macht, dann sind irgendwann diese offenen Institutionen, die man da hatte, und die Infrastruktur nicht mehr glaubwürdig für alle. Also bilden die ein, selber welche. Dann gibt es diese Fragmentalisierung, die stattfindet, weshalb er damals dafür plädiert, dass man das nicht so machen sollte. Das wir aber ja sehen können, auch in dem Buch von Nikolas Mulder über die Sanktionen, dass die Sanktionsregime in den letzten 20 Jahren immer stärker zugenommen haben, aber natürlich nicht gegen Kanada oder so gerichtet, erst einmal, ja, und keine Zölle gegen Kanada oder die EU, sondern gegen andere Länder, die man nicht wollte. Und jetzt, wo man auch selbst mal betroffen ist davon, jetzt fängt man plötzlich an, die ganzen letzten 20 Jahre so abzuwickeln, als hätte man damit eigentlich nie was zu tun haben wollen.
Also, Maurice Höfgen macht ja immer wieder dieses Argument, zu sagen, die Amerikaner können ja das Geld selber herstellen, machen sie auch, dafür braucht man keine Arbeiter, sondern da drückt man auf den Knopf in der Zentralbank, dann hat man Geld hergestellt, dann schickt man das ins Ausland und bekommt Güter. Das heißt, die Amerikaner haben eigentlich extrem davon profitiert, also sieht man ja schon an der Anzahl der Malls und der Berge bei Weihnachten, wie sehr und so weiter man da von der Welt eigentlich profitiert, dass einfach alles zugeliefert wird. Man muss gar nichts selber machen, man kann sich wie in Wall-E zurücklegen und das Zeug kommt einfach nach Amerika rein. So, nur, und das ist dann diese Saldenmechanik, die man sich so richtig praktisch vorstellen muss, der Zahlungsverkehr wird halt über die Wartsheet abgewickelt. Und wir haben ja jetzt gehört, wie viele Leute, nämlich 200.000, dort 400.000 Dollar im Jahr verdienen. Das heißt, dieser ganze Wohlstand, der nach Amerika geliefert wird, der musste durch so ein Nadelöhr, wo ein paar Sachen hängen geblieben sind. Das wurde also gar nicht ins Land distribuiert, sondern man hat den Leuten gesagt, ne, sorry, wir müssen jetzt doch ein bisschen sparen und so. Die Wortschied-Leute müssen nach Japan zum Skifahren fahren, sonst wären die unglücklich. Ihr müsst jetzt leider leiden. Also es hat da so Verteilungsprobleme gegeben, was dann dazu führt, dass die Profiteure dieser Umverteilung jetzt in Davos sitzen, sagen, unsere Arbeiter wollten verraten, aber nicht von uns, sondern von denen. Und jetzt klappt das alles nicht mehr. So, und sich das wirklich mal vor Augen zu führen, um wie viel Ecken und auf welchen Argumentationslinien der Kanye jetzt wie so ein Pirouetten, ich mache hier meine Kühe, zu so einem Standpunkt kommt, bei dem er ab jetzt in der Rede anfängt. Und deswegen werden wir jetzt Kanada neu aufstellen. Wir werden es, und das ist ein original Trump-Text fast, wie ein Unternehmen gestalten. Wir werden das Risiko diversifizieren. Und hier und da und so.
Dann zählt der Linde auf.
Das ist wirklich, eigentlich müsste man ein richtig comedy Programm daraus schreiben.
Kanye und die multilateralen Institutionen.
The multilateral institutions on which the middle powers have relied, the WTO, the UN, the COP, the architecture, the very architecture of collective problem solving are under threat. As a result, many countries are drawing the same conclusions that they must develop greater strategic autonomy in energy, food, critical minerals, in finance and supply chains. And this impulse is understandable. A country that can't feed itself, fuel itself or defend itself has few options. When the rules no longer protect you, you must protect yourself.
Also es geht jetzt doch eigentlich nur darum, dass man sieht, man ist also selbst an einem Punkt angekommen, an dem man nicht mehr davon profitiert. Das müsste er eigentlich ehrlichweise sagen und nicht so tun, als wäre das eine Frage von den letzten 20 Jahren gewesen. Das ist wirklich sehr eigenartig. Auch, ja, wir hören mal weiter, also der Preis für Abschottung, das ist natürlich klar, was er jetzt hier sagt. Das ist im Prinzip auch das, was wir schon hören konnten bei dem chinesischen Vizepräsidenten.
But let's be clear-eyed about where this leads. A world of fortresses will be poorer, more fragile and less sustainable.
Gut, was schlägt er vor?
If great powers abandon even the pretense of rules and values for the unhindered pursuit of their power and interests, the gains from transactionalism will become harder to replicate. Hegemons cannot continually monetize their relationships. Allies will diversify to hedge against uncertainty. They'll buy insurance, increase options in order to rebuild sovereignty. Sovereignty that was once grounded in rules, but will increasingly be anchored in the ability to withstand pressure.
Merkwürdiges Doppelsprech doch, oder? Er hat doch eben die ganze Zeit gesagt, dass diese Rules nur so, ja, halbgar waren, dass man die immer so angewendet hatte, wie man wollte. Und jetzt schwärmt er aber eigentlich von dieser Ordnung, die es da gab. Und jetzt, wo es sie nicht mehr gibt, müssen wir das dann über die Mittelmächte lösen.
Ja, genau. Und er redet ja vor allem auch vor Unternehmen. Ja. Und er sagt ja auch, also aus diesem Spruch hier macht er ja diese Schlussfolgerung. Und das sind wirklich nur fünf Worte, aber die gehen so ins Schwarze.
This is classic risk management. Risk management comes at a price.
Das ist klassisches Risikomanagement, aber er meint gar nicht klassisches, politisches Risikomanagement, sondern das der Unternehmer. Sicher deine Lieferketten ab, sorge hier für genug Research und Development, verbünde dich aber nur in dieser einen spezifischen Frage mit diesem anderen Unternehmen und so. Das ist eigentlich schon crazy, dass jetzt Finanzialisierung, Ökonomisierung, Unternehmertum, also alles, was wir bei Trump immer so kritisieren, da kommt so ein Unternehmer und der sieht das alles nur noch transaktional und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt kann ich einfach, das ist so toll, der hat so verstanden, das ist schön, wie er Kanada jetzt neu aufstellt und alle feiern das. Obwohl das wirklich eins zu eins des Programmes ist.
Und wir konnten das ja auch schon lesen. Wir haben im Salon ausführlich drüber gesprochen. Geoökonomie von Milan Babic. Der hat ja gesagt, nein, die Globalisierung wird ja jetzt nicht abgewickelt einfach, sondern wir sehen, dass es viel mehr ausdifferenzierte Verflechtungen geben wird, die so gestaltet sind, wie du das jetzt gerade beschrieben hast. Und das ist dann immer auch mit so einem geopolitischen Aspekt, aber eben nicht nur, sondern es ist immer das ökonomische Da, weshalb all diese Herrscher dort sind, um zu sagen, liebe Unternehmen, kommt her, wir haben euch schon ein Nest bereitet und wollt ihr noch einen Steuervorteil, wir können ihn euch geben.
Genau. Es wird nicht lange dauern, dann wird man einfach ganz normale Vertragsunterzeichnung haben zwischen Carney, der dann sagt, ja diesen Google Maps Service brauchen wir schon. Also wir machen den Vertrag mit und dann Google, dann kommt einfach Pitae dahin und unterschreiben wir das so. Dann stampft Trumpf irgendwie auf und stellt dann fest, so eine pauschale Zollsache irgendwie, ich chicken out und so. So ein Durchschnitt, wie wir es jetzt erleben.
Wobei ja auch wiederum klar ist, dass wenn man so jetzt über sein Land da spricht, dann geht es natürlich immer darum, dass so ein BIP steigen muss, dass man diese Konzerne glücklich macht, geht es darum, diese nationale Souveränität zu halten oder zu verbessern. Es geht jedenfalls nicht darum, dass es der Bevölkerung dadurch besser gehen muss.
Nee, die nur um die finalen Kennziffern.
Ja, also das ist das alte Prinzip Davos. Wie gesagt, der Slutnik bleibt der einzige, der von den amerikanischen Workern überhaupt mal spricht.
Ja, also jetzt wo du es so ansprichst, Larry Fink führt das Gespräch mit Karp und Elon Musk. Und die allerersten Worte sind immer, als ich Blackhawk gegründet habe, sind wir Public gegangen und dann haben wir so und so Gains gehabt. Karp hatte diese und bei Elon Musk macht er denselben Spruch. Er hat Tesla die Bursche geführt und dann 34% plus irgendwas. Irgend so eine Kennziffer rausgesucht. So und er ist wirklich kurz davor, ja also als Carney kam, war Karp da so drauf und dann hatten die diesen BIP zuwachs. Einfach knallert abgerechnet.
Aber das ist nicht, weil das jetzt ja auch so journalistisch so verarbeitet wird, als sei das jetzt so eine Rede, die Carney hält für die Bevölkerung. Liebe Bevölkerung, ich mach euch hier sicher oder so. Das ist nicht die Frage. Was natürlich stimmt, ist, dass diese Großmächte, also die USA, sprechen wir sie direkt an, wir nennen sie Carney, dass die natürlich auch eingeschränkt sind in ihrer Macht, wenn die Mittelmächte sich verbünden und gewisse Handelsabkommen machen. Also eine Allmacht hat man als Großmacht natürlich nicht.
Niemand hat eine Allmacht.
Das ist nicht gegeben, ja.
Niemand hat eine Allmacht. Die Chips kommen aus Taiwan. Die Maschinen in Taiwan kommen aus den Niederlanden. Die Teile für die Maschinen aus den Niederlanden kommen von Carl Zeiss. Und niemand hat eine Macht. Jeder kann von sich behaupten, er sei das Nadelöhr und alle haben recht.
Und wenn der Lattnick sagt, ich bin der Hammer, dann kann er das in manchen Fällen sein, aber ganz häufig nicht.
But that cost of strategic autonomy of sovereignty can also be shared. Collective investments and resilience are cheaper than everyone building their own fortresses. Shared standards reduce fragmentations. Complementarities are positive sum. And the question for middle powers like Canada is not whether to adapt to the new reality. We must. The question is whether we adapt by simply building higher walls or whether we can do something more ambitious.
Dem will ich sehr zustimmen. Halte das für sehr gut, wenn man da mehr auf Freihandel versucht zu setzen. Was er jetzt da für eine Unterscheidung macht oder was ihn leiten soll bei all dem? Nun ja, wir können das mal uns anhören.
We aim to be both principled and pragmatic. Principled in our commitment to fundamental values, sovereignty, territorial integrity, the prohibition of the use of force, except when consistent with the UN Charter, and respect for human rights.
Man hört das. Man ist soziologisch nur ganz leicht angeschliffen, aufgeklärt und man denkt sich, genau, also prinzipiell und pragmatisch. Das ist yin und yang. Wolfgang, das ist, also um einen 3-Nanometer-Chip herzustellen, braucht man die ganze Welt. Rohstoffe von überall, technische Erfahrungen von überall, freie Seewege überall.
Und da ist nichts Prinzipielles.
Jetzt kann man da rangehen und sagen, wir machen das jetzt prinzipiell. Spätestens nach sechs Monaten kommt irgendjemand und sagt, ja hier, schön, dass wir das mittig anbraumt haben. Ich finde, wir sollten hier auch mal eine pragmatische Lösung treffen, weil dann geht es schneller. Der ganze Raum ist überzeugt, genau richtig, wir müssen das pragmatisch machen. Half a year later, ich finde, das ist mir zu durcheinander. Wir müssen ja auch mal ein paar Prinzipien festlegen. Der ganze Raum schwingt wieder zurück auf, Prinzipien. Halb ein Jahr später, ist man wieder bei pragmatisch. Daraus ziehen Organisationsberatungen, die Bertelsmann und so weiter. Das ist deren Einkommensquelle. Dass man alle sechs Monate die große Reform vorschlägt, die laut Luhmann vor allem dafür da ist, zu vergessen, was man vorher gemacht hat, damit man das dann wieder machen kann, wenn das sich so eingeschliffen hat. Und das ist einfach, wir hatten ja diese tote Floskel, dass Floskel einfach leer gelaufen sind. Das ist einfach nur noch, also wenn man sagt, wir nehmen das Schaufenster, also wir räumen das jetzt leer. Wir halten keine Sonntagsreden mehr. Und dann kommt man mit, wir versuchen jetzt den Mittelweg aus, prinzipiell und pragmatisch.
Ja, wir müssen uns ja erst einmal konkret vergegenwärtigen, was er sagt. Er sagt, prinzipientreu bedeutet die Menschenrechte. Pragmatisch bedeutet auch mit Partnern zusammenarbeiten, die nicht alle unsere Werte teilen. Also das heißt nicht die Menschenrechte in dieser Weise sehen. Dann sei doch gleich pragmatisch, denn das andere ist dann wieder Schaufenster, ist wieder gesagt, und da haben wir auch irgendwas mit Werten. Nein, es geht da nicht um Werte und es ging vorher nicht um Werte. Und es geht auch jetzt nicht um Werte. Es ist unsinnig. Zumal ja auch so amüsant ist, dass er offenbar glaubt, davon im Publikum zu reden, dem man das so sagen muss. Also das frage ich mich immer.
Wir kommen ja auf Milet. Das ist ganz schräg da.
Die hören das doch auch so und denken, naja, was soll das denn jetzt für mich bedeuten? Also klar, der setzt sich jetzt ab von der Baerbock, die würde jetzt nur prinzipientreu rangehen und dann hätten wir natürlich auch keinen Chip oder sonst irgendwas mehr, wenn du überall sagst, aber da sind die Menschenrechte. Aber das ist ja wirklich unsinnig, das in so einer Weise aufzudröseln.
Ich glaube auch, nach Davos fahren, also keine Arbeiter, da sitzen nur Manager, die halt den Entsendevertrag für die drei Tage 50.000 Dollar Davos kriegen. Die hören eh jeden Tag zehn Stunden in den Meetings das, was der Carney hier sagt und wissen, ist eigentlich Bullshit. Und jetzt kommt er und macht auch nochmal Bullshit. Also auch ein bisschen dramatisch, traurig eigentlich.
Man könnte natürlich auch sagen, es ist der Versuch, doch eine Großraumordnung herzustellen. Nämlich zu sagen, die Großräume sind da und dann kann man auch Handel miteinander betreiben, aber man mischt sich nicht ein. Also das ist ja bei Karl Schmitz so, das nicht Interventionsgebot. Also es gibt diesen Text, ich hab den hier mal liegen, Völkerrechtliche Großraumordnung mit Interventionsverbot für raumfremde Mächte. Das ist ein Text, der auch im Zuge eines Großdenkens bei Hitler entstanden ist. Und dort will er natürlich, dass die Großmächte für sich da sind und dann aber nicht gegenseitig intervenieren. Großmächte meint er also nicht, man hat ein Imperium, das die ganze Welt beherrscht, sondern man hat verschiedene Großmächte, die dann solche Pufferzonen haben, Einflussgebiete, die müssen die nicht immer komplett dann mit ihrer Ideologie beherrschen, aber es muss dann so angedockt sein und das Ganze. Jedenfalls müssen Großräume ja schon Ideologieträger auch sein. Also sie haben schon eine Weltanschauung. Und da ist aber natürlich die Frage, wo wäre die dann bei Kanada oder wo ist die dann bei Europa? Wenn man dann sagt, ja prinzipientreu und pragmatisch ist das so ein Versuch. So ein bisschen Ideologie können wir mit reingeben, aber wir können ja nicht so viel machen, weil wir ja sonst den Handel nicht so treiben können, wie wir wollen. Die Welt zu nehmen, wie sie ist, darum geht es. Da würde ich wiederum sagen, ja, das ist ja dann rein pragmatisch.
So, we're engaging broadly, strategically with open eyes. We actively take on the world as it is, not wait around for a world we wish to be.
Ja, gut gebrüllt.
Kommen wir, vielleicht springen wir ein bisschen zu den Clips, wenn er im Gespräch ist. Kani wird nach China gefragt, wenn du mal das anklicken könntest. Denn es war ja unter beiden so, dass man doch eigentlich so ein de-risking erlebt hat.
It's the second largest economy and it's our second largest trading partner. We should have a strategic partnership with them in that, within those guardrails and that's what we've achieved.
And it is an interesting reversal, though, because I think certainly during the Biden administration, there was this sense that the Western world was trying to decouple from China, Or de-risk, at least.
Ich hatte ja zuerst nur darüber gelesen und dachte, die Rede besteht daraus, wie man sich jetzt China öffnet, um so richtig aggressiv, aber indirekt gegen Trump einen Punkt zu machen. Aber es fand tatsächlich erst in dieser Fragerunde statt.
Ja, er hat dann nur davor mal erwähnt, dass sie auch Handelsabkommen jetzt neu mit China haben. Wir springen mal zu dem Punkt, wenn er gefragt wird, wenn die Mittelmächte nicht zusammenarbeiten, was dann ist?
The middle powers must act together, because if we're not at the table, we're on the menu.
Das ist ja der Satz, der vielfach diskutiert wurde und kommentiert wurde. Da muss man aber ja wieder sagen, da gibt es ja ein Problem. Wir haben all die anderen gehörten, gleich noch Friedrich Merz, die dann immer betonen, Wettbewerbsfähigkeit ist das Entscheidende. Das heißt, diese Länder, die da als Mittelmächte jetzt beschrieben werden, stehen sich ja auch wiederum in einer Konkurrenz gegenüber. Die sind ja nicht einfach jetzt, wir sind die kleineren und deswegen sind wir alle nett miteinander, sondern die haben ja auch wieder konfligierende Interessen, was man ja schon nur an Deutschland und Frankreich sehen kann. Und dann sind wir dann noch gar nicht bei Europa und Kanada. Das heißt da so zu tun, als könnte man da so eine Kooperation einfach so herstellen. Erstmal klingt das so natürlich, weil man sagt genau damit man diesen bösen Trump hat, dem man etwas entgegensetzen kann. Aber so einfach ist das ja nicht im Konkurrenzsystem. Jetzt hast du ja schon darauf hingewiesen, Gavin Newsom sitzt da, wird eigentlich schon als der künftige Präsident von vielen so empfangen. Und ich habe dann einen Podcast gehört mit Scott Galloway, der sehr schlechte Laune in Davos hatte, weil er ja in seinem patriotischen Gefühl dann gekränkt ist, wenn er so Leute wie Trump auf der Bühne sieht, die Krönland und Island die ganze Zeit verwechseln, Lattnik in dieser Art erlebt. Dann will er ja eigentlich das gute Amerika sehen und betonte dann auch, wie dieser Gavin Newsom empfangen wird. Und man kann dann schon merken, okay, die hoffen, dass jetzt bald wieder diese Zeit kommt, damit das gute Amerika wieder da ist. Nun wird jetzt Kanye auch befragt, ob sich das denn wieder ändern könnte, diese Haltung, die er da jetzt gerade vertreten hat.
I was interested that you said basically the old world is not coming back.
And we regret it, but we're not going to sit around and mourn it. We're acting.
Klassisches Interregium, oder wie man das nennt.
Genau.
Man muss halt jetzt das kurz aushalten. Und man kann aber jetzt nicht drei Jahre lang so, keine Ahnung. Ja. Also macht man mal eine Duftnote.
Wir hoffen, es geht da weiter.
Mal an, das ist deine Karnik Clips. Dann würde ich gerne noch.
Das waren meine Karnik Clips.
Okay.
Dann kannst du jetzt mal.
Denn man muss jetzt diese Zeit überbrücken. Und vielleicht auch eine Chance darin sehen, denn ehrlicherweise, man guckt sich dieses Trump-Zeug an und denkt sich so, also hier sind ja schon viele Business Opportunities drin. Angefangen bei dem Universitätssystem. Dann der chinesische Überfluss muss irgendwo hin. Kann man vielleicht was billiger kaufen, wie auch immer. So, ne? Also es gibt ja die ein oder anderen. Schon allein, dass sehr viel weniger Tourismus in Amerika stattfindet. Las Vegas hing ja wohl sehr von Kanada ab. Und jetzt kommt da also wirklich null Leute buchen da. Das sind ja wirklich auch dramatische Zahlen. Was bedeutet, man muss diese Zeit, in der Trump das gerade runterreitet, bevor dann Gavin Newsome kommt, nutzen. Also es ist auch ein Zeitfenster jetzt, um Sachen möglich zu machen. Was bedeutet, Carney ist natürlich jetzt auf Brautschau. Also er ist die Braut. Er muss Amerika jetzt als die hübsche Dame vorstellen. Und das ist ja, finde ich, immer der witzigste Teil von ganz Davos. Wenn das so umschwenkt nach zwei Dritteln der Rede, also Blabla, Sonntagrede, Blabla, irgendwas mit Zeit down, ich hab's verstanden und KI und so, und dann wird plötzlich der Investorscall-Modus eingeschaltet. Und das war natürlich bei einigen Sprechern hier ganz interessant.
Since my government took office, we have cut taxes on incomes, on capital gains and business investment. We have removed all federal barriers to interprovincial trade. We are fast-tracking $8 trillion of investments in energy, AI, critical minerals, new trade corridors and beyond. We're doubling our defense spending by the end of this decade. And we're doing so in ways that build our domestic industries.
So, das heißt, man muss warm up. Jetzt kommt der Investorscall.
Canada has what the world wants. We are an energy superpower. We hold vast reserves of critical minerals. We have the most educated population in the world. Our pension funds are amongst the world's largest and most sophisticated investors. In other words, we have capital talent. We also have a government with immense fiscal capacity to act decisively. And we have the values to which many others aspire. Canada is a pluralistic society that works. Our public square is loud, diverse, and free. Canadians remain committed to sustainability. We are a stable and reliable partner in a world that is anything but. A partner that builds and values relationships for the long term. And we have something else. We have a recognition of what's happening and a determination to act accordingly. We understand that this rupture calls for more than adaptation. It calls for honesty about the world as it is. We are taking the sign out of the window. We know the old order is not coming back.
Also, einfach die Vorzüge vorgestellt. Das Finale der Rede, die allerletzten Worte, fand ich auch grandios.
The powerful have their power. The capacity to stop pretending. To name reality. To build our strength at home. And to act together.
Blabla, also das ist wirklich Sonntagsrede. Er fing an mit diesem großen Anspruch, jetzt nehmen wir das Schild doch zum Fenster. Und zwar genau wie der selbe Investors call Davos sprech, wie immer.
Hast du auch den Eindruck, man sieht da eigentlich die unfreisten Menschen der Welt?
Absolut, das ist ganz schlimm zu sehen. Vor allem jetzt, wo sie alle von Larry Fink vorgestellt wurden. So, das war wirklich grausam. Also wir hören noch zwei Clips, einmal März, einmal Macron, dieser Investors call. Das ist, worum es bei Davos geht. Hier Macron.
I want here to insist on the fact that we have a competitive, stable, low-carbon electricity supply. We exported last year 90 TWh of electricity, and a low-carbon one, based on our nuclear model. We have world-class innovation and research capabilities, and we will improve them. And we have one of the most vivid and active ecosystems in AI, quantum computing, energy transition, et cetera, et cetera. And a lot of startups and unicorns and large caps of these sectors are with me in my delegation today. And on top of that. Let me insist.
Also wir beide sehen jetzt das Bühnenbild. Links steht Macron, rechts sitzt Larry Fink. Und hört sich das einfach an und denkt sich so, ich habe ja dieses Businessmodell, wo mir einfach jedes Jahr eine Billion Euro überwiesen werden, in der Hoffnung, dass ich daraus mehr Geld mache, was mir natürlich immer gelingt. Und jetzt kommt ein Investor, jetzt kommt ein sozusagen Unternehmer nach dem anderen einfach zu mir. Nur wir reden ja hier von Staatschefs. So, ne?
Auf der globalen Ebene sind Staaten konkurrierende Unternehmen.
Absolut. Also wir haben es schon gehört. Kanye, wir haben die klügsten Leute. Macron weiß, wie viel Terrawatt Strom man für die KI's bereithalten kann durch das tolle Nuklearmodel, das man da hat und so. Und jetzt Merz.
At home, we are making Germany competitiveness again as a place for business and investment both. In the industry and our many small and medium sized enterprises. Let me tell you, the so-called Mittelstand in Germany has to be reckoned with. We are providing more targeted support to innovators, removing obstacles from their path and making it easier for them to access capital markets. We have reduced energy costs. The focus for our electricity supply is on a combination of renewable energies, storage and modern gas power plants. In the coming years, you will see massive investments in state-of-the-art power plants, power lines and heat supply. We will speed up efforts to expand and modernize infrastructure. 500 billion euro have been made available for this purpose. At the heart of our efforts lies digital transformation. Artificial intelligence requires industrial scale. Germany has one of the world's largest pools of industrial data. That is just one reason why we are investing in high-performance AI, Gigafactories, speeding up the expansion of data centers, and creating the digital infrastructure for a competitive AI economy in Germany. Our research and technology policy is guided by a new high-tech agenda. We are global leaders in so many areas of cutting-edge research. We want to ensure that innovation gets to market more consistently, building industries of the future. And whoever wants to invest in the future, let me be clear.
Ja, in der Liste fehlt natürlich, dass wir Deutschland auch die besten Podcasts haben. Ja, dann wäre es im Grunde rund.
Ja, holt die Portemonnaies raus, jetzt könnt ihr investieren.
Also es gibt ja diesen Spruch, wenn du nicht zahlst, bist du das Produkt oder so. Hier, wir werden verkrökert als Schwungmasse.
Also man muss sich das wirklich auch sehr bewusst machen, wenn er da von Wettbewerbsfähigkeit redet. Dann meint das genau das, was wir jetzt gerade erleben. Teilzeit, braucht man das überhaupt? Krankentage, muss man die bezahlen?
14,5 Krankentage muss das sein. Ich möchte nächstes Jahr in Davos sagen, wir haben nur noch elf Krankentage.
Ja, genau. Also das ist ja das, was bei Schröder stattgefunden hatte damals. Wir haben den größten Niedriglohnsektor und eigentlich ist das ja die Vision, die da wieder kommt. Deswegen alle, die da jetzt laufend immer wieder sagen, ja, aber der kämpft da für unsere Freiheit oder so. Nein, der kämpft um Investoren. Und die Frage ist, wenn hier so ein Großmachtsdenken immer mehr Raum nimmt, ist man dann dafür bereit für ein Großmachtsdenken, wo es ja pragmatisch und prinzipientreut zugeht. Also das heißt, Werte sind eigentlich dann doch scheißegal, ist man dafür bereit, irgendwas zu tun, gar zu sterben. Und die Freunden wollen das immer nein.
Wir haben eine neue Argumentation. Wir können gar nicht in den Krieg ziehen, weil wir da nicht mehr arbeiten können.
Das ist natürlich ein Punkt.
Es darf auch gar keinen Fall, dass Erwerbspersonenpotenziale, also wir dezimiert werden. Wie soll denn die Rede in Davos aussehen?
Naja, das ist dann das Potenzial, wo man die Leute herholen kann. Es ist ja immer klar, in den Krieg ziehen ja schon mal nicht die, die am allerproduktivsten sind. Also im Sinne von für das BHP.
Also Leute, die sehr viel verdienen, ziehen nicht in den Krieg oder die Kinder derer, die sehr viel verdienen, ziehen nicht in den Krieg. Die volkswirtschaftliche Rechnung. Wie viele junge Leute können wir an die Front schicken oder ins Biwak? Und um wie viel muss das dann mit Lifestyle wieder ausreglichen werden? Lifestyle Teilzeit nicht mehr. No Lifestyle Teilzeit. Das würde der Erterner auch auf Deutsch in der Rede sagen. Der Mittelstand, die Lifestyle Teilzeit muss er aber auch üben, sonst kommt er durcheinander.
Wir springen jetzt wieder nicht zurück zu Kanye, sondern wir hören jetzt kurz in den Podcast von Esra Klein. Der war natürlich wahnsinnig begeistert von der Rede von Kanye. Er hat deshalb Henry Farrell eingeladen. Der hat einen Begriff geprägt, weaponized independence. Da geht es darum, dass ja hier von Kanye angesprochen wurde, man hat dieses internationale Zahlungssystem, man hat den Dollar und und und. Und hat damit ja auch seine Partner sehr unter Druck setzen können. Und tut das jetzt in einer dramatischen Weise mit Trump. Dass der dann einfach sagt, dann schmeiß ich euch da raus. Oder ihr seid Richter. Habt da irgendwas gegen Israel entschieden. Dann bekommt ihr jetzt Sanktionen. Also das ist ja dieses Weaponizing, das stattfindet. Und davon will sich Kani auch in gewisser Weise lösen. Zumindest kurzzeitig würden wir gleich hinzufügen. Dieser Begriff aber, der da so fällt, ist eigentlich einer, der zurückgeht auf diesen Henry Ferrell. Und der hat wiederum dieses System, das da jetzt entstanden ist, beschrieben mit dem Wort Enschedification, das wir kennen von Corey Doctorow, der damit die Plattformen meint. Und jetzt beschreibt erst mal Henry Ferrell, was mit Enschedification gemeint ist in Bezug auf die digitalen Plattformen, die wir nutzen, also beispielsweise Instagram oder Google.
You've called what we're doing the enschedification of American power. Tell me about that idea. Okay, so this is a term which we are taking very directly from Cory Doctorow, who is a science fiction writer and general thinker, who is also, I guess, a shit stirrer, since we have used the S word already. And so he uses this to talk about the way in which the platform economy works. And so more or less his argument is that the platform economy, typically platforms start out as being absolutely awesome. You have these wonderful uses which you can make of Google search and whatever. It is beautiful. You have incredible access to information. But over time, the platform has these incentives to get shittier and shittier and shittier for the user. It basically, it begins to see the ways in which the users are not the customers. The customers are, of course, the advertisers. And so you find, for example, if you're using Google these days, you look up a restaurant. Google does not want you to go to the restaurant's homepage. It wants you to click on some affiliate link to DoorDash or somebody else. So you order via Google rather than the restaurant.
Und so weiter.
Ich dafür bin, dass wir alle eigene Webseiten haben.
Ja.
Nun gehen wir damit aber auf eine globale politische Ebene. Pharrell führt aus.
So, our argument is that if you look at the ways in which United States power and United States hedge money works, it's kind of like a similar system. That is that we are seeing the increased intensification of all of these platforms that the United States provides that the world relies on. So the dollar clearing system, we've already talked about the way in which the US is able to use the dollar in order to leverage its advantage against other countries.
Diese eigenen Vorteile kann man natürlich nutzen, aber irgendwann kann man das auch überreizen. Dann kommt man an den Punkt, an dem dann Kanye sagt, das mache ich jetzt so nicht mehr mit. Jetzt fragt doch Esra Klein, war das denn eigentlich immer ein Honeypot? Hat man eigentlich von den USA immer nur diese ganzen Institutionen aufgebaut, um die anderen Leute dann so, wie Kanye das darstellt, zu unterjochen? Da sagt Pharrell.
So I think the United States did not set this up as a deliberate kind of honey trap. This is not a world in which the United States decided we are going to pull everybody in. And then once we pull everybody in, we are going to figure out ways to screw the maximum amount of money and tribute out of them that we possibly can. But I do think that this very much is the way in which Trump and the people around him view the world. They do see this as a world in which the United States bluntly ought to be getting tributes.
So ein Tribute-System hat er eigentlich nicht gesehen. Auch vor vielen Jahren nicht, als Farrell mit David Crabber diskutiert hat. Der hat nämlich immer gesagt, das ist so ein Tribute-System. Aber ich würde auch sagen, was die westlichen Partner anbelangt, ja, mussten die natürlich dann am Ende Washington sich eher nicht unterwerfen, aber zumindest klein beigeben. But you have benefited a lot from it. That's different from the Western relationship to developing countries. But they have at least chatted on stage about this topic.
So I had this, I remember 15 years ago, I had this big fight with the late David Graeber, which was about whether or not the world economy was a tribute system. And he was saying, absolutely it is. And I was saying, nope, it was not. And I kind of feel like the last year or so, Donald Trump has been doing everything he can possibly to prove that it is a tribute system and to try and figure that out.
Das ist der Versuch, jedenfalls, der von Trump jetzt unternommen wird, in dieser Idee von Allmacht. Aber, Kanye hat natürlich recht, wenn er sagt, ja, wir haben auch eine gewisse Macht. Mal schauen, was wir damit machen können, wenn wir mitunter mehr Kooperation haben. Pharrell geht dann in eine endliche Richtung.
Now, there are limits, because the more that you do this, the more that other countries begin to try and figure out ways to use what the late political scientist James Scott calls the weapons of the weak. So they begin to resist in different ways. I do think we're beginning to see some of that happening. The more that you use it as well, The last other countries are going to be willing to buy into the stuff that you offer.
Ja, wenn man es überreicht, muss man aber auch sagen, ist das jetzt so wichtig? Oder nein, wichtig ist es schon, aber ich finde dann erstaunlich, dass die 90 Minuten darüber bei Esra Klein sprechen, wo das doch eigentlich auf der Hand liegt. Also, dass man natürlich so eine Macht in gewisser Weise ausspielen kann, aber dann nicht bis zum Exzess. Also, Monopolist beispielsweise hat ja auch eine gewisse Preismacht, aber die ist nicht unendlich. Ja, also sonst können schon auch wieder Konkurrenz entstehen oder Leute sagen sich dann einfach davon los. Ja, es gibt natürlich die Möglichkeit für Apple, das Smartphone jedes Jahr 150 Euro teurer anzubieten, aber wenn die jetzt sagen, es kostet ab sofort 3000 Euro, dann entsteht nun das Problem. Und das wäre ja so, wenn die das jetzt in den USA produzieren müssten, mal davon abgesehen, dass das mit der Manpower da nicht ginge, aber sagen wir mal, die würden es da machen, wird es 3000 kosten. Das würde einfach dazu führen, dann würden ganz viele Leute sich das Ding nicht mehr leisten können oder wollen. Und dann wird damit die Allmacht von Apple natürlich erheblich geschwächt. Und das übertragen jetzt auf ein Land wie Amerika. Ja, die können viel machen, aber die können natürlich nicht alles machen. Und deswegen ist ja auch ein Trump die ganze Zeit zu erleben, seit jetzt seiner zweiten Amtszeit, der große Androhungen macht und dann sehr schnell wieder zurückrudert, ja jetzt auch offenbar in Bezug auf Kanada. Wer weiß, was sich heute Nachmittag wieder ändert. Aber da ist es ja so, dass er 100 Prozent Zölle jetzt versprochen hat, weil Kanada ein Handelsabkommen mit China geschlossen hat. Und jetzt sieht es schon wieder anders aus.
Es ist ja eh alles so wirr gerade. Ich habe ja vom Stress, den so viele Leute schon erleben, schon gesprochen. Und das ist ja auch sehr lehrreich, weil man sich so grundlegende Fragen nochmal stellt. Weil du hast jetzt zum Beispiel immer gesagt, die sind so mächtig und hier und da und überhaupt. Und ich frage mich halt, und du hast ja auch schon die Frage gestellt, sehen die so glücklich und mächtig aus? Oder halt nicht? Und die Frage kann ja jeder für sich gerade beantworten. Also wir haben ja die Maritocacy Trap gelesen. Und angeblich sind das ja die mächtigen und glücklichen Leute, weil die verdienen ja so viel Geld und sind an Posten, wo sie richtig bestimmen dürfen, was passiert und so. Und dann haben wir gegenüber diese neue Nachwuchsgeneration Arbeitsmarkt, die einfach sagt, Freitags-Yoga. Isst zwar auch erstmal nur so ein Bild. Also traut sich kaum einer, um das wirklich zu machen. Aber angenommen, der nächste Jahrgang sagt jetzt wirklich geschlossen, Freitags-Yoga. Wenn ihr uns zur Arbeit zwingt, dann locken wir uns halt eine in der Arbeit. Und dann machen wir dort Yoga. So, wer von den beiden ist jetzt der Mächtige, der Glückliche, der Reiche? Das können wir entscheiden. Aber die anderen beiden Sachen, das ist doch schwierig.
Ja, aber eigentlich nur an Zahlen. Also es ist ja interessant, dass wir ja bei The Meritocracy Trap lesen können, dass diese Menschen ja überhaupt gar keine Zeit haben, dieses schöne Geld auszugeben. Also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, wenn mir jemand eine Million gibt, dass ich dann das verballern gehe. Aber wenn ich gesagt bekomme, ich muss die ganze Zeit der Entfremdete Arbeit machen. Denn das ist ja so, wir reden ja nicht von Leuten, die jetzt passion-driven sind und sagen, ich wollte immer das sein, ich wollte immer Sänger sein, deswegen stehe ich jeden Abend auf der Bühne. Wir haben es ja mit Leuten zu tun, die sogar sagen, in ihrem Studium, natürlich würde ich jede Woche zwölf zusätzliche Stunden eine unsinnige Tätigkeit verrichten, wenn ich dadurch eine höhere Qualifikation erhielte. Also in dieser Situation sind die ja dauerhaft. Und dann noch Fragen, wieso stellen sie überhaupt diese Frage? Es ist doch klar, dass man das macht. Also Entfremdung im höchsten Maße, aber sehr viel Geld und keine Zeit, das Geld auszugeben. Das ist ja nun wirklich toxisch in jeder Hinsicht. Jedenfalls würde ich auch dazu stimmen. Wir sehen da sehr unglückliche Menschen. Und in gewisser Weise sind es Menschen, die so sehr in Sachzwängen die ganze Zeit sind, dass sie ja nicht eine ernsthafte Frage Elon Musk stellen können, weil sie so sehr in den Sachzwängen sind. Deshalb würde ich jetzt sogar vorschlagen, dass bevor wir jetzt mit meinen politischen Akteuren weitermachen, wir erst mal zu deinen technischen Akteuren springen. Denn dort können wir Unfreiheit und Wenigdenken nochmal in ganz anderer Weise erleben. Auf jeden Fall. Und kommen dann darauf zurück. Wir würden nur an dieser Stelle mal darauf hinweisen, dass es ja noch den Salon gibt, mit dem man diesen Podcast unterstützen kann und wodurch man auch sehr viel mehr dann bekommt. Nämlich einmal im Monat sprechen wir ja sehr ausführlich über ein Sachbuch, das wir gemeinsam lesen. Und anschließend gibt es dann immer noch Empfehlungen von uns, Bücher, Texte, die man auch lesen sollte oder kann. Wir diskutieren diesmal ausführlich über das Buch Zerfall der Weltordnung von Patrick Kazmarchik. Wir haben schon von ihm Kampf der Nationen gelesen. Untertitel lautet Die Ignoranz des Westens und der Aufstand des globalen Südens, der nämlich wirklich nur auch peripher wieder in Davos vorkam, in den meisten Reihen überhaupt nicht auch nur benannt wurde. Wirklich ganz erstaunlich. And I am very excited. Das Vorwort dazu hat übrigens Heiner Flassbeck geschrieben. This is the book we want to discuss. You can listen to all of this. If we publish it in a week. Über neuzwanziger.de findet man den Salon. You can find the salon on the website by steady. Das empfehlen wir auch, bei steady ein Abo abzuschließen. Und dann ist man für 3 Euro im Monat dabei. Kann natürlich dann auch sofort all die anderen alten Folgen hören. Also, Kampf der Nation lohnt sich. The Metocracy Trap haben wir schon vorhin gesprochen. Dann natürlich die Besprechung von Branko Milanovic, der ja genau auch auf diese Ansprache, die jetzt von den Republikanern kommt, wir machen hier was für die amerikanischen Arbeiter, sehr gut eingeht und zeigt, wie eigentlich so reaktionäre Tendenzen sowohl in den USA als auch in China anzutreffen sind. Oder dass es eigentlich nicht Revolution, sondern Reaktion ist. Also, das kann man alles da hören. Und wer nicht bei Steady ist oder schon bei Patreon seinen Account hat und nicht jetzt noch zu Steady überwechseln will, kann auch zu Patreon natürlich gehen, dort ein Abo abschließen. Oder ganz praktisch für die, die bei Apple sind und das Haus Apple nicht verlassen wollen, können auch über Apple ganz einfach dort ein Abo abschließen. Aber wir empfehlen Steady.
Wir empfehlen Steady. Das ist am günstigsten, am vollständigsten. Und man kriegt einen SSF und kann den überall einstellen, also auch in der Apple Podcast App. Man muss gar nicht aus seinem amerikanischen Gefängnis ausbreiten.
Und ja, man kann das dann auch alles über Spotify hören, wenn man möchte. Das ist dann kein Problem. Das ist alles sehr selbsterklärend. Es gibt in der Regel nie Probleme.
Wir freuen uns über die Unterstützung. Wir sind unterworfen, aber nur weil wir wissen, dass es einige Hörer gibt, die einfach nur eine App zum irgendwas Hören auf dem Handy haben und das ist dann Spotify.
Das würden dann die meisten Menschen.
Ja, also schon die meisten, genau. Aber ich kriege dann auch mal Fragen. Ich möchte jetzt aus politischen Gründen von Spotify zu irgendwas Kronki oder so wechseln. Wo ich dann nur zurückschreiben muss. Sorry, wir betreuen einfach gar keine Dinge. Also auch Spotify nicht. Das sind einfach Automatismen. Aber es gibt den RSS Feed, der allgemeine Standard, der sich überall anhören lässt. Man kriegt alles, Kapitelmarken, Coverbilder, Begleittexte und so weiter und so fort. Also zu dieser Wahrheit, Konzerne und Unternehmen sind quasi mit den Staaten jetzt in Konkurrenz gehört. Dass man natürlich nicht nur Carney, Merz und Macron da hat, sondern auch Karp, Hasabis, Amodei und natürlich Elon Musk. Wer will auf den reichsten Mann der Welt verzichten? And Harari war auch da. Nun habe ich Harari's letztes Buch als nicht sehr lesenswürdig kritisiert, weil das quasi hunderte Seiten, irgendwer hat ihm nochmal Informationen zusammengesammelt, wie Informationen nie mit Wahrheit zu verwechseln waren, sondern nachdem der Gutenberg das erste Druckwerk vorgelegt hatte, war natürlich eine Bibel, wurden erst mal 300 Jahre lang nur Porno- und Hexengeschichten.
Der Hexenhammer ist ja das Thema.
Genau, der Hexenhammer, der ganze Kram. Und ich muss sagen, offenbar hat er unseren Podcast gehört und hat gesagt, ich muss mich nochmal anstrengen. Ich muss nochmal ein bisschen was reinlegen, auch unter der Maßgabe, dass man da nur 20 Minuten Zeit hat und die Leute nicht verstehen, wovon er redet. Das wird wahrscheinlich die größte Herausforderung gewesen sein. Dennoch, zu Beginn dürfen wir alle nochmal Harari jetzt, die alte Fragestellung ist doch blöd und was soll denn das und so, ja. Aber ich verspreche, es ist dann doch ein kleiner Dreh drinnen. Gerade weil wir dieses Gespräch von Harari auf der Bühne oder sein Vortrag und dann das Gespräch ja nochmal koppeln können, mit den anderen Praktikern aus diesem Themenfeld KI. Und da ist dann vor allem K. Palantir und die führenden Modelle von Gemini und Entropic und so gemeint. Also Harari, erstmal ein Einstieg, den wir alle gut nachvollziehen können.
There is one question that every leader today must answer about AI. But to understand that question, we first need to clarify a few points about what AI is and what AI can do. The most important thing to know about AI is that it is not just another tool. It is an agent.
So, zu verstehen. It is not a tool to understand, but tools that have an agency. You just have to make a decision. It is not a completely new computer. If, then, to make a decision. To do things that are target-oriented. Without knowing beforehand for which scenario. The software for that it is a text editor was already there, before you have all the word dictum subverted, how a footnote looks like now and so on. So a little bit the computer has already always intervened in the course of things, but not yet as it is now. That one says, okay, I can't keep writing here, you write the next sentence. We had it in the last Salon, was dann selbst in der Literaturwelt los ist. Nun gut, von hier aus allerdings, und Erinnerungen an Amlinger und so weiter, einfachste Wahrheiten, wie jemand hat einfach ein enger Gefühl in seiner Brust und plötzlich regiert Trump die Welt, ernst nehmen und einfach entfalten. Was bedeutet das?
If thinking really means putting words and other language tokens in order, then AI can already think much better than many, many humans. AI can certainly come up with a sentence like AI thinks, therefore AIM. Some people argue that AI is just glorified autocomplete. It barely predicts the next word in a sentence. But is that so different from what the human mind is doing? Try to observe, to catch the next word that pops up in your mind. Do you really know why you saw that word, where it came from? Why did you think this particular word and not some other word? Do you know? As far as putting words in order is concerned, AI already thinks better than many of us. Therefore, anything made of words will be taken over by AI. If laws are made of words, then AI will take over the legal system. If books are just combinations of words, then AI will take over books. If religion is built from words, then AI will take over religion. This is particularly true of religions based on books. Like Islam, Christianity or Judaism. Judaism called itself the religion of the book. And it grants ultimate authority, not to humans, but to words in books.
So, wir gehen jetzt genauso schlampig vor, wie wenn wir den Auftrag hätten, eine 10-Minuten Davos-Rede zu halten. Also eine Druckerpresse druckt nicht einfach nur eine Zeitung schneller, als wir sie abschreiben, sondern sie druckt eben auch 100.000 Zeitungen pro Stunde. So, und da liegt ja ein gewisses Potenzial drin, das Wort zu spreaden. Ja. Da kommt nämlich einfach so ein kleiner weißer Lieferwagen und dann wird das da eingeladen und dann drei Stunden später, ist ja schon auf der Autobahn weit weg und am Morgen liegt die Zeitung in Kiel, obwohl sie in Stuttgart gedruckt wurde. So, das heißt, wir haben schon, also wir wissen, was das Potenzial einer Technologie ist. Jetzt müssen wir einfach noch eine Übertragungsleistung machen. Wenn das Zeitungsschreiben auch von der Maschine gemacht wird, geht das ja auch schneller. Und dass eine Maschine eine Zeitung schreibt, ist ja nicht neu. Also eine Sportberichterstattung ist das ewig, Börsenberichterstattung und so weiter. Einfach nur die Textformulierung für Standardinformationen runternudeln. So, das breitet sich jetzt eben aus in andere Textgestaltungen. Und jetzt dieser große Bogenschlag historisch. Die Menschheit kam auch ohne Bücher zurecht, aber dann wurden halt Bücher erfunden. Und was wir auf keinen Fall abstreiten können, dass das Bücher als Prinzip alles dominieren. Also wir haben gestalteten Text als Vertragswerk, der wird dupliziert, jeder legt das in sein Fach. Und wenn irgendeine Streitfrage ist, gucken erst mal alle in den Text. Bevor sie sich verprügeln. Nur die allerletzten Fragen werden dann noch vor Gericht geklärt. So funktionieren Verfassungen, so funktioniert das politische Gefüge. Es gibt keine Schlägerei in einem Parlament, weil in einem Parlament muss man sich nicht sprügeln, weil das Parlament überhaupt ist nur dafür da zu befrieden. Das funktioniert über Text. Da kann man nochmal in die Tagesordnung gucken, kann man nochmal in die Geschäftsordnung gucken, kann man nochmal einen Änderungsantrag stellen und so weiter. Alles läuft über Text. So, dass er hier diese Pointe macht, ist auch auf die Religion noch mal runterzubrechen. Da haben wir natürlich im Hinterkopf jetzt, aber Emotionen spielen auch noch eine Rolle. Also der Gottglaube steckt ja nicht im Text so. Du könnt zwar die Geschichten lesen, die da drin stehen. Es ist ja, dass es auch Testament heißt, also so die Hinterlassenschaft, was euch bleiben soll nach dem und wie auch immer. Aber es ist erst mal Text überall.
Aber das ist ja erst mal was, wie wir Menschen einfach kommunizieren. Wir machen das über Texte.
Das hatten wir im letzten Salon, genau diese Gegenüberstellung.
Wir können auch, wie die Vögel kommunizieren. Die brauchen keine Texte, die singen sich was vor.
Unter dieser Maßgabe brauchen Menschen auch keine Texte. Und Menschen haben ja mal wie Vögel gelebt. Aber dann kam halt das Buch.
Naja, aber der Text war ja schon immer da, also das menschliche Sprechen. Der Text ist ja der niedergeschriebene Text oder der orale Text. Wir haben es ja, wir sind ja Textwesen, auch vorher gewesen, auch wenn wir nicht lesen und schreiben können, sind wir Textwesen.
Für wie viele der 300.000 Jahre Menschheitsgeschichte würdest du das...
Naja, das wir sprechen, ist nun eine menschliche Eigenschaft, die vorher, sonst sprechen wir nicht vom Menschen. Also man spricht erst dann vom Menschen, auch dann, wenn er spricht.
Ja, also der Homo sapiens im Sinne von vor 300.000 Jahren Afrika und so weiter, der hat sich jetzt nicht vor allem dadurch ausgezeichnet, dass er sprach, vor allem nicht, dass er sich mit Fremden, die vielleicht mal um die Ecke kamen, sofort in Sprache, also das ist schon eine sehr moderne Angelegenheit, diese Textbasierung.
Na ja, wie bald willst du jetzt zurückgehen? Aber sonst würdest du auch schon sagen, dass auch vor der Gutenbergpresse gesprochen wird und der Text offensichtlich sehr wichtig war, weil die Bibel ja vorher entsteht und andere Schriften der monatüristischen Religionen, zu denen die Philosophen da sind, das ist natürlich eine kleinere Zeitspanne, als wenn ich jetzt zurückgehe. Aber wir würden ja schon sagen, zum Menschen gehört die Sprache hinzu.
Ja, wir unterscheiden jetzt mal zwischen Sprache und Schrift. Ja? Wir haben schriftliche Dokumente aus dem alten Griechenland, aber nicht von Ötzi. Ötzi ist vor 5000 Jahren gestorben und die Griechen, ja, so kurz vor Jesus war es dann vorbei. Das heißt, ja, die Menschheit ist geprägt von schriftlichen Dokumenten, das wissen wir, weil wir diese schriftlichen Dokumente haben. Wir können aber nicht einfach davon ausgehen, dass diese, sagen wir mal, jetzt 5000 Jahre von den 300.000 sich auch vorher schon mal abspielten und wir davon aber keine Überlieferung haben, sondern sonst hätten wir ja schon.
Na, gesprochen haben die ja schon.
Genau, so, aber die Menschheit aus ihrer Stagnation zu befreien, in so ein exponentielles Wachstum reinzubringen.
Geschieht durch das Aufschreiben von, weil das natürlich in einer anderen Weise ein Archiv darstellt.
Das ist die Schrift. Die Sprache hat das nicht ermöglicht, die Schrift war es. Und er sagt jetzt, in Sachen Schrift, egal in welcher Domäne, ist uns die KI immer überlegen. Also wir können Jura studieren, aber wenn wir statt dem Kommilitonen oder dem Professor der KI eine juristische Frage stellen, wissen wir, die potentiell basiert auf allen jemals gefassten juristischen Texten und ihren Kommentaren. Und das ist eben neu. Und damit dominiert einfach ein neuer Agent die Domäne, die uns Menschen so stark gemacht hat. Also man müsste das jetzt ewig ausbreiten und ich halte es auch für sehr wichtig, sich diesem Gedanken jetzt fast in so einem Surrender-Moment mal zu erlegen, auch wenn man sich es gerne anders wünscht und so weiter.
Nein, nein, ich halte das auch für absolut richtig jetzt zum Beispiel bezogen auf die Juristerei. Nur würde ich ihm da widersprechen, wenn er sagt, man sagt, die KI machen doch eigentlich eine Art Autocomplete, ja? Gucken, welches Wort kann als nächstes kommen? Und dann sagt er ja, wir machen das Menschen nicht auch. Und dann würde ich sagen, ja, in der freien Rede, wenn ich jetzt mit dir spreche, dann habe ich ja jetzt nicht gerade darüber nachgedacht, welches Wort jetzt und jetzt gleich und noch gleich kommen wird, sondern da sind gewisse Reflexe, die da ablaufen, Wahrscheinlichkeiten, auch Marotten kommen dort zu tragen.
Sagen wir, es ist eine Blackbox, man durchschaut es nicht richtig.
Bei denen dann gewisse Worte auch wiederkehrend sind, vielleicht auch gerade dann, wenn mir nicht einfällt, das eine zu sagen, dann sage ich das eher anders wieder. Und das hat man aber eben schon mal vor einer halben Stunde so gehört. Okay, nur gibt es schon noch auch ein intentionales Sprechen, zum Beispiel dann, wenn ich es vorher niederschreibe und sage, ich sage es genau mit diesem Wort und habe mir etwas dabei gedacht, dass ich nicht trotzdem, sondern wenn auch sage, ja, diese ganzen Feinheiten. Und hier kommen wir aber in den Punkten ein, wo ich Harari widersprechen will, weil er manchmal so apokalyptische Szenarien aufbaut, dass ich sagen würde, er hat für diese ganz vielen Punkte, die er da anspricht, aus dem realwirtschaftlichen oder so Recht, wenn er aber dann auf die Religion kommt oder auf den Menschen an sich und sein Sprechen, dann sind wir eben nicht der KI gleich und hat auch das religiöse, nur weil es ein Text ist, der ja bis Luther ihn übersetzt hat, zum Beispiel jetzt im Christentum, keine Relevanz hatte für das Leyenvolk, ist das eben nicht mit der KI zu koppeln und wir beten nicht die KI bald an.
So, Harari ist dir viel näher als mir. Im Grunde redet er deinen Text, hörst du gleich. Weshalb ich mir das eigentlich radikaler wünsche. Aber ich glaube, er hat auch nochmal so Rücksicht genommen auf die Menschheit. Wir werden es aber jetzt entfalten. Wir springen kurz in die Fragerunde danach, wo er diesen Strang nochmal aufgreift.
I mean, first of all, I would say that Davos is about words. It's about talking. The basic idea of Davos is that you can change the world just by talking. Which I like this idea, because this is also my idea as an author, as a university lecturer. This is what I do. I talk, I write. I think I can influence the world with words. And this is now in question. Are we at the end of the road for words? Is this no longer functioning? And, you know, engineers and also soldiers, they don't change the world with words. They do stuff.
They take action.
Philosophers, scholars, also political leaders, they try to change the world with words by saying things. And maybe we've reached the end of that road.
Aber das stimmt doch gar nicht. Also Politiker versuchen doch nicht mit Worten die Welt zu verändern. Also die halten mal Reden. Und das ist auch mal ganz wichtig, um eine Wahl zu gewinnen oder um in Davos vielleicht ein IG-Store anzulocken.
Ja, aber das letzte Texte sind ja auch Worte.
Aber dann wird ja Politik gemacht, die dann in eine Textform gegossen wird. Man könnte es auch wahrscheinlich mit einem binären System machen. Wir haben uns mal irgendwie gedacht, mit einem Alphabet ist das angenehmer zu regeln. Aber das ist doch nur die Art, wie es festgehalten wird.
Ja, also...
Und das ist ja auch der KI völlig egal. Wenn wir jetzt die KI damit trainiert haben, dass wir unsere Welt in Farben und Klänge einteilen, dann würde eben KI uns eben Noten ausspucken oder so. Also ich verstehe bei ihm nicht diese Engschaltung, die da stattfindet, wo ich ja zugleich sagen würde, also KI, wenn sie, wo jetzt ja gerade eingesetzt wird, dann ja, also wenn wir jetzt wirklich vom effektiven und nicht von unseren Spielereihen ausgehen, dann sind wir eigentlich auf dem Schlachtfeld und dann sind wir bei den Ingenieuren, wo die KI ganz wichtig ist und wo die KI gar nicht mit Worten in dem Sinne agiert, sondern anschaut, wo kann man besser targettingen, wo kann man möglicherweise Ingenieurprobleme lösen?
Also bisher lief es ja so, wir haben Textgenerierung im Sinne von, und das ja Politiker halten reden, aber Politiker treffen im Grunde zwei große Entscheidungen. Das eine, was verbieten sie per Gesetz und was fördern sie per finanzieller Subvention? Ja. Und nichts davon funktioniert, ohne es in Vertragstexten niederzuschreiben, weil das sind ja Gesetze und, ne, also wir haben so eine Doppelbödigkeit, deswegen komme ich auch immer mit Semantik und Struktur. Also wir haben auf der einen Seite so Institutionen als Erwartungsbündel und sei es ohne Tagesordnung einzuhalten, bei der am Ende ein Strich drunter gezogen wird und jetzt Abstimmung, 51 Prozent Mehrheit ist da. Dieses Geld wird jetzt dahin ausgezahlt. Der Haushalt, wie gesagt, ist dann so das Standardgesetz, in dem diese, hier verbieten wir etwas, hier fördern wir etwas, also Geld und Verbote und Gebote, so zusammengedings werden. Das ist dann tausend Seiten lang. Und daran muss man sich halten. Wenn die Militärstrategie aus Amerika rübergeliefert wird, dann kriegen wir von General Bühler die Aufklärung. Das ist der Text, an dem sich die Verwaltung hält, wenn sie und so weiter. So, also wir kommen aus diesem, der Text ist es, nicht raus. Und jetzt stellt er dem gegenüber. Und dann gibt es ja noch Ingenieure und Soldaten, die sorgen einfach für Tatsachen. Also ein Ingenieur stellt einfach eine Maschine her und die funktioniert. Und wenn er sich vorher einen Plan geschrieben hat oder ein Rezept oder was auch immer, dann hat er es vielleicht für sich behalten, wie auch immer. Vielleicht hat er es intuitiv so. Also die Maschine macht halt, was die Maschine macht. So, und jetzt ist ja interessant, dass wir ja, und das ist ja der eigentliche humanistische Gedanke, gerne in unser Schicksal eingreifen wollen. Und es ist nicht gut finden wir niemanden anders, diese schicksalshaften Entscheidungen und Vorbestimmungen und Prägungen und Korridor schafft für uns. So, also wir drehen uns immer um diese Machtfragen und fragen uns dann, und das ist dann unser Hobby sozusagen als Podcaster, finden wir jetzt wirklich so mächtig oder ist nicht einfach der Yoganachwuchs und so weiter? Also solche amüsanten Fragen. Und jetzt zu den Praktikern. Amodai, also der Chef von Anthropic, sitzt hier im Gespräch mit dem Hasabis von Gemini. Der eine Hasabis hat erst jetzt den Nobelpreis für diese Forschung bekommen. Und wir wissen alle, den hätte es jetzt nicht unbedingt gebraucht. Wir merken selber in unserem Alltag, wie sehr uns das schon prägt. Dass einfach Sachen zur Verfügung stehen, uns entweder, und das ist ja das Neue, einen Text zu liefern. Da macht sich dann Harald Staunen lustig in der FAZ. Das sind nur nur Textgeneratoren, so als wäre er als Journalist was anderes. Oder sie schreiben uns halt direkt den Code. Also Entropic schickt uns gar nicht mehr einen Text, den wir lesen sollen, sondern schickt einfach komplett die Maschine.
Und da würde ich aber ganz kurz einhaken, bevor wir da weitergehen. Aber es ist doch etwas anderes, wenn ich schreibe und wenn ein Textgenerator schreibt.
Ja, aber du generierst doch auch Text. Das Resultat ist etwas anderes, ja, aber ich generiere auch Text.
Ja, aber es geht ja darum, dass ein Subjekt sich ausdrückt und seine Perspektive einbringt, während die KI nicht ihre Perspektive einbringt, sondern sich an irgendwas da gerade anpasst und das dann so hinmodelt, wie das gerade gewünscht ist, was ich hier dann sage. Und das ist ja ein Unterschied, wenn ich sage, Harald Staun, was ist ihre Position zum Thema, weiß ich nicht, Ja, aber jetzt mal ganz konkret. Migration in Frankreich und dann würde, dann könnte ich eine Position und eine Subjektivität abfragen. Und die KI würde sagen, das ist eine interessante Frage.
Ja, ich verstehe voll, was du meinst. Die Frage ist nur, klingt jetzt ein bisschen frech, wen interessiert es und jetzt sage ich dir ein paar Leute, die es nicht mehr interessiert. Wenn du ein Haus verkaufst und du brauchst einen Text, mit dem du zum einen das Angebot möglichst aufhübschst, danach den Vertrag wasserfest machst und einen hohen Preis rausholst, ist dir nicht mal egal, was der Anwalt, der ganz viele Erfahrungen mit der Textlande hat. Nee, das war eben nicht immer so, weil du jetzt eine KI hast, die das machen kann. Du musst auf den Anwalt keine Rücksicht mehr nehmen.
Ja, aber ein Anwaltstext ist nicht von einer subjektiven Stimme geprägt, sondern ein gesetzlicher Text.
Wenn du ein Haus verkaufst, ist dir doch egal, welcher sinnhafte und so weiter. Da geht es um, unterm Strich zähle ich, welcher Preis ist zu ermitteln.
Da sind wir aber auch in einem Bereich, wo es nie um eine, also bei einem Werbeangebot geht es nicht um eine besondere Wahrhaftigkeit. Und hier geht es einfach um eine Funktionalität.
Nee, weißt du, wo wir hier sind? Da, wo es Leute unendlich glücklich macht, wenn sie aus ihrem Haus 50.000 Euro mehr rausleeren können. Das macht die sehr viel glücklicher als 50 Romane, wo sich ein Autor richtig reingekniet hat.
Das bin ich ja überhaupt nicht.
So, das ist eine Domäne. Ich will noch ein paar nennen. Hausaufgaben. Wenn du vor einer Prüfungssituation bist, ist dir scheißegal, welcher Autor, welche Sinnhaftigkeit in welchem Text. Du willst einfach, dass dir die prüfungsrelevanten Inhalte so dargeboten werden, dass du sie gut reproduzieren kannst. Und die Leute machen flächendeckende Erfahrungen, dass es der Mitschüler nicht so richtig bringt und der Lehrer zu wenig Zeit hat. Was machen sie? KI. Und so geht es durch die Bank.
Aber du würdest ja zum Beispiel nicht sagen, dumm, wer überhaupt noch eine Hausaufgabe schreibt, wer noch zum Beispiel eine Inhaltsangabe eines Textes macht.
Nee, das würde ich nicht sagen.
Gibt das doch einfach der KI. Und das ist ja der Unterschied, den ich mache. Deswegen würde ich auch, also ich kann natürlich auch sagen, ich lese nicht mehr die FAZ. Ich sage einfach, heute ist Freitag, bitte KI, mach mir so eine Art FAZ. Und dann lasse ich mir was generieren. Und dann würde ich sagen, nein, da sehe ich schon einen Unterschied, weil ich gerne gewisse Autoren lesen will. Genauso bei dem Schüler möchte ich, dass der die Hausaufgabe macht, damit er einen Fortschritt erzielt und damit er sich selbst, seine Schreibensbewusstes und so weiter. Dass der Schüler wiederum selber besser damit lernen kann, wenn zum Beispiel die Schulaufgabe noch mal paraphrasiert wird von der KI. Das glaube ich gern, denn das nutze ich ja so auch. Ich lese ja auch manchmal irgendein wirtschaftliches Blog.
Harari ist ganz auf deiner Seite. Harari ist nach Davos gefahren, um gleich diesen Raum wieder zu öffnen, den alle schon vor 400 Jahren an Text verloren gegeben haben. Und jetzt stolpern sie unbemerkt in diese Falle, dass die Texte der KI ihnen in ihrem Leben besser helfen. Es kommt mehr aus den Kaufverträgen raus. Sie können ihre politische Position besser bei einer Anhörung formulieren. Sie können sich vor Gericht besser verteidigen und so weiter und so fort. Beim Arzt kommen sie besser in die Sprache auf Augenhöhe mit dem Arzt, weil sie besser beschreiben können, was ihr Leiden ist. Das sind alles Domänen, die sind vom Text dominiert. Und jetzt mischt sich da nicht-menschliche Agentur in diese Textgenerierung ein. Und das lässt sich den Leuten jedenfalls nicht normativ oder moralisch wieder rausprügeln aus ihrem Leben, im Sinne deiner Argumentation. Sondern das muss irgendwie anders funktionieren. Deswegen ist der Harari-Vortrag so gut, weil er es gleich macht.
Ich will es nicht moralisch rausbringen. Ich will nur zur Feinheit mahnen, dass du dann nicht zum einen betonst, dass es viel differenzierter von Harari gesagt wird. Aber dann gehst du so drüber hinweg und sagst, na ja, ein Journalist generiert genauso Text wie eine KI. Das tut er nicht.
Ich fand nur witzig, dass Harald Staun in der Sonntagszeitung, ich hab nur online gelesen, aber wahrscheinlich Vöter, Seite 1, im ersten Satz, und zwar nur um zu diffamieren das Wort, die Leute glauben so den, Zitat, Textgeneratoren. Und ich möchte frech anmerken, Harald Staun, für die Leute bist du auch nur ein Textgenerator. Nur für deine Family und Friends bist du jemand anders. Aber für die nicht mal mehr 100.000 Abonnenten deiner Zeitung bist du ein Textgenerator. Du kommst dort als Mensch nicht zur Geltung. Also, rede nicht so dispektierlich über Textgeneratoren. Insbesondere, wenn die Leute den anderen Textgeneratoren schon sehr viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit und Treue spenden als dir. Ja, das möchte ich doch anmerken.
Zumal wir ja schon hier festgestellt haben, auch das sei dir jetzt zugestanden, dass die KI ja zum Beispiel in wirtschaftlichen Belangen oft sehr viel vernünftiger Antworten gibt, als zum Beispiel in das wirtschaftsjournalistische Programm der FAZ.
Genau, zum Beispiel. So, jetzt aber folgender Punkt. Harari sagt also, die Ingenieure und die Soldaten machen irgendwie was anderes. Aber was genau machen die, so technikherstellen? Der Amo Dai, die reden jetzt über folgendes Problem, das sie gerade lösen.
We'll have a model that can do everything a human could do at the level of a Nobel laureate across many fields by 26, 27. We're in 26. Do you still stand by that timeline?
So it's always hard to know exactly when something will happen, but I don't think that's going to turn out to be that far off. So the mechanism whereby I imagined it would happen is that we would make models that were good at coding and good at AI research, and we would use that to produce the next generation of model and speed it up to create a loop that would increase the speed of model development.
8 Milliarden Menschen auf der Welt, die davon hören, haben eine Meinung dazu. Das interessiert die 100 Ingenieure aber nicht. Also, wir können uns jetzt stundenlang darüber aufregen. Ich reformuliere aber jetzt, woran die arbeiten. Und danach spiele ich den Hasabes von Gemini, der sagt, wir sind die Einzigen, die das auch können. Wir machen genau dasselbe. Es geht um Folgendes. Du hast einen Haufen Sand. Und du weißt, da ist das Zeug drin, das du brauchst für ein Chip. Du brauchst ein Chip, um überhaupt mit Elektronik dann Compute zu machen. Für das Compute brauchst du Software. Und diese Software soll sich selber schreiben. Wenn die Software sich selber geschrieben hat, kann sie wiederum Steuerung von Robotern vornehmen, die einen Bagger herstellen, die in den Sandhaufen greifen und der Maschine den nächsten Sandhaufen für den nächsten Chip und so weiter. Da ist also ein Loop, in dem ein, ich sag jetzt mal, geschlossenes System, eine Entwicklung beginnt, in der Menschen nicht mehr vorkommen. Daran arbeiten die. So, und jetzt sagt der Herr Sabis im Gespräch einfach, ja genau, daran arbeiten wir.
What is your sense of, do you stand by your prediction? And what's changed in the past year?
Yeah, look, I think I'm still on the same kind of timeline. I think there has been remarkable progress. But I think some areas of kind of engineering work, coding, also you could say mathematics, are a little bit easier to see how they would be automated, partly because they're verifiable what the output is. Some areas of natural science are much harder to do than that. You won't necessarily know if the chemical compound you've built or this prediction about physics is correct. You may have to test it experimentally, and that will all take longer. So I also think there are some missing capabilities at the moment in terms of like not just solving existing conjectures or existing problems, but actually coming up with the question in the first place or coming up with the theory or the hypothesis. I think that's much, much harder. And I think that's the highest level of scientific creativity. And it's not clear. I think we will have those systems. I don't think it's impossible. But I think there may be one or two missing ingredients. It remains to be seen how, first of all, can this self-improvement loop that we're all working on actually close without a human in the loop?
Es ergibt ja auch nur so Sinn.
Ja, im Grunde.
Also wenn man sich die Börsenentwicklung ansieht, wenn...
Ja, das ist das ganz große Versprechen.
Es kann nur so gehen. Also wenn sich dies nicht einlösen sollte, one or zero, dann haben wir den Crash.
Dann haben wir den Crash. Also wenn das jetzt in drei Jahren nicht passiert, ist Crash, weil dann ist einfach klar, vielleicht war doch viel verschwunden. Er sagt jetzt, also er spricht auch von diesem Loop, den sich selbst entforcenden Loop, der keine Menschen mehr in sich hat. Und er sagt, also Coding und Mathe gelöste Probleme. Da wissen wir, da können wir Antworten verifizieren. Da wissen wir, wann die Maschine richtig falsch gearbeitet hat. Bei Bio und Physik braucht man noch so ein bisschen Labor, Kreativität, sag ich mal. Und das ist schon crazy, finde ich, dass die beiden da einfach so sitzen und sagen, ja, ja, also uns geht es jetzt nicht darum, den Mensch so langsam aus der Arbeitswelt und dann haben wir hier noch mal eine Maschine, die ihn ersetzt, sondern wir wollen so einen Loop aufbauen, der von Anfang an ohne Menschen auskommt und dann alles herstellt. Autos, Turnschuhe, wie auch immer.
Die wollen das Perpetuum mobile bauen.
Also diese Idee, dass dann nur noch einer der Konzernchef und einzige Mitarbeiter einfach sagt, heute grün.
Hältst du das für irgendwie realistisch? Ich sage nein.
Nun ist es wie folgt. Der Chef von Mistral, Arthur Mensch, war nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob er Davos war, er hat jedenfalls, ich habe einen Clip von ihm, wo er im Radio ist. Wenn du jetzt sagst, ich halte das nicht für realistisch, ist ja die Frage, ob man den Loop wirklich komplett ohne Menschen schafft. Jetzt will ich noch mal Folgendes anmerken, ich habe es häufiger, die Mühle, die 1000 Tonnen Mehl am Tag mühlt, war vor 400 Jahren gar nicht denkbar. Vor 200 Jahren hat man dafür eine ganze Stadt gebraucht, die sie betreut. Heute sind es drei Ingenieure im Schichtsystem. So, das heißt, das, wovon die reden, das haben wir flächendeckend in ganz vielen Domänen schon hingekriegt. Nur, einer muss immer noch die Maschine kaufen und steuern. Ob man jetzt die letzten drei Leute noch rausbringt oder nicht, ist im Grunde unerheblich.
Ich sehe den Produktivitätszuwachs dann nicht, beziehungsweise die Kostensenkung sehe ich nicht, die dadurch entsteht. Es sei denn, man würde ja in Bereiche vordringen, die bislang noch nicht so aufgebaut sind, wie du das schilderst, dass da nur noch drei Leute sitzen.
Jetzt überlege ich, was wir gelesen haben. Meritocracy Trap mit der besonderen Beobachtung. Wir haben hier ökonomische Felder, in denen es derzeit lukrativer ist, für die Bank zu arbeiten, als sie zu besitzen. Ja. Und jetzt sagen die, das ist eine Zwischenphase. Es wird wieder lukrativer, diese Unternehmen zu besitzen, statt ihnen zu arbeiten, weil genau diese Arbeit, diese textlastige, juristische, mathematische, was auch immer aufwendige Arbeit, genau die ist, die hier ersetzt werden soll.
Dann müsste man jetzt eigentlich ein ETF für das Handwerk auflegen und da investieren. Denn das würde nicht durch das Perpetuum Mobile ersetzt werden. Dafür ist es zu kleinteilig. Genau.
Es gibt so ein paar Domänen, wie zum Beispiel Lokführer, Piloten. Niemand fliegt ein 800-Leute-Flugzeug und sagt, also den einen Menschen vorne, der allen Sicherheit und Vertrauen spendet, den müssen wir ersetzen. Es wird immer eine Ausgabe sein, die man noch erledigt. Aber wie sieht es aus mit den 100 Leuten, die die ICE-Fahrt stationär betreuen? Oder bei der Lufthansa irgendwelche Boarding-Abwicklungen machen? Du sollst ja heute schon hingehen und nur noch mit deinem Gesicht ins Flugzeug einsteigen und lauter solcher Sachen. Es bleiben am Ende wirklich nur Servicekräfte übrig. Für Servicekräfte gilt halt was immer. Für Servicekräfte gilt, sie sind vor allem austauschbar. Dadurch ist der Lohn extrem niedrig. Von daher, ich wollte nur kurz vorstellen, woran die so arbeiten. Jetzt kommt Karp.
Wo man übrigens dann nichts von hört, wenn die politischen Führer da auftreten.
Die haben ja mit Symbantik und Textproduktion zu tun.
Ja, aber sie könnten ja zum Beispiel das auch thematisieren, was das eigentlich bedeuten würde. Der einzige Wunsch ist ja, dass wir auch gerne von diesen Unternehmen, die an solchen Maschinen bauen, an diesem Loop bauen, gerne welche im eigenen Land hätten.
Genau, und ab jetzt wird es hier wirklich wahnsinnig interessant in diesen ganzen Gesprächen. Alex Carp zum Beispiel sagt, Nee, das muss jetzt in den Markt noch bevor der Loop geschlossen ist, was auch immer. Es interessiert ihn gar nicht so, wo an die da arbeiten. Er ist ja auf dieser praktischen Ebene. Und er kommt jetzt mit dem, Ja, am Ende, das funktioniert einfach, Larry, du machst doch selber nur Kennziffern-Politik. Und in Sachen Kennziffern schlägt meine Maschine alles, was ansonsten da war.
We're just in a lag where there's a lot of AI, some of it works. Again, if you go back to the battlefield context, like it most people, everybody in the world assumed this would not work, but now it does work. And so now the question isn't, does it work? But how can we get it to work for my country? And this is exactly what's happening in companies. It's like, oh, this company, it worked, mine didn't. What are you doing? Like, for example, I mean, if you want to just make it like parochial to us, Palantir barely has a sales force. In fact, it seems to be getting smaller every time I go see them. And it's like, and it's simply because you're laughing because you know it's the Palantirians here, but it's getting smaller and smaller and smaller. And it's not because we're trying to save on the unit economics. It's actually because it is a low trust environment in AI. People have tried lots of stuff. A lot of it hasn't worked. But if you've delivered stuff that does work, why do you need a sales force?
Also in Nürnberg gab es eine Situation, ich muss eine Zeugenaussage gegenüber der Polizei machen und meine Personalien wurden mit IGVP aufgenommen. Das heißt, da sitzt irgendjemand an einem sehr alten Rechner, an einer sehr alten Software, ruft einen Browser auf, in dem dann IGVP, und dann dauert alles eine halbe Stunde länger, weil man vergessen hat, zwischenzuspeichern. Wenn in diesem Battlefield-Kontext jemand wie Palantir-Type kommt und hier einfach muss nur noch diktieren, besteht alles automatisch, ist quasi Black Box, Magic, wie auch immer, kann dir auch egal sein. Dein Arbeitstag ist eine Stunde schneller. Dann sagen die natürlich, it works. Guckt die Stuttgarter Polizei nach Nürnberg und fragt sich, sollten wir das nicht auch machen? Dann sagen alle klar. Und dann kommen die Grünen und sagen, machen wir landesweit.
Ja, so läuft das ja.
Greift auch so ein Loop, muss man nicht mal sagen. Karp fordert jetzt regelrecht so eine Art...
Das ist ja sowieso das Allerirrsinnigste überhaupt. Dass wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel den Grünen auf Social Media folgt und sieht, wie die sich zu Trump verhalten, dann sind die ja kurz davor, in den dritten Weltkrieg gegen Trump zu ziehen. Zugleich lassen sie Alex Karp überall mitmischen jetzt und stimmen für all das dafür. Das ist ja so widersprüchlich, dass man nur noch lachen kann.
Es ist wirklich lächerlich. Die Grünen sind wirklich lächerlich. Karl fordert jetzt regelrecht ein Surrender-Moment der Regierungen. Nutzt doch einfach KI.
Their learning process in building how do you build this for sovereign governments is also a learning process for how do they adopt these technologies. So it's not just a technology, because if you're building a tank, like the British and then the French So, let's go back to the question that the Germans kind of optimized tank technology. It's easy to see how you would deploy it, but how do you deploy a system that's primary value is organizing parts on the battlefield without seeing the parts on the battlefield and seeing does it work, how much does it work, is it much better than we had, can we do things we couldn't do in the past? And then there's a hidden thing about software AI that a lot of the value, interestingly, people always assume the value is from where you are to where you should be. And that's obvious. But in most sovereign nations in the world, and we deal with almost all in one form or another that are broadly defined as, in it, that could be it, it could deal with a company that's American. The actual technological rigor of the enterprises has significant holes in it.
Und dann aufs Battlefield wechselt er mit seinen Bumblebee-Tronen. Macht's Erlingscarpe einfach umgedreht. And then he switched to the battlefield with his Bumblebee Throne. He just turns the card upside down. He goes to the battlefield first, then does something like, yes, it just works. We can't simulate it at home anyway. We just need battlefield. And then later you come into the normal economy and say, it's basically also battlefield here, right? Because it's not even our technology.
Ich will hier keine Verschwörungstheorien entwickeln, aber ich frage mich ja oft jetzt, wo das auch alles sich so zäh gestaltet mit den Verhandlungen der Ukraine, inwieweit auch einfach so Leute wie Karp und so gerade sagen, wir haben da gerade noch mal ein großes Experiment am Laufen.
Das wäre ganz ungünstig.
Also wir müssten zumindest da an dieser Kante, müssten schon noch ein paar Tests gemacht werden.
Wir haben noch ein paar Drohentests offen und Minneapolis, ehrlich gesagt, das sind auch alles, das ist doch absurd. Also ich meine, es gibt ja wirklich mittlerweile, also ICE hatte ja auch vorher schon Mitarbeiter. Und die sind jetzt mit diesen neuen Mitarbeitern unterwegs. Und die reden natürlich auch so semiöffentlich über diese neuen, die sie da haben und so. Das lässt sich auch nicht mehr lange durchhalten. Also das sprengt ja auch wirklich da ganze Bundesstaaten in die Luft. Und von daher, die haben jetzt auch ein bisschen Zeitnot da. Ukraine nervt sich dem Frieden. Minneapolis wird so langsam, also kann man Countdown zählen, wie lange man das noch durchhält. Also es ist wirklich alles ganz, ganz, ganz düster. Aber es ist halt so eine gewisse Zugkraft da drin. Das Zeug hat einfach so einen pragmatischen Prinzipienfreien. Da sind wir da wieder. Also da wird nicht eine Mode durchgeboxt, sondern da muss die Technologie einfach rauf aufs Battlefield. Und Harari sagt es ihm auch.
How do we keep humans thinking? Because if we keep abdicating our decision making, our financial decisions or whatever it might be, increasingly, increasingly to AI, the worry we have quite quickly, and we're seeing this with students coming to us through the school system, very overusing ChatGPT, is the de-skilling of critical faculties of human brain thinking. So what's your advice to me in the academic sector about how can we hang in there as humans and keep humans thinking, so that we at least have some capacity to live alongside these technologies, which as you say, bring us into a very different place going forward in terms of world order.
Schon wie sie diese Frage formuliert, bevor wir jetzt die Antwort hören. Wir haben uns ja im Buch gewundert, dass da in diese großen Kanzleien einfach abbrechenbare Stunden oder dass Goldman Sachs vom Human Capital und so weiter statt Personalabteilung spricht. Human Brain Thinking ist jetzt auch eine Kenngröße. Wie viel davon kannst du reinwerfen in das Projekt da? Wie viele Stunden Human Brain Thinking?
Yeah, at the present moment, we still think better. So at the present moment, it's kind of telling people, you need your critical thinking, you need moral evaluations, you cannot get that from AI. We need to prepare for the moment, let's say again, take economics or finance, when AIs create a new financial system, that they understand and we don't understand.
So, diesen Dreh haben wir jetzt schon. Wie viele Leute verstehen wirklich das Finanzsystem? Ob wir die letzten 500 die Märkte, wie sie dann immer heißen, auch noch aussortieren? Das wäre jetzt für die meisten nicht der große Neuerung. Nur, das sind halt diese 500, die Meritokrasie betreiben.
How do you train economists or politicians in a world in which humans really can no longer understand how finance functions? Because AIs have created this super complex financial system. That we are like the horses, you know, that horses can see that they are being traded from one human to another for a few shiny gold coins. They can't understand this idea of money. Too complicated. We can be in the same situation. 10 years from now. Davos, 10 years from now.
So, jetzt hat er dieses Bild des Pferdes, das zwar sieht, dass es für so Goldstücke irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die schimmern so, und jetzt gehört jemand anderen, hey, warum soll ich jetzt mit dem mitgehen, ja? So haben Macron, Kani und Merz über uns gesprochen. Ja. Wir sind im Grunde diese Pferde, die für so ein paar, die es aber nicht verstehen.
Ja.
Also für Davos hat er sich genau richtig.
Also man muss das sich so genau in dieser Traste klarmachen, dass er da.
So, und jetzt hat er hier, und das fand ich einfach witzig, weil er das auf der Bühne so.
Aber warum, warum glaubst du, wird das nicht so rezipiert? Also wir sprechen das jetzt natürlich so an. Aber das wird ja nicht so gesehen, sondern es gibt ja schon da wieder diese Idee, ah ja, da sprechen jetzt immer so Nationale wie es. Das französische Nationale wie Macron, das deutsche Nationale wie Merz. Und alle sprechen für alle. Ja, ein jeder ist dort, um für seine Leute zu sprechen. Das ist ja die Rezeptionshaltung, die wir finden können, wenn jetzt über Davos berichtet wird. Auch gar nicht mit einer sinisteren Absicht, sondern aus einer Selbstverständlichkeit heraus wird so berichtet.
Ich guck noch mal in meiner Notiz nach. Also zu diesem Zeitalter. 30 Jahre nach dem Holocaust hat man das erste Mal ein Bild davon gesehen. Und dann hat es noch mal 20 Jahre gedauert, um vielleicht sollte man das verhindern. Floating Gap. Also es gibt ein Gap. Das ist Floating, das ist Jan Aßmann zum Thema Ihr Gedächtnis und so weiter. Das kann man hier wieder anwenden. Es wird jetzt ein paar Termine dauern in Davos, bis man dann feststellt, ach so, das mit der Industrie 4.0 war ernst gemeint und nur die Chinesen haben es verstanden. We are just in the floating gap. We can hear him talking, but no, come on, there are no horses. That's the way it is. As far as you can hear. You can ask around who saw Harari in Davos.
You can see that in the call numbers. These are the call numbers that we have with the podcast.
That answers everything.
That's global.
Harari is standing here on the stage and basically comes to speak on this floating gap.
Will your country allow AI persons to open social media accounts, enjoy a feeling of speech on Facebook and TikTok and be friendly with children?
So, und das macht ihr jetzt in so einer Kaskade. Das sind immer wieder so Sachen, wo man sich denkt, hey, ist doch jetzt schon so, also wer macht denn die Wahlkampfplakate? Natürlich eine KI. Google bietet ja an, eine A-B-Vergleich beim Titel und so anzubieten. Und dann immer, ten years ago, das hätten sie vor zehn Jahren machen müssen. So, jetzt also die Rückeroberung unserer Domäne. Er betont also, die KI hat keine Gefühle, aber wenn man sie danach fragt, was Liebe ist, wird sie wahrscheinlich die schönste Erklärung bieten. Ich sage ja, maßgeschneidert vielleicht. Die KI weiß ja, dass ich mehr gebeten will. Also, wie ich es auch bombastisch...
Wie im Pluribus. Da bekommst du auch immer die Antwort geliefert, die du gerne hattest.
Genau, während du dann halt so deine niedergestaffelte, auf die das einzelne Wort kommt, an und so. Und jetzt kommt er mit der Wahrheit. Und jetzt interessant, weil jetzt hat er ja dieses Buch geschrieben damals, um einfach pauschal zu sagen, Informationen und Wahrheit waren immer unterschieden. Das sah nur immer so aus. Und das hat er jetzt ein bisschen aufgebaut. Es gibt zwei Wahrheiten in diesem Vortrag. Es gibt die Wahrheit und die absolute Wahrheit.
The Bible says, in the beginning was the word. And the word was made flesh. The Tao Te Ching says, the truth that can be expressed in words is not the absolute truth. Throughout history, people have always struggled with the tension between word and flesh, between the truth that can be expressed in words and the absolute truth, which is beyond words.
So, das Wort und die Wahrheit. Die Spannung zwischen Letter und Spirit. Juristen kennen das auch. Was ist eigentlich gemeint mit dem juristischen Text? Muss ich mal den Richter klären und so? Und dann versucht man das in und dann eben theatralischer Darbietung vor Gericht irgendwie zu erkämpfen, die Deutungshoheit zu erlangen. Das ist ja auch der Sinn einer politischen Rede oder auch der politischen Lüge, während man dann hintenrum einfach Gesetze macht, die komplett dem widersprechen, was man so macht. Es gibt also eine Wahrheit jenseits der Worte. Jetzt sind wir also wieder in deiner Domäne. Und es ist ja interessant, dass er das so in Davos aufbringt.
This tension between spirit and letter existed in every religion, every legal system, even every person.
So, wir haben es also künftig nicht nur mit Politikern, Wir sind ja die Menschen, die uns Reden erhalten mit Thema Lifestyle, irgendwas und so. Und wir sagen dann, no, ich opponiere, sondern wir müssen jetzt diese Selbstbehauptung auch im Sinne von mein Spirit ist gerade irgendwie anders gegen die Maschinen behaupten, wozu auch erst mal gehört Maschinen erkennen. Und hier finde ich es wahnsinnig interessant. Wir kennen ja Realität der Massenmedien von Luhmann. Alles, was wir über die Welt wissen, in der wir leben, wissen wir aus den Massenmedien, woher sonst selbst die Leute, mit denen wir darüber reden, wissen das ja aus den Massenmedien. Ich meine, wir reden über Minneapolis. Das ist 10.000 Kilometer von hier. Aber es hat ja doch eine prägende, gestaltende Kraft. Und nun haben wir eine Realität der KI geprägten Massenmedien.
AIs will soon be the origin of maybe most of the words in our minds. AIs will must produce thoughts by assembling words, symbols, images, and other language tokens into new combinations. Where the humans will still have a place in that world depends on the place we assign our non-verbal feelings and our ability to embody wisdom that cannot be expressed in words. If we continue to define ourselves by our ability to think in words, our identity will collapse.
Das ist natürlich eine große Herausforderung, jenseits der Worte Gefühle gewähren zu lassen. Gerade dann auch, wenn jemand nicht in der Lage ist, sie so eloquent wie eine Maschine auszudrücken, sich dann sozusagen nicht der Maschinenwahrheit zu ergeben, weil die Grammatik stimmt und die Eloquenz ist intelligent.
Aber eine Situation, die wir vorfinden, zum Beispiel in Liebesbeziehungen, ist es häufig so. Also man greift ja genau dann auch auf so Formulierungen. Mir fehlen die Worte.
Störgefühle, mir fehlen die Worte.
Also eine Zuneigung kann ziemlich wortlos ausgedrückt werden oder eher Worte können störend werden. Zumal ja sehr viele Menschen gar nicht davon leben, dass sie ihre Sprache laufend einsetzen, zum Beispiel um einen Podcast voll zu quatschen oder um ein Buch zu schreiben, sondern sie nutzen ihre Sprache ziemlich funktional und sind da auch mitunter gar nicht so sensibilisiert bei der Nutzung der Sprache. Nutzen die eher in funktionaler Weise, können aber dann auf andere Weise was ausdrücken. Oder man muss ja nur in einen Club gehen, da hilft es, nonverbalerotiker zu sein, denn mit Sprechen kommt man da jetzt nicht so weiter, wenn die Musik zu laut ist.
Genau, und jetzt kommt Elon Musk. Wir hören einen kleinen Ausschnitt. Den Rest machen wir vielleicht später mal oder so, weil es wirklich unerträglich. Elon Musk hat letztes Jahr rechnerisch 600.000 Menschen auf dem Gewissen. Also er hat einfach USAID gekillt, völlig planlos. Es konnte gar keinen großen Anschluss gefunden werden. China baut jetzt natürlich alles nach. Diese politische Diskussion kennen wir. Er hat Amerika durchgründet mit diesem Doshzeug und so. Und das sie ihn einfach in Davos so begrüßen.
Die Entwicklungsgelder gestrichen.
Genau, der ganze Traum. Also, es ist ja wirklich unfassbar einfach. Und jetzt hören wir aber mal im Zuge unserer Argumentation, was Elon Musk automatisieren möchte.
But if you have billions of humanoid robots, I think there will be. I think everyone on earth is going to have one and going to want one. Because who wouldn't want a robot to, you know, assuming it's very safe, watch over your kids, take care of your pets. If you have elderly parents, a lot of friends of mine said they have elderly parents. It's very difficult to take care of them. And expensive. Yeah, it's expensive. And it's expensive. And there just aren't enough people to take care of the, there aren't enough young people to take care of the old people.
Kindererziehung, Altenpflege, kümmern ums Haustier.
Also all das Zwischenmenschliche nehmen wir einfach raus.
Es gibt diesen, der zirkuliert so ein bisschen auf Instagram, als Frage einfacher. Und die finde ich aber sehr gut. Nämlich wurde uns nicht versprochen, dass die KI unsere Arbeit erledigt, aber jetzt malt sie unsere Bilder und macht unsere Filme. Ja. So, das heißt, genau die falsche Aufgabe. Und es ist hier auch, man fragt sich so ein bisschen, wie weit kann man sich mit Drogen im eigenen Kopf ins Ego abseits schießen, um überhaupt nicht mehr an dieser Menschheit teilzunehmen?
Ja, das ist eigentlich eine schöne Idee. Wir können dann mit Reinhold Wirth und Friedrich Merz 80 Stunden arbeiten gehen.
Weil der Roboter kümmert sich ja um die Mutter zu Hause.
Und um die Kinder und um das Haustier. Sehen wir dann alles nicht mehr, aber der Roboter hat sich drum gekümmert. Das ist die Vorstellung, die davor herrscht.
Das ist wirklich, also, Elon Musk ist einfach die dümmste Person der Welt. Der ist so dumm, der versteht es einfach nicht. Ich habe das immer so im Ohr erzählt, er rutscht mir das manchmal raus. Ich bin durch Wien gelaufen im Dezember und mir kam so eine Frau entgegen. Und wir hörten einfach nur, nur diesen Ausschnitt. Also es war wirklich wie so eine Fügung. Die sie am Telefon sagt, du bist so dumm, wenn du das machst. Und das habe ich seitdem in so einem Ohr jetzt seit so zwei Monaten.
So dumm, so dumm.
Dass ich einfach so Sachen sehe und denke, du bist so dumm, dass du das machst. Ja, wirklich so ein Wiener. Es war genau dieser Ausschnitt. Also in der Ansicht, das ist einfach so wahnsinnig dumm. Also mehr Sinn austreiben aus allem kann man überhaupt nicht.
Ja, es ist eine interessante Vorstellung auch, was eigentlich dann damit gewonnen wäre. Also, für wen, für was. Das wäre die erste Frage, die man sich stellen würde.
Was ist hier der Win, Elon? Also, man muss so hart in Känze von denken. Das ergibt uns keinen Sinn.
Ja, ich will jemanden, der sehr viele Kinder hat, was ja interessant ist.
Die er nicht sieht. Also, für ihn ist das ja alles Realität. So geistig auf dem Mond irgendwo rumzuschweben. So, Larry Fink sitzt jetzt Karp gegenüber und fragt ihn auch, die kommen über so ein Ding. Und das ist natürlich mein Lieblingsthema.
Because they're so good at fighting.
Ah ja, das fasse ich mal kurz zusammen. Also die Dominanz wird wohl Amerika und China sein, weil die jetzt mit der Technologie und Russland, weil die so gut sind im Kämpfen. Also hier ist man schon voll in der Recht des Stärkeren und so weiter. Logik, da gibt's gar nichts mehr. So, wir haben uns ja gewundert, als wir Carps Buch gelesen haben, warum er Jürgen Habermas, bei dem er ja selbst gelernt hat, so fundamental falsch verstanden hat. Hier kommt die Erklärung.
A part of Germany, And I really care about Europe. And especially the German parts of Europe. Where I had many of my best years. I still fantasize of going back to grad school. For not, for the learning reasons. And...
You're going to have more fun?
I had so much fun. We won't go into that. But it's like endless. Sometimes when I'm traveling across the country, I just think of grad school.
Dann könnte man nicht einfach genau so leben. I'm on vacation until the end of my life.
Jetzt kommt wieder deine Museum-Europa-Idee.
Das steckt natürlich hier drin. Ganz Europa in ein Museum umwandeln mit dem Vorteil. Es ist keine Plage mehr, sondern jeder, der will, kann so ein Gewerbe anbieten.
Ja.
Also Stefan, ich gebe dir jetzt einen ganz kleinen Vorschlag, weil du das Thema ja immer wieder aufbringst. Du kannst das machen, aber dann musst du eine sozialistische Wirtschaft einführen. Ja, da habe ich, also von mir aus. Dann geht das nur so. Dann sagen wir, wir haben ja einen enormen materiellen Reichtum da. Wir haben auch sehr viel Know-how, wir haben Handwerk und all das. Wir haben auch die Möglichkeit, unsere Ernährung in Europa zu sichern.
Mir geht es auch nach dem, der Loop beschlossen ist.
Ja, ich will das so sagen. Dann könnte man sagen, man muss das sozialistisch organisieren, dann können wir die Arbeitszeit drastisch reduzieren, pflegen dann in der freien Zeit, die wir haben, die Denkmäler und Kirchen und all das, was steht, und gehen dann einer Zukunft entgegen, die nicht mehr darauf so stark aus ist, Produktivitätsgewinne zu erzielen, wie Alex Karp sich das vorstellt.
Also da bin ich doch total dafür.
Will ich nur sagen, da muss man die aber anders organisieren, weil solange man natürlich eine profitgetriebene Wirtschaft hat, die in einer internationalen Konkurrenz steht, funktioniert der Museumsgedanke nur bis zum touristischen Gedanken und darüber hinaus dann aber nicht.
Also ich schwäche den Vorschlag ein bisschen ab. Wenn es Kommunen aufgrund politischer Hoheit, die heute eben in Bund und Land liegt, gelänge, die Wertschöpfung, die in ihren Städten passiert, in der Stadt zu halten, könnte man das auch einfach marktwirtschaftlich organisieren. Also dann bräuchte man nicht das sozialistische Dekret von oben, weil dann würde man nämlich einfach sagen, sorry, aber diese drei Milliardäre, die hier einen Kampf um die beste Kulinarik mit drei Sterneköchen in sieben Restaurants kämpfen, das Geld könne man auch besser in der Breite.
Ja, das ist aber dann schon auch eine sozialistische Wirtschaft. Ich meine auch nicht im Sinne einer zentralen Planwirtschaft. Das wäre sicherlich unsinnig. Gerade in einem so föderalen Land wie Deutschland, das ist mit so unterschiedlichen Regionen. Aber man könnte natürlich auf einer regionalen Ebene noch Organisationen erstellen, wo zum Beispiel so etwas nicht stattfindet. Also so viele Missallokationen, mit denen irgendwelche tollen Sterne Prestige für Milliardäre geschaffen wird, während man eigentlich für alle gutes Essen anbieten könnte. Das könnte man natürlich organisieren.
Von daher, das sind alles nur ein paar politische Entscheidungen, die man halt mal treffen müsste, wenn man sich dem Stress entledigt und einfach mal ein ehrliches Wort findet. So, aus diesem Themenblock hören wir noch ein Clip. Der Hasabis wird gefragt aus dem Publikum, was er denn von dieser Idee hält, dass man eventuell als Zivilisation den technischen Fortschritt ab gewissen Punkten gar nicht überleben kann. Es gibt da auch ein Wort für, ich hab's jetzt nicht nachgeschlagen, wer gut zuhört. Das ist natürlich auch immer, die sind sehr vornehm, die Briten, die stottern ja immer so komisch. Man hört jetzt gleich, was ich meine. Aber wie er auch darüber schmunzeln muss, finde ich ganz witzig.
I wanted to ask a slightly philosophical question. The sort of strongest argument for doomerism to me is the Fermi paradox, the idea that we don't see intelligent life in our galaxy. I was wondering if you guys have any thoughts on that.
Yeah, I've thought a lot about that. That can't be the reason, because we should see all the AIs that have... So, just so everyone knows, the idea is, well, it's sort of unclear why that would happen. So, if the reason there's a Fermi paradox, there are no aliens, because they get taken out by their own technology, we should be seeing paper clips coming towards us from some part of the galaxy. And apparently we don't. We don't see any structures. Dyson spheres, nothing. Whether they're AI or biological. So to me, there has to be a different answer to Fermi's part. I have my own theories about that. But it's out of scope for the next minute. But I just feel like... My feeling is that we're past the great filter. It was probably multi-cellular life, if I would have to guess. It was incredibly hard for biology to evolve that. So, there isn't a comfort of like what's going to happen next. I think it's for us to write as humanity, what's going to happen.
So, also das Szenario ist ja immer aliens kommen von außen, fallen über die Welt her, sie berumpeln uns geradezu, nutzen uns aus, töten uns, nutzen unsere Ressourcen, wie auch immer. Jetzt hat er hier dieses, also die reden über dieses alternative Szenario, dass man von der eigenen Technologie Schachmatt gesetzt wird, weil sie einfach, also das Matrix-Szenario.
Bitte um die Büroklammern da wieder.
Die Büroklammern zum Beispiel, genau, darüber macht es sich auch lustig. Also man hat jetzt nicht aus dem Weltraum Büroklammern auf uns zu fliegen sehen und so. So, und in Amerika wird ja noch mehr als in England, ich glaube, es ist eine amerikanische Art, von Ausländern als Aliens gesprochen. Deshalb das deutsche Hörgel, man denkt dann immer gleich an, die reden jetzt von Independence Day im Sinne von Roland Emmerich, wenn sie von Aliens reden, obwohl es nur um Mexikaner geht oder sowas. Und der Harari macht eine wunderbare Debatte auf. Zum Thema, sollten wir KI, das Aufkommen von KI-Agenten, er hat ja auch von den natürlichen und dann eben neuen juristischen, elektronischen Personen gesprochen, nicht auch in diesem Maße von Immigrants reden. Also eine Migrationspolitik machen. Also wirklich hervorragendes Gedankenbild. Wir leiten es mal ein mit Karp. So, 80% der Belegschaft rausschmeißen und trotzdem mehr Umsatz machen.
Now, it can take a week.
Let me further that question, though. I'm sure it's on the minds of some people here. Is AI going to create jobs or destroy jobs overall?
Yeah, I think one of the unfortunate things of the narrative in the West is it will destroy humanity's jobs of like... You went to an elite school, and you studied philosophy. Use myself as an example.
I did too.
Dieser kleine Nachsatz, ja, das war ja immer schwierig, ein Philosophiestudium am Arbeitsplatz zu platzieren. Ja, genau. Und das ist heute, finde ich jetzt nicht grundsätzlich anders als damals, nur weil hier unsere Sachen passieren. Also in der Ansicht ist es auch so ein bisschen bescheuert irgendwie, dass immer Leute, die die Milliarden haben und das Studium hinter sich haben und so weiter, den Leuten dann einreden, nee, sei mal zufrieden mit, dass du nur Mieter bist das ganze Leben und bitte schick deine Kinder nicht auf eine höhere Schule. Ja. Das ist ja wirklich so eine verlogene Ansprache.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, weil wir ja in den letzten Jahren immer erlebt haben, dass gerade in solchen Berufen dann, ja, Talente entstehen, die wo ganz anders gebraucht werden. Also das ist ja, klar kann nicht jeder, der Philosophie studiert, Philosophie-Professor werden. Das geht natürlich nicht in einer solchen Szene. Das war nie so angelegt. Aber das wir zum Beispiel in den Zeiten nicht mehr sind, wo eigentlich so die Taxifahrer-Witze dann kommen, du studierst Philosophie oder Soziologie und wirst dann Taxifahrer. Das ist ja nun auch nicht mehr der Fall.
Nee, genau. So, jetzt Harari.
The AI immigrants will also bring with them problems. Those who are concerned about human immigrants usually argue that immigrants might take jobs, might change the local culture, might be politically disloyal. I'm not sure that's true of all human immigrants, but it will definitely be true of the AI immigrants. The AI immigrants will take many human jobs. The AI immigrants will completely change the culture of every country. They will change out religion and even romance. Some people don't like it if their son or daughter is dating an immigrant boyfriend. What would these people think when their son or daughter starts dating an AI boyfriend? And of course, the AI immigrants will have some dubious political loyalties. They are likely to be loyal not to your country, but to some corporational government across the ocean, most probably in one of only two countries, China or the USA. The USA encourages countries to close their borders to human immigrants, but open them very, very wide to USAI immigrants.
Was aber machen wir jetzt wieder damit? Das begreife ich halt nicht. Er ist ja dann manchmal sehr fein. Und dann sagt er ja auch was.
Ich finde das ein dramatischer Einwurf in einer politischen Debatte.
Also das kann man natürlich so machen. Aber jetzt dieses Beispiel. Was ist, wenn die Kinder einen AI-Boyfriend oder Girlfriend haben?
Nimm das mal raus. Das dachte ich mir schon. Das ist ja völlig unnötig. Das ist schon wieder unsinnig. Wir reden jetzt über Arbeitsmarktmigration.
Über das kann man reden, ja.
Das mal bei einer Maischberger Sendung eingeworfen.
Richtig, ja.
Ist doch genial.
Ja.
Ich will diese Sendung sehen. Da ist mir dann auch egal, wer Gast ist.
Wollen Sie die Migranten von Palantir haben, die die Arbeit jetzt machen?
Das ist doch als Idee für die politische Debatte. Das ist einfach eine geniale Fragestellung. Alex Karp. Jetzt ist ja hochinteressant. Wir hatten ja in Deutschland extreme Verwerfungen wegen der Wärmepumpe. Wir wissen ja heute aus forensischer Rekonstruktion. Der Krieg in der Ukraine beginnt. Die Bundesregierung stellt fest, weil mal so viel Öl aus Russland verfolgen wir hier in unseren Heizungen. Wir brauchen sofort neue Heizungen. Gucken die nach, was der technische Stand ist. Sie sind so fasziniert von der Wärmepumpe, dass sie gar nicht dran denken, dem Publikum nochmal Bescheid zu sagen, was es damit auf sich hat, sondern im Gesetz steht dann einfach, die alte Heizung muss weg, Wärmepumpe rein. So. Und hier ist es auch ein bisschen. Alex Karp ist ja wirklich gerade an dem Projekt dran zu sagen, wir brauchen diese Immigranten gar nicht mehr. Warum sind in den Städten lauter Leute, die da nicht hingehören? Wir schicken jetzt mit Eis alle raus. And then we have KI. Also er schafft sich sozusagen für seine KI-Immigranten gerade das Arbeitsvolumen, indem er die Migranten aus dem Servicebereich durch Eis aussortieren lässt. Und das ist ein wahnsinniger Gedanke, der auch einfach gar nicht aufgehen wird. Weil diese Branchen, die nicht ersetzt werden durch KI-Immigranten, sind nun mal die Servicebereiche, die vor allem durch migrantische Einstiegsjobs in das neue Land gefüllt werden.
Was wir doch erleben ist, in einem Ausmaß, wie es noch nie da gewesen ist, eine Entwertung des menschlichen Lebens in einem so höflich-rationalen Diskurs. Da sind ja auch der Palantir-Chef in Großbritannien, saß jetzt auch wieder auf einem Podium, hat er heute erzählt, wie man Palantir auf dem Schlachtfeld in der Ukraine einsetzt. Kein Wort dazu, dass dort Menschen sterben. Wer da stirbt, alles spielt gar keine Rolle. Hier geht es, Alex Karp, darum, dass wir zu viele Migranten haben. Die müssen wir auch irgendwie loswerden. Arbeiter werden wir ausrangieren durch so ein Perpetuum mobile, durch so ein Loop, das wir schaffen können. Das ist ja jetzt nicht nur bei Alex Karp, sondern das ist ja generell eine Sprechweise. Carlo Massalla sitzt bei Anne Will im Podcast und sagt, na ja, wenn dann der Krieg ist, dann sterben natürlich so ein Drittel oder sind schwer verwundet nach einem Monat. Dann müssen die aufgefüllt werden. Dann sitzt ein Militär bei Ilna und sagt, na ja, also wenn der Ernstfall ist, dann geht es ja eh nicht mehr um Freiwilligkeit. Dann müssen ja alle ran. Also diese Entwertung von menschlichem Leben, wie die Pferde jetzt, die ja im ersten Weltkrieg noch mal in die Schlacht ziehen mussten, die sind ja da auch hunderttausendfach verreckt, so wird jetzt eigentlich über die Menschen gesprochen. Und das ist aber in so einem rationalen, unternehmerisch gut vernünftig ausgerichteten, das Kurs so scheint es.
There will be more than enough jobs for the citizens of your nation, especially those with vocational training. I do think these trends really do make it hard to imagine why we should have large scale immigration unless you have a very specialized skill.
Das ist schon verrückt. Elon Musk.
I mean, what you think of it is that If you have a large number of humanoid robots, the economic output is the average productivity per robot times the number of robots. Right. And actually my prediction is in the benign scenario of the future that we will actually make so many robots in AI that they will actually saturate all human needs. Meaning you won't be able to even think of something. You can't have work that has to be done. And amazing abundance for all.
Man kann einfach nicht beides haben. Wir müssen uns jetzt mit entweder Überfluss für alle, alles wunschlos glücklich oder halt Sinn des Lebens. Kannst du nicht beides haben? Eden Musk ist der dümmste Mensch der Welt. Das ist einfach unglaublich.
Zehn-Milliarden-Roboter.
Ja, also ichfehle allen, Sascha Pallenberg arbeitet sich ja immer sehr an Musk ab und geht auch wirklich in die Investorscalls rein und den ganzen Kram. Es ist wirklich unverständlich, wie jemand, der in einer einzigen Stadt Austin noch nicht einen Meter wirklich selbstfahrendes Auto auf die Straße gebracht hat, während Google schon in zehn Städten hunderttausend Kilometer ohne Fahrer wird, einfach auf der Bühne in Davos sitzen kann und sagen kann, selbstfahrende Autos ist ein größtes Problem.
Ja, ja, ja.
Und alle so, das ist super toll. Jetzt kommt er hier mit seinem Robber, das Szenario um die Ecke. Die Leute sind gestört, also das ist wirklich, dass Tesla als Unternehmen mehr wert ist, als die ganze Autobranche der Welt zusammen.
That was unsinnig.
Ja, das sind, hier haben wirklich nur dumme Leute mit Luftbuchungen solchen Erfolg. Und reißen dann die ganze Welt ab. Also zuerst wird materiell die Welt abgerissen und dann auf der WoS auch noch intellektuell alles abgeräumt, so. Ja, sorry, wir essen alle Kuchen. Wir brauchen keinen Lebenssinn mehr. Also, auch liebe deutsche Journalisten und so, ja. Jeden was darf man wirklich nicht mehr ernst nehmen. Ansonsten kann man euch nicht mehr ernst nehmen. Es geht so nicht weiter. Carp wird hier gefragt von Fink, weil wir die Meritocracy Trap gelesen haben.
The foundation for white-collar work in Europe and the United States has been through the universities. What I just heard you say, we're going to need more vocational men and women, and they may, they're going to be, but are you also insinuating we're probably going to need less white-collar?
I think, like, I think what we need to do is yes, but I think we need different ways of testing aptitude. You know, it's like, you know, there are a lot of people doing X that should be doing Y.
Whatever, Karp, das war der letzte Clip dazu.
Es ist so dramatisch, dass wir in solchen Zeiten leben. Also wir haben das jetzt durch diese Techbosse in dieser absoluten intellektuellen Feindlichkeit, die sie aber dann zugleich dann noch so tarnen mit, ich habe Mare Ne Girard gelesen und habe eine Idee vom Antichristen und so.
Nicht auszuhalten, bescheuert, dumm. Man hätte gern wieder die Entkopplung aus seid einfach superreich, aber bitte wie in China. Das ist einfach, ihr müsst trotzdem anhalten, wenn da Leute über die Straße gehen.
Ja, ja, ja. Wir gehen zu Ursula von der Leyen. Sie betont die Unabhängigkeit Europas. Die europäische Unabhängigkeit hängt stark davon ab, wie aufgerüstet ist Europa.
We have done more on defense in the last year than in decades before. We have started a surge in defense spending up to 800 billion euros till 2030. Member states are stepping up their investment at record level. And this has helped to triple the market value of European defense industry companies since January 2022. We now have three leading European defense tech startups that have reached unicorn valuation.
Großartig.
Das ist jetzt das Kriterium.
Ich glaube, irgendwann wird die Zeit kommen. Also bei mir ist jetzt schon, aber vielleicht morgen für alle. Dass man einfach sagt, das Video der Rede geht 35 Minuten. Transkribieren dauert 7 Sekunden. Und dass die Pro-Version von Gemini einfach die Antwort generiert, was davon ist wichtig, was nicht, was ist nur Semantik, was Struktur. Du weißt, was mir wichtig ist. Sag es mir einfach kurz. Ja, das ist ein Rundown, der ja vielleicht 300 Minuten dauert. Dann weiß ich nach vier Minuten, was hier Sache ist. Und dann können wir uns wieder um andere Texte kümmern, weil wir das einfach abparken können. Also vielleicht kümmern wir auch das letzte Mal Davos einfach, weil man hat dieses Sprech so drin und irgendwie alles ist tremendous. Und dann wird nochmal eine Känze vergenannt. Und jetzt haben wir Unicorns.
Auffrüstungsunicorns. Also auch da. Wenn wir die ganze Zeit in den politischen Talkshows diesen Diskurs haben, die Demokratie schützen, die Werte verteidigen, die Menschenrechte. Und Herr Nyman, warum verteidigen Sie nicht die Menschenrechte? Sie sind doch Linker. Sie müssen auch die Menschenrechte verteidigen. Und dann stehen Sie auf der Bühne und wissen eigentlich nur, mit Zahlen zu glänzen und zu sagen, wir haben endlich auch ein Hörner in der Auffrüstung. Geil. Grönland. Auch ein Thema.
When I started preparing for this year's address, security in the high north was not the main theme. That Europe must speed up its push for independence, from security to economy, From defense to democracy.
Die Idee ist bei Von der Leyen denke ich schon, jetzt wo das zumindest mit den Amerikanern vorher es nicht funktioniert, ein sehr, sehr starkes Europa aufzubauen. Und für sie bedeutet das natürlich ein starkes Europa durch Deutschland. Hören wir deshalb den Bundeskanzler Merz, der dort auch spricht.
The comment piece up here on the magic mountain.
Zauberberg, weißt du, der Thomas Mann und so.
Endavos is at stark contrast to a world whose old order is unravelling at breathtaking pace.
Breathtaking pace.
Ja, das ist auch schön, wenn man das schneidet. Das so jedes Wort und dann zwei Sekunden frei, wie der Wort.
Also genau, das muss man dazusagen. Wir sind ja Service-Dienstleister. Das heißt, aus unserem Podcast Video und Audio ist natürlich jede stille Länge als 0,3 Sekunden rausgeschnitten. Deswegen klingen wir auch so klug. Ihr müsst euch das jetzt bei Friedrich Merz reindenken.
Ach so, wird das ja rausgeschnitten jetzt gerade?
Naja, aus unserer Aufwunik-Version. Also aus unserer schönen Podcast.
Wir können die Leute nicht so belassen.
Deswegen sage ich sehr ausdrücklich dazu, bei Merz müsst ihr euch vorstellen, dass wirklich jedes Wort nochmal die Wortlänge in Kunstpause hinten dran und so weiter.
Ach so, wir haben das ja alles gestraft.
Merz klingt alleine in unserem Podcast klüger, weil wir von einer KI-Stille rausrechnen lassen. Aber was heißt KI? Also es ist halt nicht schwer zu erkennen, wenn Merz gar nichts sagt im Vergleich zu es sind zumindest noch Worte.
Ja, sehr schön. Merz spricht über die Großmächte. Geht das jetzt auch in so eine Karnier-Richtung?
This new world of great powers is being built on power, on strength and when it comes to it, on force.
Hey, das ist doch der Spruch von Stephen Miller.
Power, strength, force.
Ja. So hat das bei jedem eingesagt.
Ja, da hat er gedacht, dann nehmen wir das auch.
Ja, hier kennen wir uns Deutsche auch aus. Ich mein, Stephen Miller hat es ja auch von uns. Ich meine, das ist auch so ein Loop, der sich erschließt.
Was bedeutet das jetzt für uns? Was ist zu tun?
First, we must invest massively in our ability to defend ourselves. And we are doing this.
Gegen wen? Das ist die größte Lüge der Welt.
Ja.
Nicht um uns zu verteidigen, es sei denn er meint, dass jemand die Seewege zumacht für unsere Schiffe. Ja. Das ist natürlich blöd. Dann müssen die in die Steinzeit zurückgebombt werden. Und wir brauchen das unter Verteidigung. Okay.
Ja, denn das wäre ja zu beantworten. Was wird da wie verteidigt?
Ich meine, es kann jetzt auch nicht die ganze Welt Russland den Krieg erklären.
Ja, vor allen Dingen ist ja das Interessante bei einer Aufrüstung, die ja jetzt global stattfindet. Also wir haben ja überall die Zahlen und sehen, wie die Aufrüstung nach oben geht. Und jeder überbietet sich. Es kommt ja nicht an den Punkt, dass man sagt, jetzt haben wir genug aufgerüstet. Das wäre ja nur dann, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel Russland und China gar nichts mehr produzieren würden. Einfach nur noch da sitzen und sagen, so kein Panzer mehr. Und dann könnten wir mehr Panzer produzieren. Dann sagen wir, jetzt haben wir zehn mehr, jetzt haben wir gewonnen. Aber solange die ja auch mit aufrüsten, gibt es ja nicht das, was man sich da vorstellt, nämlich dass man die anderen in die Knie zwingt. Das Einzige, was passieren kann, ist, dass irgendwann vielleicht dann Europa wirklich das Geld ausgeht, weil man einfach sehr, sehr dumm Geld verschwendet hat und irgendwann die Kapitalmärkte sagen, also mit den Staatsanleihen, wir sind nicht mehr so glücklich damit.
Ich will mal, dass Frau Meischberger mir das Szenario aufschlüsselt, wie wir jetzt gegen China dann den Krieg führen, wenn wir uns fertig aufgerüstet haben.
Mit den 83 Millionen Deutschen gegen 1,3 Milliarden Chinesen.
Also das scheint ja irgendwie erfolgsvoll zu sein, sonst würden sie es ja nicht machen, wäre sonst total dumm.
Aber Ulle war jetzt bei Sterbenstunde Philosophie, da hat aber die Dame gesagt, wir sind schon im dritten Weltkrieg, die da saß.
Ja, natürlich. Ich habe die Sendung gesehen und ich habe Ola auch ein bisschen beneidet dafür, da sitzen zu dürfen. Die Widerworte hätte ich auch gerne. Ich hätte auch gerne die Gelegenheit genutzt, die ein oder andere Rückfrage zu stellen.
Jaja, also man ist doch verblüfft darüber. Ja, mir ist auch aufgefallen, dass diese Think Tank Leute alle doch sehr gleich aussehen. Ist dir das mal aufgefallen? Dass die Herren und Damen aus den Think Tanks, das ist so ein gewisser Typ. Ich weiß nicht, wo man diese Frisuren herbekommt und diese Jawlines und so. Jedenfalls sehen die alle so aus. Also ich kann zum Beispiel jetzt die Dame, die da saß, da habe ich jetzt auch gedacht, ist das Claudia Mayor? Ach nee, es ist sie ja gar nicht.
Du hast ja einen neuen Fernseher gekauft, der wohl so groß ist, dass man einfach gar nichts mehr sieht. Man steht so nah am Bild. Komm, es sind 82 Zoll. Ja, 82 Zoll. Schreibt mal bitte, Wolfgang, wie viel 82 Zoll sind.
Ich bin ja Filmkritiker. Ich brauch das ja.
Ja, natürlich. Also 4K ist 4K, auch auf 82 Zoll. So, was wollte ich sagen? Ach so, ich höre das ja nur. Ich möchte aber kurz anmerken, ich habe Cornelia Stelzenmüller bei Ronsheimer, glaube ich, gehört. Ich habe auch einen Clip irgendwo, den spiele ich aber nicht. Das fand ich gut. Und es ist mir wirklich aufgefallen, dass ich so dachte, das ist so gut, dass sie auch Ronsheimer kurz sagt, ne, darauf wollte ich gar nicht hinaus. In dem Sinne, setzt sie noch mal an und versucht es einfach zu erklären und so. Das scheint mir die einzige zu sein, die aus dem amerikanischen Kontext in deutscher Sprache uns jetzt erklärt, was mit den Amerikanern los ist.
Ah, okay.
Sollte man vielleicht beobachten.
Ja, was ist noch zu tun, Friedrich Merz?
Second, we must rapidly make our economies competitive. And we are doing this.
Friedrich Merz, das machen wir seit 88 Jahren.
In wieviel?
Viele, viele Jahre machen wir das. Im Grunde immer. Wann haben wir das nicht gemacht? Wann war der Satz von Sinnhaftigkeit geprägt?
Ja, da haben wir schon mal gesagt, wir machen jetzt zehn Jahre keinen Wettbewerb. Und Wettbewerb bedeutet innerhalb Europas, dass sich die Länder gegenseitig die Butter vom Brot nehmen. Das macht gerade Europa nicht stark. Also wenn man ja mal in dieser Logik bliebe, das starke Europa, dann ginge das ja schon mal nicht. Das wäre ja dumm.
Also wenn einfach jedes Land sich stark macht, indem es das andere schwach macht, dann ist die Summe klar.
Also wenn wir jetzt zu zweit draußen jemanden verprügeln wollen, aber uns erstmal ordentlich prügeln, dann haben wir uns schon mal erheblich geschwächt, bevor wir da rausgehen. Das ist bescheuert. Drittens.
Third, We must stand closer together.
Sorry, das widerspricht sich mit Platz eins.
And among like-minded partners. We are doing this.
Nee.
Nee, wir tun genau das nicht. Grönland. Sehr schön jetzt, passt auf.
To secure the high north is NATO. This is a common transatlantic interest. Germany is doing just that. We are doing it in the framework of NATO. And we will do more. Our neighbors and partners in Europe, including Denmark and the people of Greenland, can count on our solidarity. We will protect Denmark, Greenland, the North, from the threat posed by Russia.
Ja, finde ich auch sehr gut. Als er da so, was sagt er? High North, der hohe Nord. Ich habe das gehört und in meinem Kopf ploppt er The Rock auf, in Pain and Gain. Der da auch so ein Priester, der ihn irgendwie angetauscht hat, ermordet hat und so. Und dann halt im Süden war. Und dann fragt die Marki, Mark, wo kommst du denn her? Und der sagt so, ab Nord. Und möchte es eigentlich unbestimmt halten. Und so ist das hier auch. Klar verteidigen wir den hohen Norden. Warum auch nicht? Der hohe Norden, mystisch. Alle so, in Finnland leben doch die glücklichsten Menschen der Welt, oder? Ja klar. Also klar verteidigen wir die.
Grönland, da wäre uns jetzt als erstes eingefallen, dass natürlich jetzt Putin da schon kurz davor steht. Aber er kommt dann doch noch auf die USA zu sprechen, weil er dachte, damit kommt er alleine jetzt nicht durch. Man muss wohl doch noch erwähnen, dass es da auch andere Interessen gibt.
We will uphold the principles on which the Transatlantic Partnership is founded. Namely sovereignty and territorial integrity. We support talks between Denmark, Greenland, the United States on the basis of these principles. I have discussed this with President Trump, Prime Minister Fredriksen, Secretary General Mark Rutte and others in these days. The aim of these talks is to agree for closer cooperation amongst allies in the High North and beyond.
In the High North. Also die Doctrin war, Grenzen werden nicht mehr mit Gewalt verschoben.
Ja.
Wenn man davon jetzt abrückt, weil irgendwelche Gespräche und vielleicht kommt da irgendwas raus und wie auch immer, das geht einfach gar nicht. Das Grönland-Ding ist eigentlich der Moment, bei dem man Antony Scaramucci der Empfehlung folgen sollte, wenn Trump anruft, nicht rangehen. Sich Briefe schicken lassen. Auf die Briefe irgendwann mal reagieren. Nur öffentlich reden. Nicht hinter versteckten Türen und so. Solche Sachen. Es ist eigentlich, wie man mit so einem Typen umgeht, sollte doch mittlerweile klar sein. Nein, jetzt brauchen wir Gespräche. Europa beraumt noch Gespräche an. Damit Amerika hier mal was sie eigentlich wollen sagen kann. Das geht echt gar nicht. Aber ich fand es auch sehr witzig durch die Bank. Die Bundeswehr hat ja 18 Leute geschickt nach Grönland. Um dort zu sondieren, ob die von Russland bedroht sind. Und die Erkenntnis war ja, ne, wir sehen hier gar nichts. Und auch aus China sehen wir gar nichts. Aber klar, perspektivisch und so weiter muss irgendwas gemacht werden. Dann wurde der Kani im Gespräch ja auch gefragt, ist Grönland von Russland bedroht? Kani gesagt, Russland ist immer eine Bedrohung. Ich will noch mal dran erinnern, in der amerikanischen Verteidigungsstrategie, die alle gerade durchgenudelt haben, von der alle behauptet haben, dass sie sie gelesen haben vor allem, die Journalisten, steht das nicht drin. Da ist Russland nicht als, so wie alle Jahre vorher, Gefahr und so weiter benannt, sondern da geht es um Stabilitätsgarantien mit Russland. Das heißt, ein Stabilitätsfaktor, dass die Europäer hier nicht einfach die leichte Pointe nehmen und sagen, als allererstes möchte ich Ihnen sagen, die Amerikaner haben recht, Russland ist dort keine Bedrohung. Haben sie das Dokument der Sicherheitsstrategie nicht zubekommen, haben sie es nicht erhalten oder was? Soll ich sie nochmal vorlesen? Stattdessen alle so, ja Russland ist da voll die Bedrohung und so. Es werden Poanten liegen gelassen, das finde ich nicht gut.
Friedrich Merz wechselt auf Deutsch.
Wir haben die Schwelle hinein in eine neue Welt der Großmächte überschritten. In dieser Welt weht ein rauer Wind. Diese Welt wird uns Härten und Gefahren zumuten. Das spüren sie, das spüren wir alle.
Nee, sie müssen das besonders spüren. Sie sollen nämlich länger arbeiten und und und. Aber ich spüre das natürlich nicht als Friedrich Merz hier. Außer, dass man sich ein bisschen verstimmt, wenn abends ein Dinner ist und der Ludnik da wieder auf den Tisch haut.
Ich finde, also ich kann jetzt nur noch mit Poanten angeboten und so. Aber wenn man als deutscher Kanzlerin Davos auf der Bühne steht und sagt, wir haben die Schwelle zur Großmachspolitik überschritten, muss man auch sagen, für uns keine Pionierarbeit, back home, hier kennen wir uns aus.
Ja, und das ist ja genau das Problem. Also wir werden ja jetzt darauf zu sprechen kommen. Ich habe die Karl-Schmidt-Vorlesungen mir angesehen von Brandon Sims. Ein Freund hat mich darauf hingewiesen, dass das sehr interessant sei. Diese Vorlesungen sind erschienen bei Duncker und Humblot. Titel Die Rückkehr des Großraums. Da leitet der irische Historiker zunächst einmal ab, woher dieses Großraumdenken kommt. Und das ist zunächst tatsächlich dann nach dem ersten Weltkrieg Hitler war. Der sagte, ja, die Monodoktrin finde ich eigentlich ganz gut. Wir müssen auf so eine deutsche Monodoktrine abzielen. Später ist es dann Karl Schmidt, der das wieder aufgreift, in modifizierter Form zwar etwas, als das, was Hitler da vorschwebt. Und die Idee ist dann eben, dass man den einzelnen Großmächten Räume zugesteht, in denen sie schalten und walten können, wie sie wollen. Diese Großräume haben dann auch so ein ideologisches Fundament. Und diese müssen dann auch, ja, also die können miteinander Handel oder so etwas treiben, aber es gibt eben dieses Interventionsverbot, dass die eine raumfremde Macht nicht in das Reich der anderen Macht hinein kann. Das ist also ein deutsches Denken, das auch dazu führte, zum Beispiel, dass man dann expandierte nach Osten zur sogenannten Lebensraumgewinnung, weil man sagte, wir brauchen natürlich einen sehr großen Raum, um das zu haben.
Aber unter großem Betrug, Hitler, Stalin, die hatten ja genau so eine Abmachung.
Ja, ja, genau.
Soweit reicht es also in der Praxis?
Ja, ja, natürlich. Und jetzt hat Brendan Simms, den ich so als so einen liberal-neokonservativen beschreiben würde, auch wenn der das nicht so ganz transparent macht, der sagt natürlich ja, die Großräume sind zurück. Das ist aber von 23 insofern ganz interessant zu lesen. Biden-Ära, das ist noch nicht die Trump-Ära, die zweite. Da sagt er jetzt ja, wir haben zwei Großmächte und zwei Großräume, die entstanden sind. Einmal China, einmal Russland. Und das könnte man dann eben mit dem Krieg in der Ukraine gut sehen. Aber er denkt dann darüber nach, ob Europa auch ein Großraum werden kann und inwieweit man den Westen als Großraum bezeichnen kann. Und da würde er immer sagen nein, denn der Westen ist ja universalistisch und der interveniert, wenn zum Beispiel irgendwo Menschenrechte bedroht sind. Also wir kennen, dass die Fassade von der Carney eben gesprochen hat. Simps ist jemand, der das richtig findet. Der findet also die Einmischung gut und das Interventionsverbot soll es auch nicht geben, sondern man soll intervenieren. Auf den kommen wir jetzt gleich, denn erst hören wir nochmal Merz, der die transatlantische Partnerschaft betont.
Lassen Sie uns bitte auch bei allem Frust und Ärger der letzten Monate die transatlantische Partnerschaft nicht voreilig abschreiben. Und das ist kein wohlfeiler Verweis auf das Prinzip Hoffnung. Nein, wir Europäer, wir Deutsche wissen, wie kostbar das Vertrauen ist, auf dem die NATO fußt.
Ja, also ich sehe, wie der Trump grad mit Amerikanern umgeht und ich will nicht wissen, wie er mit Deutschen umgeht. Weiß nicht, warum er das noch nicht geschnallt hat.
Aber...
Im Zeitalter der Großmächte werden auch die USA auf dieses Vertrauen angewiesen haben. Es ist ihr und unser entscheidender Wettbewerbsvorteil.
Jetzt versucht er, eine Differenz auszumachen zwischen Autokratien und Demokratien. Ich habe sie nicht so ganz verstanden.
Ich sage es auf Deutsch. Autokratien mögen Untertan haben. Demokratien haben Partner und verlässliche Freunde.
Also Autokratien haben ja auch Partner und verlässliche Freunde. Und Untertan, das bezieht sich auf die eigene Bevölkerung. Und so wie Friedrich Merz über die eigene Bevölkerung jetzt gerade denkt, ist das auch eher so, die Untertanen sollen bitte mehr arbeiten.
Wir haben das denn die Dolmetscher übersetzt, müsste man sagen.
Zum Schluss, das neue NATO Ziel wird nochmal benannt.
Germany pledges to take a special responsibility here. That is why we decided right at the start of my tenure to increase Germany's defense spending up to 5% of GDP.
Man muss sich das auch vorstellen. Nochmal, es geht hier nicht um 5% des Haushalts, des Bundeshaushalts, sondern 5% des Protoinlandsprodukts wird jetzt für die Aufrüstung ausgegeben. Also gigantisch viel, wo man also schon merkt, es gibt da Großmachtsansprüche, wo wir natürlich bei dem Problem sind. Europa ist sehr zersplittert. Wir haben zwei starke Akteure. Ein Akteur Frankreich hat eine Atombombe. Deutschland hat keine. Deutschland will eigentlich da eine militärische Oberhand haben. Das geht aber mit den Franzosen nicht. Wir haben anfangs zum Golisthmus ein bisschen was gesagt. Jedenfalls ist es Brandon Sims, der schon vor zehn Jahren beim IFO-Institut darüber nachgedacht hat, wie Europa eigentlich sich stärken kann, wie man dort, man würde heute sagen, wehrfähig sein kann. Er hat damals Folgendes vorgeschlagen.
Professor Sims, Sie haben hier heute Abend einen Vortrag gehalten bei uns im IFO in München zu der Frage, wie kann man die Euro-Krise lösen und schlagen unter anderem vor, die Schaffung eines europäische Staates und zwar in der Euro-Zone. Wie kommen Sie darauf?
So, mein Argument aus der Geschichte ist, dass kräftige Staatsunion nur im Zusammenhang mit einer äußeren Gefahr zustande kommen.
Die äußere Gefahr hätten wir dann jetzt, China, Russland. Und ich spiele das jetzt alles deshalb, weil ich glaube, dass es in der geopolitischen Debatte gerade zwei Stränge dominierend gibt. Also es gibt natürlich die einen, die weiterhin die transatlantische Partnerschaft einfach herstellen wollen und das alles so wie in Span im Prinzip sagen, wir machen da genauso weiter, wo wir aufgehört haben und wir sehen da gar keinen Bruch, sondern genau richtig, dass da auch mal gegen die Wurken vorgegangen wird in den USA. Das sollten wir uns zum Vorbild machen. Und da gibt es dann Teile, die sich dem sehr anschließen würden. Dann gibt es aber ein anderes Lager. Und da würde ich sagen, da gibt es wiederum zwei Varianten von, nämlich ein Lager, das sagt, wir brauchen jetzt ein eigenständiges, souveränes Europa. Und da denkt man auch in dem Großraum, der geschützt werden muss. Europa muss selbst so eine Großmittelmacht irgendetwas werden. In diesem Lager sind aber nicht, also das ist nicht eine Eintracht einfach, sondern da gibt es quasi zwei verschiedene Fraktionen, die auch nicht zusammengehören wollen. Aber wir können die jetzt mal darstellen. Da gibt es zum einen die, die ich jetzt mal so im Lager Strack Zimmermann und Co. sehen würde, die das tatsächlich sehr vehement und sehr aggressiv auch gegen den USA stark machen wollen. Europa muss jetzt wer sein und deswegen brauchen wir auch unbedingt Wehrpflicht und all das, damit wir da unsere eigenen Leute positionieren können. Und dann gibt es aber noch andere, die auch sagen ja Großraum, wunderbare Idee. Das kenne ich doch noch gut von früher, nämlich jemand wie Maximilian Krah und andere aus der AfD, die ja nicht so sehr auf diese Trump, also die die Trump nicht so als Partner sehen, aber gut finden, dass Trump dann Venezuela seinen Großraumgehabe hat. Und wir brauchen das eigentlich hier auch. So.
Tripbrettfahrer.
So, und dann kann der Großraum bei Maximilian Krah, glaube ich, auch bis in die Türkei gehen, weil man mit denen eigentlich auch ganz gute Geschäfte machen kann. Wichtig ist nur dann, Türkei gehört nicht zum eigentlichen Großraum, denn der Großraum, wir wissen das von Karl Schmitt, muss natürlich weltanschaulich eine gewisse Einheit bilden und das meint dann ethnisch, weiß und christlich und und und.
Also wenn ich in Spanien bin oder in Griechenland, bin ich mit denen weltanschaulich sehr auf, siehe es da und es ist hier zu warm und wir legen uns erstmal alle hin.
Ja, aber das sind quasi die drei Lager, die wir jetzt da sehen, die alle sagen Aufrüstung ja, nur ist dann die Frage, gegen wen soll sich was gerade richten und die auch alle sagen ja, wer pflegt an sich, wichtig. Und deswegen ist also so ein progressiver Ruf, wir müssen mehr Europa wagen oder so, auch mit Vorsicht zu genießen, weil das durchaus auch ein militaristisches Projekt sein kann. Brandon Simms gibt jetzt mal ein historisches Beispiel.
Und ich gebe da das Beispiel, die anglo-schottische Union von 1707 und die amerikanische Union von 1787-88. Und ich glaube, dass die Prinzipien, die diese Union geschaffen haben, die Prinzipien einer gemeinsamen Staatsschuld, einer gemeinsamen Außenpolitik, ein gemeinsames Parlament, dass diese auf die Eurozone angewandt werden müssen, um das Problem des Euro zu lösen, aber auch das Problem des mangelnden Zusammenhalts Europas in Angesicht großer außenpolitischer Krisen, zum Beispiel ISIS, aber insbesondere auch natürlich das Vorrücken Russlands unter Herrn Putin.
Wann war das?
Das war vor zehn Jahren. Ah ja, vor zehn Jahren hat er das vorgelesen.
Man hat noch die Euro-Krise durchschimmern.
Brendan Sims hat aber Probleme mit Frankreich bzw. Frankreich macht Probleme.
Ja, also Frankreichs Europapolitik ist letztendlich immer davon getrieben worden, Deutschland einzudämmen. Das war das Argument für die Europäische Union, das Argument für den Euro. Und die Franzosen haben sich bis jetzt aus einer gemeinsamen politischen Union und aus einer militärischen Union herausreden können. Mit dem Argument, es müsste also eine europäische Armee für Deutschland und eine französische Armee für Frankreich. Und ich würde sagen, das geht nicht mehr.
Was empfiehlt er? Er will eigentlich ein starkes Deutschland.
Also Deutschland sollte drohen sozusagen mit seiner eigenen Souveränität, um Frankreich zu zwingen an solchen Bund?
Es ist nicht so, dass die Deutschen das androhen müssen. Sondern es wäre einfach strukturell, zwangsläufig eine Folge des Auseinanderbrechens der Eurozone und vielleicht letztendlich auch der Europäischen Union. Das ist die Schlussfolgerung. Und da die Franzosen meines Erachtens das vermeiden wollen, dann würden sie dann, wenn es drauf ankommt, in einer gemeinsamen politischen Union einsteigen mit Deutschland.
Also was ich spontan historisierend wirklich interessant finde, zehn Jahre später redet keiner mehr über dieses Problem, weshalb er überhaupt auf diese Idee kommt. Der Euro ist unbedroht. Zentralbanken kaufen einfach alles weg vom Markt, was weggekauft werden muss, um das zu stabilisieren. Und in der Hinsicht ist das schon interessant, dass er hier so eine Problemlösung formuliert, wo man so zehn Jahre später denkt, ja unter ganz anderen Kontexten wird das plötzlich wieder aktuell, aber gar nicht unter diesen, wo man sich selber wohnt.
Aber interessant ist, dass er hier der Denker eines starken Deutschlands ist. Da zucke ich ja immer schon gleich zusammen. Die Rückkehr des Großraums ist also diese Vorlesung, die er hält, diese Karl-Schmidt-Vorlesung, die sehr renommiert ist. Ich habe zwei Passagen, kurze Passagen daraus eingelesen. Er überlegt nämlich da auch weiter über Europa als Großraum. Und er bezieht sich dabei auf einen Autor, den wir alle gut kennen. Es besteht kein Zweifel, dass die Europäische Union ein Großraum sein könnte, wenn sie wollte. Sie hat sicherlich das wirtschaftliche Gewicht, die Kohärenz und die Reichweite, um ein solches Bekenntnis zu untermauern. Selbst ein verkleinertes Europa, das sich auf den deutsch-französischen Kern konzentriert, könnte ein Großraum sein. Kurz nach dem Irak-Krieg argumentierte Carlo Massalla, dass ein solches Kerneuropa als Nukleus eines politischen Großraumes Europa als Gegensatz zu den Vereinigten Staaten figurieren könnte.
Also diese Leute wie Massalla, die hatten ja richtig Glück, dass mal ein Ukrainekrieg so nah bei uns war, dass sich mal alles unter Kriegsgesichtspunkten runter, also der Kriegsturm, alles andere wird untersortiert. Aber ich dachte, das hat damit zu tun, dass hier gerade Krieg ist, aber das scheint der grundsätzliche Denken zu sein.
Ja, das ist eine grundsätzliche Denkung, die ich auch immer gedacht habe. Ich habe immer gedacht, das ist einfach nur transatlantisch ausgerichtet, weil so ja auch immer die Fassade war. Aber wir sehen plötzlich, nein, es gibt neben dieser rein transatlantischen Ausrichtung auch nochmal eine ganz andere Strömung, die eigentlich sehen will, dass wir hier so eine Großraumordnung haben und Europa muss sich darin behaupten. Und dann ergibt es natürlich auch Sinn, wenn aus eher progressiver, mittelinksliberaler Seite gesagt wird, und zur Not schießen wir die Hutis in die Steinzelt zurück, weil das ja natürlich das Großmachtsbegehren dann auch ist. Und wir haben so eine ideologische Weltanschauung, wir sind für Menschenrechte und Klima ist uns auch wichtig und all diese ganzen Dinge. Queere Politik, mit der Bundeswehr, Queerfeld einmarschieren, all das.
Ich will jetzt nicht zu hart in meinem Urteil sein, aber anscheinend wird der Ukraine-Krieg wirklich von allen missbraucht. Also Putin macht da so seine, keine Ahnung, hält nochmal das Land an sich, weil es ja Krieg und so. Dann kommt Palantir und sagt, tolles Battlefield habt ihr da. Und Masalla so, ja, ich wollte schon immer diese Theorie mal ausformulieren.
Ja, ja, ja.
Simms sagt hier aber, 2023 hält er diese Vorlesung, dass er dieses Großraumdenken in Europa nicht sieht, weil man sich eigentlich immer so eng an den USA anlehnt. Und solange das der Fall ist, ist das natürlich nicht vorzufinden. Zumal Simms an sich auch so ein Verfechter ist von so einer westlichen Hemisphäre, die sich immer wieder einmischen kann, wenn sie glaubt, sich einmischen zu müssen. Nun endet aber das Ganze damit, dass er nicht einfach nur so einen Universalismus des Westens beschwört, sondern ein Szenario für die Zukunft ausmalt, bei dem er uns ebenfalls Angst und Bange werten kann. So enden seine Carl-Schmidt-Vorlesungen. Die westliche Unipolarität muss die chinesisch-russische Multipolarität verdrängen oder bei dem Versuch untergehen. Der universelle Raum der westlichen Demokratie und Die größeren Räume, in deren Mittelpunkt, die Diktaturen Russlands und der Volksrepublik China stehen, können auf Dauer nicht nebeneinander bestehen.
Why? Also mir ist es klar, es ist jetzt, ich kenne den Text vorher nicht.
Ja, es ist die Idee, dass wir entweder eine unipolare Weltordnung weiterhin haben müssen. Also Washington und die Verbündeten regieren, egal was Kanye und so weiter sagen. Und dann muss das aber auch auf diesen Systemstreit hinauslaufen, der am Ende in die Tukididis-Falle führt und wovor jetzt zum Beispiel Adam Toos gewarnt hat. Oder die Alternative ist natürlich, dass man so einen Großraumdenken hat, in dem man aber dann auch immer wieder in militärische Konflikte gerät, weil man ja auch die Pufferzonen, all das verteidigen muss, Handelswege etc. Das heißt, diese Szenarien stehen jetzt gerade bei den Thinktankern und bei all denen, die wir so aus dem geopolitischen Umfeld hören in Podcasts und Talkshows. Diese Szenarien stehen jetzt gerade da und man ist sich noch gerade uneins. Macht man es nochmal, wenn Kevin Newsome antritt mit so einer unipolaren Weltordnung? Gehen wir da all in oder machen wir es so in einem Großmachts-Think? Bedeutet aber, egal für was man sich entscheidet, um das nochmal zu betonen, wir sind dabei die Pferde. Mhm. Wissen nur noch nicht, in welche Richtung wir geschickt werden.
Also ist denen einfach zu langweilig. Wer kommt denn auf die Idee und setzt sich so hin und sagt, ich würde mir mein Leben jetzt einer Ausarbeitung einer Großraumtheorie und dann halte ich da so Vorträge und also hat man nichts Besseres zu tun so. Ist mir alles sehr schweihart.
Ja, also ich finde es auch in dieser Alternativlosigkeit, in der es aufgezeigt wird.
Weil was heißt denn untergehen? Das ist ein bisschen wie, Harari hat ja vorhin auch so einen Spruch gemacht, wenn wir nicht früh genug unsere Qualität entdecken, jenseits des Textes, werden wir von den neuen Agenten, die den Text besser beherrschen als wir, so bedrängt, dass unsere, sagt er, Identitäten kollabieren. Und ich frag mich so ein bisschen, was soll denn das bedeuten? Ja, so ein bisschen wie Schömerer damals zu dieser Zeit. Eurokrise tobt und so. Und er, den einen Nachricht nach der anderen spiegelt online, ja, Merkel ist grad da, Seehofer ist jetzt hier unter Druck, blablabla, irgendwas ist und so. Nee, das war ja damals noch vor dieser Zeit. Aber Ostern heißt und dann wird es ganz schlimm. Ich hör mal so, kann das jemand aufschreiben? Was heißt denn das Wort dann ganz schlimm?
Naja.
Und alle so, hm, den können wir da jetzt anfragen, wer uns mal einen Text schreibt, was bedeutet, dass alles ganz schlimm ist? Ja. Und hier hört man einfach, ja, dann geht Europa unter.
Geht dann einfach in Flammen aus oder was ist dann, bauen wir dann Rom ab?
Ja, genau. Also, müssen wir das dann ganz abbauen, ja? Müssen wir dann das Forum Romano wieder verschütten oder?
Ja. Also, es ist ja eigentlich die Vorstellung.
Dann nehmen wir das Schild aus dem Schaufelz.
Man könnte es ja mal umdrehen und sagen, ja, für die, die da sich so in Davos treffen oder so, wird es tatsächlich dann sehr ungut.
Genau. Das ist nämlich, das verstehe ich total.
Vor allem, wenn die anderen nicht mitspielen würden.
Also, wenn man nur noch in Budgets und Känze verdenkt und einfach sagt, mir geht hier gerade der Markt verloren, wo soll ich denn meine drei Millionen Autos verkaufen? Klar, da ist natürlich dann Untergang. Aber für uns, also, ja.
Ja, ich glaube, man muss wirklich diese Distanz ganz stark machen. Und mir ist es wieder so aufgefallen, ich hatte einen Abend, da saß ich zusammen mit Studenten. Unter anderem war da eine Studentin, die hat doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft, russisch-deutsch. Und die erzählte dann, wie mit russischen Studenten in Deutschland umgegangen wird. Mir war das überhaupt nicht klar. Es ist absurd. Um das mal kurz zu skizzieren, damit man das wirklich mal sieht. Also wir könnten ja, wenn wir jetzt uns mal in diese Lage der Regierung versetzt, die jetzt sagt, wie können wir Russland schaden, dann würde ich sagen, holt die Leute hierher. Die wollen nämlich eigentlich auch hier sein. Und wir haben ja schon mal einen SPD-Queerbeauftragten gehört, der sagte, ja, wir haben ja sogar extra den Asylgrund, queer sein, weil den Russen abgeschafft, sonst würden ja so viele Russen jetzt kommen. Wo ich denke, ja, das wäre eigentlich gut gewesen, wenn sie kommen. Jedenfalls, wie ist es also mit Studenten? Doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft, aber wenn man noch nicht fünf Jahre dann in Deutschland lebt, dann ist man genauso ausgesetzt wie Leute, wie Studenten, die hierhin kommen, die nun eine russische Staatsbürgerschaft haben. Die müssen, oder ich glaube sogar noch länger als fünf Jahre, jedenfalls diese Studentin muss ein Sperrkonto anlegen und muss darauf 13.800 Euro jedes Jahr haben. Und dies wird dann monatlich ausgezahlt von dem Konto, um sicherzustellen, dass sie von diesem Geld lebt und auf keinen Fall auf irgendwelche staatlichen Dinge zurückgreift. Es gilt nicht, anzugeben, ich habe hier zwei Mini-Jobs und verdiene jetzt jeden Monat 1.400 Euro und finanziere das damit. Nein, du musst das Geld schon vorher haben und auf dem Konto liegen haben. Ich hörte das. Daraufhin ist ein anderer Student da, der mit einer russischen Studentin zusammen ist. Und er sagt, ja, wir hatten jetzt gerade auch, es ist nicht leicht, schnell dieses Geld zu organisieren, weil das dann wieder gebraucht wird, weil man sonst den Aufenthaltsstatus verlieren kann. Dann kann das passieren, dass man dann zurückgeschickt wird. Und das macht man, weil russische Studenten keinen BAföG bekommen. Alle anderen bekommen BAföG. Es gibt, glaube ich, auch keine, wo es keinen BAföG gibt.
Aber diese haben doch auch eine deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit.
Ja, aber dann ist man noch nicht lang genug hier.
Aber es ist doch trotzdem eine deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit.
Ja, man will ja auch, das war ja auch ein Vorschlag, und der kam ja auch glaube ich aus der grünen Richtung, die vor eine Wahl stellen, dass die eine doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft haben bei Russland und Deutschland, dass sie sich für die deutsche Seite entscheiden. Was natürlich dazu führt, die meisten würden ja sagen, okay, dann nehme ich die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft. Das Problem ist nur, die könnten ja nie mehr nach Russland zurück ihre Familie besuchen oder so. Man weiß ja, welchen Repressionen die sowieso schon ausgesetzt sind, wenn die sagen, aber wieso studieren sie eigentlich in Deutschland? Okay, das sind alles Außergeschichten. Die russischen Studenten hier, die hier sind, bekommen keinen BAföG. Und damit sie dann aber hier studieren können, müssen sie auf dem Sperrkonto schon mal 13.800 Euro hinlegen für das ganze Jahr, um zu signalisieren oder um sicherzustellen, dass sie Geld haben, damit sie ja nicht hier leben und das nicht komplett so finanzieren können. Das sind die, so geht man mit den Menschen um. Das ist so, so irre.
Wie weit kommt man denn mit 13.800 Euro im Jahr in der Uni statt?
Ja, das kommt ja sowieso nochmal da. Die müssen ja dann eh auch nochmal zusätzlich was arbeiten.
Ich will sie mir auf die Idee bringen, dass sie auf 20.000 zu A-Level, liebe Freundlichkeitskommandanten.
Jedenfalls ist ja auch interessant, dass man denen einfach das BAföG verweigert. Statt einfach zu sagen, ja wunderbar, wir holen die hier. Mir wurde dann eine Geschichte erzählt von einem Russen, der von zu Hause ein bisschen Geld hatte, zumindest so viel, dass er über Georgien gehen konnte. Also er hat seinen Wehrdienst abgeleistet und hat dann aber gesagt, dass er dann nicht mehr weitermachen will. Er will nicht kämpfen. Und dann kann das natürlich, na wie sicher ist das, dass du dann in Ruhe gelassen wirst? Und dann ist er über Georgien, hat er sich abgemacht. Und wie kompliziert das für jemanden ist, dann irgendwie in Europa anzukommen, wenn man auch schon Deutschkenntnisse hat und alles. Also es wird tatsächlich abgeschottet, wo es nur geht, wo man eigentlich diese Leute ja hinnehmen kann. Und das sind keine Leute, die sind ja, dann wird so getan, wir müssen uns ja schützen vor Spionage oder so, als einer der Spione. Das sind Leute, die wollen nicht da sein. Die finden das sehr unangenehm. Zumal in Moskau ja ohnehin sehr viele Drohnen von der Ukraine wiederum rübergeschickt werden, was auch nicht die Sicherheit erhöht, dazu nehmen. Also es ist wirklich katastrophal, wenn man das alles mitbekommt. Und um das jetzt noch ein bisschen zu steigern, hören wir noch ganz kurz, was der Militärbischof der Evangelischen Kirche, Bernhard Fellenberg im Interview im Deutschlandfunk Tacheles mit Nils Schneiderjahn zu sagen hat. Ich habe auch sehr viel Schneiderjahn zu Wort kommen lassen, weil man dann sieht, okay, an den Fragen lag es nicht.
Okay, sehr gut.
Jetzt scheint mir aber dieses Motiv zu sein.
Vielleicht nur der Hinweis für die, die uns jetzt nicht immer hören. Wir haben im Salon vor, ich glaube, zwei oder drei Monaten ganz ausführlich habe ich die Friedensschrift der EKD, der evangelischen Kirche Deutschland, vorgestellt. Die Friedensdenkschrift und das ist der Anlass, diese Friedensdenkschrift, warum der Militärbischof hier befragt wird.
Jetzt scheint mir aber dieses Motiv zu sagen, Gewalt ist schlecht, Krieg ist schlecht, Atomwaffen sind schlecht. Und dann immer ein großes Aber dahinter zu setzen und doch Gründe zu finden, warum es in manchen Situationen eigentlich vielleicht doch als Ultima Ratio, als letztes Mittel notwendig sein könnte, etwas zu sein. Darauf kommt man vielleicht auch, wenn man kein Christ ist. Also was unterscheidet denn dann überhaupt die christliche Position von einer nicht-christlichen? Was ist das Besondere, was die evangelische Kirche da jetzt den Menschen anzubieten hat?
Also das Besondere ist erstmal, dass es eine große Institution in unserem Land gibt, die zur Gewissensbildung beitragen möchte, die keine Gewissheit postuliert. Das ist nämlich nicht der Sinn der Friedensdenkschrift, sondern dass Argumente in einer Weise einmal in Verbindung gebracht werden, dass der einzelne Mensch sich mit Blick auf Krieg und Frieden, auf Gewaltanwendung und Gewaltverzicht seine eigene Meinung bilden kann.
Und das konntest du vorher übrigens nicht.
Ja, ich würde auch widersprechen. Ich habe es andersherum gehört, was du uns da vorgelesen hast.
Genau, da gibt es nämlich nur ein, da gibt es nicht, schauen sie mal, was sagt ihr Gewissen, sondern da geht es, es gibt sogar eine Pflicht, soll es sein eigentlich, dass man sich zum Wehrdienst meldet.
Aus meinem freien Gewissen wurde ein sehr schlechtes Gewissen gemacht, habe ich gehört.
Ja, weiter der Versuch, eine Antwort.
Wir leben doch in einer Zeit, wo viele Menschen sich nicht mehr auseinandersetzen, wo sozusagen, wenn man ein Argument hört, derjenige, der einem dieses Argument präsentiert, bereits in der Schublade des anderen sozusagen existiert.
Genau das, was in der Denkschrift passiert, da gibt es nämlich die Naiven, die Pazifisten und so was.
Die es noch nicht wissen.
Die sagen das nur diplomatischer. Wir wissen um die Errungenschaft der pazifistischen Friedensbewegungen, der bla bla bla bla bla, um dann zu sagen, aber, hört zu Leute, ihr Zwerppflicht.
Und dass es hier die Kirche ist, die die Argumente mehr oder weniger von unterschiedlichen Seiten beleuchtet, den Menschen etwas an die Hand gibt, nämlich sozusagen in der Perspektive des christlichen Glaubens, hier miteinander ins Gespräch zu kommen, mit sich und seinem Gewissen oder auch mit Freunden oder in der Familie, das ist eine große Leistung.
Und ich glaube, deshalb würde das hätte man ja vorher nicht tun können, über Beruflich diskutieren, ohne dass die Kirche was dazu sagt.
Danke, dass mir die Kirche die Erlaubnis gegeben hat, jetzt zu Hause darüber zu reden.
Diese Friedensdenkschrift auch wirklich wahrgenommen. Und natürlich ist der besondere christliche Aspekt, dass wir sagen, dass der Friede für den Christen sozusagen eine wesentliche Sache ist.
Und für andere Menschen ja nicht. Die meisten Menschen finden Frieden gar nicht so toll.
Das macht wirklich alles überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Weiß ja, über welchen Text hier er befragt wird.
Ja, das habe ich mich auch mehrmals geparkt. Jetzt Ende der Antwort.
Und von daher merken wir auch, dass wenn die evangelische Kirche in Deutschland eine Friedensdenk- schrift herausgibt, diese auch anders wahrgenommen wird, als wenn sie von irgendeiner anderen NGO oder sonstiger Institution oder Organisation auf den Markt gebracht wird.
Ja, also als ich das hörte, dass ihr diesen Text gemacht habt, habe ich gedacht, warum schreibt ihr sowas? Und nicht in den Sinn gekommen ist mir die Frage, warum schreibt das niemand sonst auch?
Nils Schneider-Jan fragt jetzt mal nach, was denn genau verteidigt wird. Das ist ja jetzt nach unseren ganzen Davos-Gesprächen auch interessant.
Und vielleicht nochmal zum Inhaltlichen. Sie haben jetzt diesen Begriff der rechtserhaltenden Gewalt eingeführt, über den bin ich bei der Lektüre auch immer wieder gestolpert. Weil mir scheint ja das eine zu sein, zu sagen, dass Gewalt in Ausnahmefällen notwendig ist, um unmittelbar noch schlimmere Gewalt zu verhindern. Zum Beispiel im Falle eines Genozids. Aber es ist ja doch noch mal was anderes zu sagen, Gewalt sei dann schon legitim, wenn sie notwendig ist, um das Territorium eines Staates zu verteidigen. Und das ist ja eigentlich das, was Sie dann mit diesem Begriff der rechtserhaltenden Gewalt meinen, oder?
Na ja, in dem Fall ist es ja die Auseinandersetzung. Vor allen Dingen, wenn man blickt auf den Krieg zwischen Russland und der Ukraine, hat die Ukraine das Recht der Selbstverteidigung. Und da muss man sagen, natürlich hat die Ukraine das Recht auf Selbstverteidigung. Und das hat natürlich was mit Anwendung von Gewalt zu tun. Dass man sozusagen dem anderen nicht erlaubt, sein Territorium einfach zu nehmen.
Ja, aber das ist ja keine Frage für die evangelische Kirche.
Genau. Also das ist ja nun zentraler Bestandteil. Immer, wenn es darum geht. Dafür brauche ich keinen Beitrag der evangelischen Kirche.
Die evangelische Kirche muss sich damit auseinandersetzen. Dann kann man Menschen zum Töten schicken oder Menschen schicken, dass sie dort sterben. Aber das war ja jetzt nicht eine Frage, die sich erstmal für die evangelische Kirche stellte.
Trotzdem ist ja nicht nur die rechtserhaltende Gewalt ein wichtiger Begriff in dieser Denkschrift, sondern auch der des gerechten Friedens, mit dem sie ja versuchen oder mit dem die Kirche versucht, zu beschreiben, dass es Situationen geben kann, in denen zwar keine unmittelbare Gewalt herrscht, aber trotzdem der Friede noch nicht nachhaltig ist. Und da geht es dann auch um soziale Gerechtigkeit, da geht es um Pluralität der Meinung, da geht es grundsätzlich darum, dass es eine liberale, menschenrechtskonforme Demokratie geben muss, damit es ein nachhaltiger Frieden ist. Aber da scheint mir ja doch so ein kleiner Widerspruch vorzuherrschen, weil dieser gerechte Frieden herrscht ja in fast keinem Land, das wir gerade auf dieser Welt sehen. In der Ukraine wahrscheinlich vor dem Krieg nicht, aber auch in Deutschland haben wir ja durchaus große Defizite, was soziale Ungleichheit, was Armut angeht. Das heißt, obwohl man diesen gerechten Frieden eigentlich nicht sieht, legitimiert man dann trotzdem die Gewaltanwendung, um den Status quo aufrechtzuerhalten. Ist es nicht ein grundsätzlicher Widerspruch in dieser Denkschrift?
Die Antwort?
Also ich finde, das ist erst mal Wesentliches zu sagen. Friede ist mehr als die Abwesenheit von Gewalt. Aber der Schutz vor Gewalt ist etwas, was wesentlich ist, um überhaupt gerechten Frieden entfalten lassen zu können. Es gibt ja...
Also der Weg ist, erstmal müssen wir jetzt kämpfen. Aber dann sollte man schon perspektivisch den Leuten in Davos klar machen, dass wir jetzt mal gerne soziale Gerechtigkeit und Umverteilung hätten. Weißt du, die lange Sicht denn.
Viele, die sagen, Hauptsache Friede. Wann ist denn da endlich mal Friede? Und jeder von uns kann nachvollziehen, dass sozusagen der Wunsch nach Frieden, also auf gut Deutsch nach Ruhe, dass das Sperben aufhört. Ja, genau. Sozusagen, dass Ruhe herrscht. Das ist sozusagen für das eigene Gewissen gut, für die eigene Seele gut. Und natürlich, dass Menschen nicht mehr sterben.
Genau, für die Menschen, die dann nicht mehr leben müssen.
Das ist selbstverständlich.
Aber so eine Ruhe, also ist es nicht ein bisschen wenig, wenn man einfach nicht sterben will? Also das finde ich jetzt ein bisschen dürftig, dürfte ein bisschen mehr sein. Da kommt natürlich jetzt der Satz, den wir schon eine Million Mal gehört haben.
Die Frage ist nur, wird es die Fortschritte so geben, dass Russland wirklich einlenkt und dann zu welchem Preis? And that is ultimately etwas, was am Ende vor allen Dingen die Ukraine entscheiden muss.
Ja, wir wissen.
Wer ist die Ukraine? Von außen beobachtet sind wir alle die Deutschen.
Ja.
Selbst in Frankfurt, ja, ich meine, schaut man sich einmal Kommunalpolitik an, ist es dahin mit der Einheit.
Naja.
Also diese Idee von wir die Deutschen, die Ukrainer, entscheiden hier irgendwas und so.
Das ist ja völlig.
Wo leben denn diese Leute?
Wo wir jetzt mal die Zahlen hatten von 300.000 Residenten während des gesamten Krieges. Wie ist es eigentlich, das ist mir auch damals aufgefallen, als ich die Denkschrift las mit dem Neust-Konflikt, der war ja da doch sehr unterrepräsentiert, wird auch mal nachgehakt.
Aber es sind ja zum Teil auch die blauen Länder in ihrem Bild, die liberal sind.
Also die blauen sind die Liberalen. So hat er jetzt das mal uns ein bisschen die Weltkarte erklären wollen.
Die demokratischen Länder, die für Kriege verantwortlich sind, die auch für Kriegsverbrechen verantwortlich sind. Zum Beispiel der Gaserkrieg, der in der Denkschrift relativ wenig Raum einnimmt. Herrscht da ein gerechter Friede? Und deswegen schaut man da als evangelische Kirche gar nicht so genau hin?
Die evangelische Kirche schaut sehr intensiv auf diesen Konflikt mit all seinen Schwierigkeiten. Wir haben selbst auch immer als evangelische Kirche uns in Gaza über entwicklungspolitische Handlungen engagiert. Wir haben sozusagen palästinensische Christen und Christen dort. Sie erinnern sich, dass auch Kirchenvertreter in den Gaza-Streifen gegangen sind. Ich selbst habe früher im Entwicklungsministerium gearbeitet. Ich war damals mit meinem Entwicklungsminister Gerd Müller im Gaza-Streifen selbst. Ich weiß, wie es dort aussieht. Aber das sind Situationen, wo eben die Frage nach gerechtem Frieden wirklich sozusagen wesentlich ist. Und man muss natürlich auch immer wieder sich klarmachen. Israel ist überfallen worden. Es hat eine riesen Anzahl von Opfern gegeben, von Geiseln. Diese Region ist wirklich in dieser Hinsicht toxisch und es ist schwer zu lösen.
Hast du jetzt eine Antwort bekommen?
Nein. Und ich möchte anmerken, wenn du mit Gerd Müller im Gaza-Streifen warst, weißt du nicht, wie es dort aussieht.
Ja.
Denn das ist Geschichte, was du da gesehen hast.
Stehen da ja und frag noch mal nach, wie war das denn jetzt mit den Waffentieferungen?
Aber noch mal konkret, also Deutschland hat Israel jetzt über Jahre hinweg mit Waffen unterstützt und damit ein Land unterstützt, dem von vielen Fällen vorgeworfen wird, ein Genozid zu begehen, die zumindest auch völkerrechtswidrige Angriffe auf verschiedene andere Länder gefahren haben. Halten sie das für richtig?
Wesentlich ist, dass wir im Nahen Osten in Israel immerhin noch einen demokratischen Staat haben, mit all den Schwierigkeiten, der sozusagen dort zu benennen ist. Und die evangelische Kirche hat ja immer sehr, sehr deutlich sich auch zum Thema Waffenlieferung positioniert. Und von daher ist es und bleibt es eine komplexe und schwierige Situation in dieser Region.
Ich habe da mal nachgeschaut. Ich habe diese Deutlichkeit auch gar nicht mehr gesehen. Und da ging es dann auch eher so darum, also Waffen bitte nur dann, wenn nicht ein Genozid verübt wird. Also genau die Position, die Deutschland immer so eingenommen hat. So, da macht er aber nichts Schlimmes mit, wenn wir das schicken.
Würdest du immer noch sagen, es ist bei solchen Themen, Krieg und Frieden, sehr viel wichtiger mit den Autoren, Menschen, von Texten, die wichtig sind, zu reden? Oder sollte man sich bei Fragen, die man selber so hat, aufgrund von Fernseh-Schauerlebnissen, mit Gemini ins Benehmen setzen, um zu fragen, was da vor sich geht?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage, denn wir sprechen ja jetzt über dieses Interview auf Grundlage dessen, dass ich ja diesen ganzen Text gelesen habe und dir dann in Auszügen referiert habe, habe ja auch einige Dinge vorgelesen dort, haben ja fast eine halbe Stunde darüber gesprochen, sind also jetzt gut geprieft für dieses Gespräch und können das natürlich jetzt alles einordnen und sagen, ja das ergibt ja alles hinten und vorne keinen Sinn und haben noch einen Moderator, der das auch gut gelesen hat und die entsprechenden Fragen stellt. Tatsächlich bekommen wir in dem Gespräch nur Material, um hier im Podcast das nochmal...
Wir machen uns in der fünften Stunde darüber lustig, was die evangelische Kirche sagt.
Ja, aber wir wären natürlich besser bedient, wenn wir jetzt Gemini den Text geben und sagen, wie steht eigentlich die evangelische Kirche zum Neustkrieg? Und dann würde da stehen, ja, nö, also da sind die jetzt nicht so.
Es ist ein bisschen wie bei medizinischen Fragestellungen. Man kann die dann ohne Rücksicht auf der Andere ist eine Person und fällt Urteile über mich. Einfach ganz ehrlich sagen, wo der Schuh drückt. Und dann kommt man auch nach vorne. So.
Ja, ja, ja. Jetzt gleich noch Felmberg unterscheidet zwischen der Kirche früher und heute.
Hier sagen, es geht nicht, dass ein Krieg legitimiert wird. Und das tun wir als evangelische Kirche in Deutschland natürlich vor dem Hintergrund unserer eigenen Geschichte. Auch das ist ja Wahrheit. Wir waren ja viele Jahrhunderte, könnte man fast sagen, immer auf Seiten des Staates und haben in Weltkrieg I und II auch Dinge gemacht, die uns sozusagen mit Grund danach haben davon Abstand nehmen lassen.
Aber sind Sie nicht jetzt wieder auf der Seite des Staates?
Wir reagieren allergisch, wenn man sozusagen uns zeigen möchte, wie sozusagen diese Allianz läuft. Wir sind, und das ist sozusagen, finde ich, das Wesentliche, wir haben früher Angriffskriege mit unterstützt. Und jetzt stehen wir für eine Demokratie, die ihre Freiheit verteidigen möchte. Ich glaube, das ist was ganz anderes.
Zugestanden? Kleiner Fortschritt.
Kleiner Fortschritt. Allerdings mit dem Angreifen ist das so eine Sache bei Präventivschlägen. Das ist der letzte Clip jetzt.
Dann wundere ich mich schon, dass der Friedensdenkgriff steht, wenn der Erwerb von Massenvernichtungswaffen unmittelbar bevorsteht und alle diplomatischen Mittel erschöpft sind, kann eine militärische Reaktion als Selbstverteidigung gegen einen unmittelbar bevorstehenden Angriff betrachtet werden. Das wäre ja in dem Fall ein Präventivschlag.
Also ich sehe uns mitnichten, in der Situation einen Präventivschlag zu führen, sondern so wie es in der Bundeswehr und in der Bundesliga Deutschland auch der Fall ist, eine rein defensive Situation zu beschreiben und das finde ich auch angemessen.
Ja, dann darf man ja nicht reinschreiben, dass man für Präventivschläge ist. Also, da war ja jetzt nicht die Frage. Halten Sie das für wahrscheinlich, dass wir nächstes Jahr einen Präventivschlag mal verüben? Nee, das war nicht die Frage.
Das ist einfach dumm, aber sehr gut.
Wir kommen dem Ende entgegen.
Ja, du möchtest einen Clip spielen, den ich kenne?
Ja, denn wir...
Wärst du auch sehr gut?
Ja, wir haben ja The Meritocracy Trap gelesen und haben da gelernt, okay...
Lass uns das doch gleich koppeln. Ich möchte eine Person des Monats ausrufen. Und es läuft im Grunde auf die Pointe hinaus. Denn ich denke, klar, ihr habt eure beiden Lieblingspodcaster, Wolfgang und Stefan, aber es gibt ja noch andere Publizisten. Und ich suche mir jetzt jeden Monat, nicht zwingend Publizisten, aber es ist schon eine gewisse Präferenz. Und ihr werdet auch gleich hören, warum, weil eigene Website und so. Und ich werde jetzt jeden Monat eine Person besonders hervorrufen, völlig ohne Kontext. Wer sich dann fragt, wo ist denn jetzt der Aufhänger dafür? Er, wir sind hier nicht beim MDR. Wir machen hier Sachen ohne konkreten Aufhänger. We say einfach nur coole Typen. Das ist in diesem Fall der Markus Begedahl. Denn er ist eine prägende Figur in unserem zivilgesellschaftlichen Leben. Solange wir es noch haben. Denn er ist Typusunternehmer. Wir wissen ja Worte vielleicht nicht mehr lange. Unsere Domäne muss man organisieren. Und wir brauchen hier solche politischen Unternehmer, die nicht auf die Einladung warten, sondern die Bühne schaffen, auf der sie dann Politiker einladen. Das ist zum Beispiel die Republika. Wir machen es ja auch immer wieder drüber lustig, was da stattfindet. Aber in diesem ganzen Wirrwarr an selbst die Bundeswehr hält da noch eine Gulaschkanone hin und so. Es finden ja trotzdem immer wieder Bühnenpräsenzen statt, die eben, und das ist das Besondere, nicht auf der Bühne der Politiker, sondern die verlassen ihre Bühne und kommen dann rüber und so. Ich verstehe zwar nicht, warum dann ein öffentlich-rechtlicher Moderator die Fragen stellen muss an Merz, wenn er da ist, aber gut, das Problem können wir ja noch lösen. Auf jeden Fall lesen, netzpolitik.org hat er ja 20 Jahre lang gemacht, damals mit gegründet, dann Digitale Gesellschaft und heute eben dieses Zentrum für Digitalrechte, also digitalrechte.de ist die Anlaufstelle. Denn dort erfährt man all das, was wir vorhin auch kurz angeschnitten haben. Jemand hält dir ein Handy ins Gesicht und sagt, du gehörst hier nicht her und du denkst, in meinem Pass steht ein anderes und das Handy sagt, ich bin Trumpf, ich übertrumpfe dich. Außerdem, Markus Becke Dahl, ist ein Überlebender von Landesverrats-Ermittlungen. Diese Geschichte ist wahnsinnig interessant, denn kommt noch alle 50 Jahre vor. Karl von Osiecki 1931, damals Weltbühnenprozess, wirklich eine Tragödie, weil echte Haft. Und dann brach auch noch die Weimarer Republik zusammen und der ist quasi vom Gefängnis ins KZ gekommen. Willy Brandt hat sich dann noch für den Nobelpreis stark gemacht im Exil. Rudolf Augstein, 1962, zu ähnlichen Text, nämlich man schreibt mal über die Wertfähigkeit, Tüchtigkeit, wie auch immer. Rudolf Augstein saß damals auch im Gefängnis, über 100 Tage U-Haft und so, aber dann musste Strauß als Verteidigungsminister gehen. Bei Markus Becke da, 2015, war es zum Glück nur noch eine Farce. Die Ermittlungen kamen auf, alle so Maßen. Damals noch in Amt und Würden, warum auch immer. Also danke liebe CDU für den Scheiß. Aber damals ran er ja zurückgetreten oder wurde in Vorrat-Stand gesetzt, wie auch immer. Und deswegen lesen netzpolitik.org, ständige Berichterstattung, Digitalrechte, da wo es ein bisschen heikel wird. Da steht wirklich alles drin zum DSA, DMA und so weiter. Und wie das jetzt mit TikTok in Amerika weitergeht und so. Und jetzt kannst du uns sagen, ab wann man Ivy League ist. Super League ist.
Ja, wir haben es ja gelernt. Die Superreichen, so steht es bei Daniel Markowitz, geben 10 Millionen Dollar pro Kind mehr aus als die Mittelklasse. So hat das mal hochgerechnet. Wir denken, meine Güte, was sind das für geniale Köpfe, die dort sein müssen an diesen Elite-Universitäten. Adam Toos auch bei einer Davos-Veranstaltung mit Studenten wird dann aus dem Publikum von einer jungen Frau gefragt, was er denn empfehlen kann, wenn man auch Ivy League sein will. Und wir machen ja solche Angebote, glaube ich, wie das, was Adam Toos da vorsteigt.
So they can achieve the type of success that they want.
I mean, so many people have iterated in different ways, but it's a sustained attention. The ability to sustain prolonged, serious attention to a text, to read, to think, to a problem, to solve. It means learning your own internal rhythms. Like, where does your spirit go? Where does your mind wander to? How do you contain that? How do you manage it? And that, I think, is the absolutely key thing. And it is rare, and it's difficult. And it takes habit. And it's a kind of training. It's like learning to play an instrument or perform well in sport. And it requires a kind of bravery. Because you have to be willing to be lonely. You have to be willing to be on your own. You have to be on your own with your own thoughts. Not constantly just in the loop with the thing that's feeding your prejudice, but actually pursuing your own thread. Challenge students to read for half an hour solidly, then 45 minutes, then an hour and so on from there. Once they've gotten up to several hours, they're already in the Super League.
Wenn man ein paar Stunden liest, ist man in der Super League. Und ich würde sagen, das stimmt.
Das stimmt auf jeden Fall.
Dass man das nochmal da eigens betonen muss, sagt auch viel. Wir werden also etwas lesen, dann darüber diskutieren. Zerfall der Weltordnung, die Ignoranz des Westens und der Aufstand des globalen Südens von Patrick Kaschmarczyk. Dieses Buch erscheint jetzt gerade. Wir sind sehr gespannt darauf, denn die Ungleichheit und die Doppelstandards der Welt, die destabilisieren, sagt dieses Buch. Er ist ja wirklich ein profunder Kenner, der auch sehr gute Beiträge geschrieben hat. Auch übrigens einen zusammen mit Adam Tosia zu Nahost, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. In der Zeit war das. Also ein Buch, da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Ich will noch gar nicht verraten, was ich mitbringe. Ich habe so ein paar Dinge dort liegen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du schon was ausgeguckt hast. Hast du schon Empfehlungen?
Mir wurde ein Buch zugespielt, das ich vom Titel her sehr mag. Ich komme nie mehr auf den Titel, aber es ist egal. Da steht einfach drauf, bitte nicht über Politik reden.
Ah, das ist interessant.
Ja, bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Also wir greifen es auf jeden Fall auf.
Das alles werden wir dann im Salon sehr ausführlich besprechen. Der Salon dauert auch immer so drei bis vier Stunden. Also wir lassen uns Zeit dafür, wollen da tief reingehen in die Werke. Wer das hören will, kann das Ganze einfach abonnieren über Apple, Patreon und was wir präferieren ist. Daddy geht einfach alle auch sowieso mal auf die neu gestaltete Seite. Stefan und seine KI-Freunde haben diese Seite doch auf ein ganz anderes Level gehoben.
Ja und ich habe ja vorhin gesagt, wir spielen noch Erbschaftsteuer-Clips. Die sind allerdings so spektakulär, weil Robin Alexander ganz Feuer und Flamme für den SPD-Vorschlag ist. Das wird es dann vor dem Salon immer.
Na, bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Dann sehen wir uns in der nächsten Woche und hoffentlich im Salon neuzwanziger.de. So lautet die Seite. Alles Gute bis dahin.